GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE ON CLIMATE CRISIS
RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION. THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND FOREST
HEALTH. I'LL BEGIN BY READING
THAT- ARE TYPICAL DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION
. WE HAVE TWO PANELISTS WHO WILL
BE PARTICIPATING IN PERSON WITH
THE REST OF OUR- PANELISTS
TESTIFYING REMOTELY FOR THE
PUBLIC- WHO ARE HERE IN THE ROOM
WE ARE IN FORT ROOM FORTY TWO-
TO. HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT
IN PERSON HEARING. AND CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN. KEEP
SIXTIES SIXTY OF SPACING. THERE
ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ALL RESTATE
THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT BEGINS
BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK.
THEY SHOULD RAISE THEIR HANDS
AND I'LL ASK THEM TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC RESPECT FOR THE CALL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN YOUR
SEAT. BUT PLEASE OBSERVE.
PHYSICAL DISTANCE UPON LEAVING
THE CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. WITH RESPECT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THIS
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD. BE
ALSO ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
PHONE NUMBER IS PUBLIC- IT'S
PUBLIC NUMBER TOLL FREE. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE THAT YOU'LL
NEED TO. INPUT IS.
1-315-420-2131 FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO I'LL REPEAT THIS
INFORMATION LATER FOOD DIDN'T
GET THAT- JUST NOW. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ASSIST YOU. WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING.
PLEASE SEND YOUR WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO BUDGET SUB THREE AT
ASM DOT CA DOT GOV. IT SAYS THAT
FEMALES WILL RECEIVE IT EVEN AS
THE HEARING IS GOING ON. TODAY
WE HAVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER- WHO IS SAID- NOT A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE BUT- HIS
DISTRICT HAS BEEN HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRES THAT WERE-PLEASED TO WELCOME HIM HERE TO-
A LISTEN TO THE PRESENTATION AND
ASK QUESTIONS- AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WE WILL LEARN
ABOUT HOW THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION OF FORCE TELL FUNDING
PLAN THAT HISTORIC AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT WE- ALLOCATED ONLY A
FEW SHORT MONTHS AGO. WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT HOW THAT'S PROGRESSING
FOLLOWED BY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MEMBERS TO ASK QUESTIONS OF OUR
PANELISTS AND ENDING WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. THIS YEAR WE WERE ABLE
TO APPROPRIATE CLOSE TO SEVEN
YEARS WORTH OF NORMAL SPENDING
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
COMMITTED TO A MINIMUM OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR THE NEXT SEVEN YEARS. BUT OF
COURSE DOLLARS AND NO ONE ALONE
WILL NOT PREVENT WILDFIRES WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THESE FUEL
REDUCTION COMMUNITY. PROTECTION
PROJECTS ARE DONE IN A TIMELY
AND EQUITABLE MANNER. BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WITH THE PRESENTATION OF
OUR PANELISTS WOULD ANY OF OUR
OTHER MEMBERS LIKE TO PROVIDE
OPENING REMARKS SHOULD WELCOME
MR FONG- OUR BUDGET TO. VICE
CHAIR TO THE HEARING AND TO
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR- AND YOUR STAFF- FOR- FOR
GETTING HIS HEARING- ON THE
SCHEDULE- I KNOW THIS HEARING
HAS TAKEN A LOT OF COORDINATION
AND APPRECIATE IF IT EVER OF
YOURSELF IN THE COMMITTEE IN THE
PALACE- AND THE STAFF TO
RESCHEDULE COME TOGETHER AND ONE
OF THE LAST HEARINGS. HERE IN
THE CAPITOL ANNEX- THAT THE
HARSH WILDFIRES THAT BURNED ALL
LAST SUMMER DESTROYED ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES. HAVE UP LOW WE'VE
EXPERIENCED LIGHT LIVES LOST.
I'M IT WAS THAT EXPERIENCE. THAT
ARE PUT RISK. OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION- WAS COOLEY THE
PRIORITY. BUT NOW WE NEED TO
PLAN FOR THE NEXT WILDFIRE
SEASON WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WE ARE- WHERE WE WERE AND
WHERE WE NEED TO BE. AT
WILDFIRES. NATURALLY OCCUR BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE DISASTROUS
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
CATASTROPHIC. WE WANT QUALIFIERS
THAT ARE LESS DESTRUCTIVE. THE
STATE IS EXPECTING ANOTHER YEAR
OUT WITH A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SURPLUSES- THIS GIVES THE
GOVERNOR. AND THE LEGISLATURE-
THE ABILITY. TO CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
AT THE CONSUMING IS FUNDING- IS
A START BUT THERE ARE STILL
MILLIONS OF ACRES LEFT TO TREAT-
AND THERE IS STILL FAR TOO MUCH
FUEL READY TO BURN. THE STATE IS
FACING IS SORT DROUGHT RESULTING
IN BONE DRY SHRUBS AND TREES AND
FUELS IN OUR FORCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES- AND WE NEED TO ACT
WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY- DURING
THIS WINDOW THAT WE NOW HAVE TO
PREPARE. THE DEVASTATION WE HAVE
SEEN HERE AND YOU'RE OUT. MUST
STOP AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
PALACE- AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK QUESTIONS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MR GALLAGHER COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT- WE WILL
NOW WELCOME OUR FIRST PANELISTS
WHO IS HELEN CHRISTIAN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
MORNING AND MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
AT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE I'M GONNA BE SPEAKING
FROM A PRESENTATION WHICH I WAS
GONNA LOAD RIGHT NOW. HOPEFULLY
YOU CAN SEE THAT ON YOUR SCREEN
AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THESE
SLIDES ARE POSTED ON THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES
BACKSIDE. PROPOSED YOU'RE
FOLLOWING ALONG AT HOME AS WELL
. AFTER THAT THE STAGE FOR THIS
HEARING BY PROVIDING SOME
BACKGROUND INFORMATION I'M GONNA
START MY PRESENTATION WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF INFORMATION ON
WILDFIRES MORE GENERALLY AND
THEN I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT RECENT WILDFIRES SPENDING.
I'M NOT SPECIFICALLY TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF THE
RECENT BUDGET ACTIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN. IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO INCREASE
WELFARE RESILIENCE. SO THIS
FIRST. SHOWS REALLY FOLLOW THEM
LARGEST AND MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES HAVE. AND HAVE BEEN
CONCENTRATED IN THE LAST FEW
DECADES SO THIS GOES BACK TO
NINETEEN THE NINETEEN THIRTIES
WHEN WE STARTED. REALLY
COLLECTING THIS DATA AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT- IF WE LOOK AT THE
LARGEST THE TWENTY LARGEST AND
TWENTY MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES. ARE THE BOTH OF THEM
HAVE HAPPENED IN RECENT DECADES
AND ACTUALLY IT'S PRETTY.
DRAMATIC HERE EIGHTEEN OF THAT
AT THAT TWENTY MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES HAVE OCCURRED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND. AND FULLY SEVEN AM
OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE TWENTY
WITH INSTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES WHAT
HAPPENED JUST IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SO WE'VE REALLY SEEN A
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE
DESTRUCTIVE ABOUT PRIOR TO THE
STATE HAS EXPERIENCED. THIS NEXT
SLIDE SHOWS A MAP OF CALIFORNIA
WITH THOSE TWENTY AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE LARGEST WILDFIRES ON
THE LOCATIONS AND THAT'S WHAT
MATTERS. AND THESE ARE THE ONES
THAT OCCURRED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND. AND YOU CAN SEE HOW
THIS IS IN A REGIONAL PROBLEM
IT'S NOT JUST A LOCAL PROBLEM
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT AFFECTS A
WIDE SWATH OF THE STATE. AND OF
COURSE THE IMPACTS OF WILDFIRES
EXTEND BEYOND JUST THE BORDERS
OF THE WILDFIRES- AS WE ALL
EXPERIENCED IN RECENT YEARS-
WELL THE MOST OF YOUR IMPACTS
OUR COMMUNITY AREAS THAT BRING
THEMSELVES- IMPACTED AS SMOKE
THAT CAN EXTEND WELL BEYOND THE
BORDERS OF WILDFIRES THAT REALLY
THIS IS THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR THE STATE SET TO
TACKLE. THIS NEXT SLIDE SHOWS
STATE SPENDING ON HEALTH FIRE
AND HOW IT'S GOING TO BRING
ABOUT THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS AND
YOU CAN SEE IT'S PRETTY DRAMATIC
FROM ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION. TO THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SO- IT'S REALLY GROWN PRETTY
DRAMATICALLY. THIS FIGURE BREAKS
OUT HELLFIRE AND THE CALPERS
BUDGET INTO THREE MAIN
CATEGORIES. BASED FIRE
PROTECTION AND YOU CAN SEE THAT-
HAS PRETTY STEADILY INCREASED
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS OR
SO- EMERGENCY FIRE SUPPRESSION
AND THAT'S BASICALLY WHEN
FIGHTERS EXCEED THE INITIAL
ATTACK SO WHEN WE HAVE LARGER
WILDFIRES- AND HEALTHCARE NEEDS
TO IT TO ADD SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO FIGHT THOSE. AND
YOU CAN SEE THAT VARIES FROM
YEAR TO YEAR AND THAT'S NOT
SURPRISING ON MANY YEARS WE HAVE
PARTICULARLY SEVERE WILDFIRES WE
SEE- ABOUT THE NET EMERGENCY
FIRE SUPPRESSION SPENDING. AND
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT FIRE
PREVENTION AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
THAT WAS PRETTY STEADY FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND IT'S
INCREASED IN RECENT YEARS WITH
THE ADDITION OF FUNDS FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND-
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS. AND
THAT'S REALLY THAT THIS LIFE
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT FOCUSING ON AT THIS AND
THIS HEARING- AND IT IS NOTABLE
THAT IT'S AND WE'VE MADE. A LOT
OF ADDITIONAL- INVEST
INVESTMENTS IN THAT AREA OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS- BUT
IT'S STILL IT'S A RELATIVELY
SMALL SHARE I'M STILL FIRE
PROTECTION AND FIRE SUPPRESSION
ARE. ARE LARGER AND IN IN IN
TOTAL SO- HOPEFULLY IT GETS A
LITTLE BIT OF HISTORICAL CONTEXT
NOW I'M GONNA TALK JUST A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE FUNDING. THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THERE TO. PACKAGES THAT WERE BY
THE LATEST IN FOR TWENTY ONE.
THE FIRST ONE AS- AND EARLY
ACTION WHILE. PASS THAT WEIGHS A
- IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT PROVIDED FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION FOR A VARIETY
OF WILDFIRE RESILIENCE PROGRAMS.
ACROSS THE STATE TO EUROPE ABOUT
TWO DOZEN DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
ACROSS ABOUT FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS. THAT WAS THE
FUNDING AND REALLY THAT FUNDING
WAS- IN ADDITION TO THE FUNDING
IS PROVIDED IN A TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET- BUT IT WAS
REALLY PART OF THAT BUDGET THAT
WITH ANOTHER ON PETITIONS THAT
BUDGET. MOST OF THE FUNDING WAS
PROVIDED FROM THE GENERAL FUND
SO IN TOTAL IT WAS I CAN
COMPLETE ABOUT TWO FOUR HUNDRED
ELEVEN MILLION THAT WAS PROVIDED
FROM THE GENERAL FUND. HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION WAS PROVIDED
FROM G. G. R. AFTER GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND. AND THE IDEA
BEHIND THAT WAS TO BRING THE
TEACHER OF SPENDING TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
CONSISTENT WITH SB NINE OH ONE.
AMEND THAT BILL HAD. INDICATED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
INTENDED TO SPEND TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. ANNUALLY
FOR FIVE YEARS. AND THEN THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE ALSO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE REASON WHY IT WASDONE AS AN
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE WISE. BUT
THE GOAL IS TO GET THE FINDING
OUT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THAT WAS
TO DEDICATE THE FUNDS TOWARDS
PROJECT THAT WE'RE BASICALLY
READY TO GO. AND I CAN GET
STARTED IMMEDIATELY AND THAT WAY
AND THOSE PROJECT THE IDEA WOULD
BE THAT THIS PROJECT WOULD BE IN
PLACE ROUGHLY A YEAR SOONER THAN
THEY WOULD BE OTHERWISE AND IF.
THE FUNDING HAD BEEN AND HAD
BEEN INCLUDED IN A TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET. AND
I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET- THAT WAS ANOTHER.
HISTORIC AUGMENTATION SO THAT
BUDGET PROVIDED AN ADDITIONAL
NINE HUNDRED. AND EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR A WIDE
RANGE OF PROGRAMS- ABOUT THIRTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS MANAGED BY
ABOUT EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT
APARTMENTS. AGAIN MOST OF THAT
MONEY WAS GOING TO GENERAL FUND.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION. A TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION WAS FROM TEACHER AT. ARE
THERE A COUPLE OTHER IMPORTANT
ASPECTS AND THAT PACKAGE. SEVEN
THERE WAS A TRAILER BILL THAT
ADDED LANGUAGE THE CONTINUING.
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATES. I
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. I'M STARTING IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE THREE
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE SO- I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE MENTIONED THAT.
BEFORE BUT IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THAT- BUDGET
PACKAGE I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
AGAIN. I THE BUDGET. INCLUDED
SOME REPORT LANGUAGE WE THINK IS
REALLY I'M REALLY BURKE
HIGHLIGHTING AS WELL. AND THAT
REPORTING LINK LANGUAGE REQUIRES
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTRATION
EXCUSE ME TO PROVIDE CERTAIN
INFORMATION ON ALL OF THAT. A
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE FUND THAT
WERE PROVIDED BOTH IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY DEAL AS
WELL AS THE EARLY ACTION MONEY
THAT WAS PROVIDED IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BUT WILL ELP
LEGISLATURE. I UNDERSTAND WHAT
WAS FUNDED IT WITH THOSE- THOSE
DOLLARS AND- WHAT WHAT AND WHAT
WE REALLY GOT FROM FROM ALL THAT
HISTORIC INVESTMENT. SO THE NEXT
FIGURED THIS IS BY CATEGORY BUT
THIS REALLY SHOWS THOSE EARLY
ACTION AND BUDGET ACT- PACKAGES.
AND IT BREAKS IT OUT BY
CATEGORIES THERE ARE FIVE MAIN
CATEGORIES THAT RECEIVED
FUNDING. YOU CAN SEE THE FUNDS
WERE APPROPRIATED AS WELL AS
THE- PERCENTAGES HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED BASS BAR. AND IT'S I
THINK THERE ARE A FEW THINGS I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT ABOUT THIS
FIGURE FOR YOU- WHAT YOU CAN SEE
HOW THE FUNDING WAS DISTRIBUTED
AMONG THOSE GUYS MAIN CATEGORIES
OF EXPENDITURES IN THIS AREA.
YOU CAN SEE THAT MOST OF THE
FUNDING FOR BOTH PACKAGES WENT
TO RESILIENT FORESTS AND
LANDSCAPES SURPRISE SO PROGRAMS
THAT REALLY EMPHASIZE THAT. ON
THE SECOND LARGEST SHARE WAS FOR
WILDFIRE FUEL BREAKS- AND THEN
THEY WERE SMALLER DOLLAR
APPLICATIONS FOR COMMUNITY
HARDENING. FOR SECTOR ECONOMIC.
STIMULUS AND SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT- YOU CAN ALSO SEE.
THAT A LARGE FRACTION OF A LARGE
SHARE OF THE EARLY ACTION
FUNDING HAS BEEN COMMITTED
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT. AND A
SMALLER SHARE OF THAT OF THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
THAT'S PART ONLY SEVEN PERCENT-
NOW THAT'S NOT REALLY
SURPRISING. FOR A COUPLE REASONS
WHY OF COURSE THE BUDGET- THE
BUDGET ACTION BUT LATER IN THE
YEAR THAN THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE BUT ALSO. THERE REALLY
ACTION PACKAGE AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
PROJECTS THAT WERE READY TO GO
AND THE IDEA WAS THAT THOSE
COULD BE COMMITTED VERY QUICKLY
AND SO IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT
WE SAW THOSE DOLLARS. HE
COMMITTED MORE QUICKLY. WITH
THAT WITH A BUDGET ALLOCATION
THE IDEA WAS THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT FUNDING WOULD PROBABLY BE
USED OVER AND OVER A-
POTENTIALLY A PERIOD OF A FEW
YEARS. AND SO IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS HAVE HAVEN'T. BEEN
COMMITTED YET. I'M YOU CAN ALSO
SEE THAT. THERE'S VARIATION IN
THE PERCENT THAT'S BEEN
COMMITTED CATEGORIES SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT. OVERALL AND HIGHER
SHARE HAS BEEN COMMINGLED FOR
THEIR RESILIENT FORESTS AND
LANDSCAPES CATEGORY IN THE
WILDFIRE FUEL BREAKS CATEGORY.
AS WELL AS A SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT CATEGORY- THEN FOR
EXAMPLE THE COMMUNITY HARDENING
AND THE FOUR SECTORS STIMULUS
CATEGORIES. SO WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT YOU CAN GET THE
OVERALL PICTURE. AND THEN THE
NEXT TWO FIGHTS BREAK THESE
CATEGORIES OUT INTO THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS. THAT'S THAT
WAY YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE'S
SOME. SEPARATION AND LOOK AT A
DIFFERENT STORY FOR CHRISTMAS.
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. HELLO THIS IS
FIRST HALF OF THE TWO PEOPLE
INTO TABLE TO SPEAK THERE IS-
THERE ARE A OF YOUR- PROGRAMS
AND WE CAN IT ALL AND ONE FIVE
AND HAVE IT BE. AN WHY. I'M HERE
YOU CAN SEE FOR WITHIN WITH. FOR
SOMEONE'S. OVER ON 93% OF THE
EARLY ACTION FUNDING HAS BEEN
COMMITTED THUS FAR. BUT THERE IS
VARIATION ACROSS DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
FOREST HEALTH PROGRAM- YOU KNOW.
ALL ABOUT FUNDING HAS BEEN
COMMITTED WHERE YOU CAN SEE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT AND YOU KNOW
RESOURCE NEEDS REFORESTATION
NURSERY. URBAN FORESTRY INTERVAL
AND GAUGE MEANT ON BEHALF I
THINK COMMITTEE YEAH. AND I DID
WANT TO NOTE HERE ALSO JUST ON
WHAT COMMITTED MEANS THAT
SOMETIMES THAT CAN BE A LITTLE
BIT OF A CONFUSING TERMS.
USUALLY THAT MEANS ALLOCATED TO
PROJECTS OR MEDIA GRANT
AGREEMENT SAYS IS SIGN THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS- IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT THE
PROJECT HAS HAS BEEN COMPLETED
SO COULD STILL TAKE SOME TIME
FOR THIS PROJECT. ACTUALLY THE
FULLY IN PLACE AND OPERATIONAL
BUT IT DOES MEAN THAT THAT THE
MONEY HAS BEEN. ALLOCATED AND
IT'S SORT OF YEAH. IT'S IN PLACE
AND DEDICATED. I SO THIS IS THE
FIRST HAPPEN AT. AND THEN THIS
HALF THE TABLE JUST SHOWS- AND
THE REMAINING PROGRAMS SO YOU
CAN SEE KIND OF THAT THE STATUS
OF THOSE AND THEN I. AM THE WAY
THAT THAT FUNDING IS GOING OUT
AS WELL. SEN AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY PRESENTATION I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS- THAT MANY
HEALTH. THANK YOU- CAN YOU OFFER
SOME- COMMENTS ARE JUST-
EXPLANATION WHY THERE'S SUCH A
DRAMATIC DIFFERENCE BETWEEN- IN
TERMS OF THE PERCENT COMMITTED
ON THE EARLY ACTION DOLLARS
BETWEEN RESILIENT FORESTS AND
FUEL BREAKS FOR EXAMPLE AND
COMMUNITY HARDENING IN THE FOR
SECTOR ECONOMIC STIMULUS THOSE
ARE PRETTY DRAMATIC. DROP OFFS.
YEAH AND THAT MAYBE SOMETHING
THAT- THAT THE MINISTRATION
WOULD BE BETTER POSITIONED AND
TO- TO TALK ABOUT BUT MIGHT I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS TECH AND
KNOWS IS THAT SOME OF A LOT OF
THE FUNDING IN THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE WENT TO ESTABLISH
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE
FOR SEVERAL YEARS- AND THAT. IN
GENERAL IT TENDS TO BE EASIER TO
GET THAT FINDING OUT A LITTLE
MORE QUICKLY- BUT THERE WERE
SOME FRIENDS THAT WENT TO
RELATIVELY NEW PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT HOME GARDENING A
LOT OF THAT COMMITTEE HARDENING
DOLLARS WERE RELATED TO THE HOME
GARDENING- PROGRAM AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S JUST BEING
LAUNCHED. SO AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE MORE
INFORMATION BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT IT'S TAKING SOME TIME TO
GET THAT PROGRAMS ARE UP AND
RUNNING AND FIGURE OUT ALL THE
DETAILS AND WORK WITH. DAVE
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO MATCHING
FUNDS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S I THINK TAKEN
SOMETIME AS WELL SO AGAIN THEY
THEY AY BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO
THAT MORE DEPTH BUT I THINK PART
OF IT IS JUST THAT CERTAIN
PROGRAMS. TAKE A LITTLE BIT
LONGER TO GET UP AND RUNNING-
AND THEN THEY MAY BE A MORE
ESTABLISHED PROGRAM MAKING. JUST
ANOTHER GRANT CYCLE OF. GREAT
THANK THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MR FONG. I THINK
REPORT FOR THE PRESENTATION- I
GUESS MY- BUT- TO PIGGYBACK OFF
WHAT THE CHAIR SAID IN HIS
OPENING REMARKS HOW WOULD YOU OR
THE L. A. L. OR HOW SHOULD WE AS
A LEGISLATURE AND EVALUATE. THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE FUNDING SO
WHAT IS SUCCESS. BUT WHAT WOULD
YOU DO AS SUCCESS. I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND I THINK IT'S I MEAN
ULTIMATELY I THINK ARE ALL HER
GOAL IS TO HAVE FOREST THAT ARE
THAT ARE RESILIENT AND HEALTHY
RIGHT AND THAT ARE LESS PRONE TO
SEVERE AND DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES- SO I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY THAT'S SORT OF THE
ULTIMATE GOAL IT'S- SOMETIMES
HARD TO MEASURE EXACTLY. EXACTLY
THAT BUT I THINK LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW HOW MANY AND HOW MANY
ANSWER WHICH TYPES OF YOUR ARE
WE MEETING OUR GOALS FOR I
TREATING ACRES AND ARE IN
RETREATING ACRES THAT ARE REALLY
PROTECTING AND COMMUNITIES AND
HAVING ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
IT'S PROBABLY A MIX OF THINGS
BUT I THINK THOSE ARE ALL I
THINK THE TYPES OF GOALS THAT-
RESISTING. AND CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATURE I'LL WANT TO AND
KEEP AN EYE ON AND I'M I THINK
THAT THEIR- WITH ITS REPORTING
LANGUAGE THEY'LL BE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL HELP THE
LEGISLATURE KEEP TRACK OF. OF
WHAT ACTUALLY IS BEING
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THIS FUNDING
AND WHETHER THAT'S HELPING TO
MEET THOSE GOALS SURE SO I GUESS
THAT THEN. THAT THE NEXT
QUESTION THEN IS. IN IN OVER.
THIS THE FUNDING AND WHAT WAS
WHAT HAS BEEN COMMITTED. DO YOU
HAVE THAT DATA TO OVERLAID WHAT
PROJECTS WERE DONE AND WHAT THEY
MIGHT OF ACRES THAT WERE TREATED
AND WHETHER THE CERTAIN AREAS OF
THE STATE HAVE IMPROVED- IN
TERMS OF HEALTHY FORCE. THOUGHT
THAT I'M LOOKING AT I MEAN I'M
LOOKING AT THE MAP THAT YOU'VE
GOT THE FIRST ONE WITH ALL THE-
THAT THE LIST OF THE FIRES I
MEAN. DO WE HAVE A LOOK WE HAVE
A LIST OF PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN FUNDED AND WHERE WHEN WHAT
AREAS THERE THERE ARE. SO WE DO
HAVE A LIST OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN FUNDED OF THE
MINISTRATION WAS KIND ENOUGH TO
PROVIDE AND A LIST OF THE
PROJECTS THAT THEY'VE COMMITTED
FUNDING TO- WE DO HAVE THAT LIST
WE HAVE NOT. AND THAT'S PRETTY
EARLY YOU KNOW BUT THE EARLY
ACTION PACKAGES WELL ANYWAY IT'S
BEEN COMMITTED THUS FAR ON THE-
ON THE BUDGET YEAR FUNDING.
pIT'S A LITTLE HARD IT'S PROBABLY
TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF AN- AN
EFFORT TO REALLY DRILL DOWN AND
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHERE EACH
PROJECT IS LOCATED. AND FIGURE
OUT I THINK THEN YOU HAVE TO DO
IS PROBABLY PRETTY COMPLEX AND
TO FIGURE OUT AND- EXACTLY WHICH
AREAS ARE COVERED- WE HAVEN'T
DONE THAT ANALYSIS BUT I. THINK
I'M- JUST AND LOOKING AT IT.
pPROJECTS THAT WERE FUNDED IN A
VARIETY OF AREAS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. MAY WELL HAVE.
MORE I HER ABOUT IT ON AND ON
EXACTLY DID YOU. JUST OF THE-
WELL MAYBE THAT'S THE- AB IF
THAT POSSIBLE TO DO AN AWESOME
INITIATION AS WELL BUT A BIT
OVERLAY- THE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN FUNDED AND COMPLETED OVER
THIS MAP THAT YOU'VE OUTLINED-
IN TERMS OF THE MOST DAMAGING
WILDFIRES SINCE TWO THOUSAND.
COULD BE INTERESTING TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY CORRELATION IN TERMS
OF WHETHER THEY WERE PROJECTS
THAT WERE DONE OR NOT DONE OR
CONTINUE TO BE DONE IN THE AREAS
THAT ARE HIGH PRONE FOR
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. IS THAT
POSSIBLE. YOUR STAFF HE
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE I WOULD
NOTE THAT THE PROJECT HAD BEEN
AND COMMITTED YOU KNOW THAT THAT
LIST THAT WE HAVE PROPOSED EARLY
ACTION PACKETS AND THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET. IN MANY
CASES AGAIN THOSE HAVE THE
PROJECT HAPPENS- THE SISTERLY
THEN COMPLETED SO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
RECEIVED FUNDING BY. AND THEY
MAY STILL BE IN. THE EARLY
STAGES SO IT'S NOT THAT THOSE
PROJECTS WOULD NECESSARILY. YOU
KNOW IT MAY TAKE A FEW YEARS FOR
THIS TO ACTUALLY HAPPEN BUT- BUT
YEAH WE CAN WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
AND SEE AND SEE WHAT'S
AVAILABLE. SURE I MEAN I GUESS
THAT THAT THE BROADER POINT IS
IT'S NOT JUST THE EARLY ACTION
PACKAGE. IT'S WHAT HAS BEEN DONE
. HISTORICALLY AND WHETHER THEY
WORK. BECAUSE IF THE STRATEGY-
WE DON'T GET WE DON'T HAVE A
STRATEGIC PLAN THAT'S WORKING
RIGHT WE WOULDN'T WANT TO
CONTINUE FUNDING. AS YOU GO PLAN
THAT ISN'T WORKING SO WE WANNA
KNOW WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S NOT
WORKING IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
YEAH AND I'M NOT SURE BUT
INSTEAD OF ALL ON THE ON EXACTLY
THE LOCATION OF ALL THE PAST
PROJECTS I'VE PROBABLY KNOW
THEY'RE AFRAID YOU FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN. JEFF
STATE FUNDING TO OF COURSE
THERE'S WORK ON PRIVATE LANDS
THAT HAPPENS- WITH REGARD TO
FOREST HEALTH AS WELL SO- SO
IT'S PROBABLY COMPLICATED TECH
TO SORT OF GET THAT FULL PICTURE
OF EXACTLY WHERE HISTORICAL
PROJECT- BUT- CERTAINLY OF. WITH
PLEASE ANYTHING THAT'S AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO YOU AS
AS YOU AS WE EVALUATE. THE
FINDINGS THAT THERE ARE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF A PRIVATE
WORK BEING DONE ON THE WORK
BEING DONE THE FEDERAL LANDS. AS
WELL AS THE STATE- FACILITIES
AND SO WE WANT TO. TO BE ABLE TO
GAUGE AS YOU SAID. THE NUMBER OF
ACRES TREATED OVERLAY IT WITH
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S BEEN
SPENT AND SEE. IF WE'RE GETTING
THE MOST BANG FOR OUR BUCK SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THE- BUT THE
BACK AND FORTH AND- I'LL TURN
BACK UP TO THE CHECK. THANK YOU
AT- SPEAKING OF- OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES- AND NEEDS WHEN IT
COMES TO WELFARE PREVENTION
THERE IS CURRENTLY A DEBATE
GOING ON IN CONGRESS- AROUND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
EXACTLY THAT PURPOSE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM-
SPEAKERS- WHO MAY HAVE KNOWLEDGE
OF- OUR LOBBYING EFFORTS TO SEE
TO IT THAT- THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIA- ARE MAXIMIZED.
IN THAT REGARD IT'S- I DON'T
THINK THE SECRET TO ANYBODY
THAT- THERE'S A- AT A
SIGNIFICANT LACK OF- INVESTMENT
IN WILDFIRE PREVENTION ON ALL
FRONTS- CALIFORNIA'S NOW STEPPED
UP IN A IN IN A BIG WAY AND OUR-
FEDERAL PARTNERS REALLY NEED TO
AS WELL THE OPPORTUNITY EXISTS.
RIGHT NOW IN THIS MOMENT SO I
WOULD LIKE TO. HEAR ABOUT THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF- IS KIRSTEN IF YOU
HAVE ANY INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
BUT- I WANT TO GET IT OUT THERE
SO THAT- OUR OTHER. PRESENTERS
COULD ADDRESS IT. THANK YOU YEAH
I'VE SEEN I'VE- BEEN TRYING TO
TRACK A LITTLE BIT THE FUNDING
BOTH AND THE BILL BACK BETTER
AND OF COURSE- YOU KNOW THE AT
THE OTHER IN THE OTHER AND- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND- I. YET
THERE IS IF THERE IS- FUNDING
THAT IS AVAILABLE AND I THINK-
AGAIN YOU KNOW THERE'S OF COURSE
SOME CONTINUING NEGOTIATIONS AND
CONGRESS AND EXACTLY HOW THIS
WILL PLAY OUT I'M NOT SURE AND
I'M NOT. I'M NOT REALLY AND-
I'VE BEEN TRACKING THE STATE'S
LOBBYING EFFORTS SPECIFICALLY SO
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
THE NEXT PANEL COULD COVER. THAT
MAKES SENSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR- PRISON MR GALLAGHER
YOU HAVE A OKAY WE HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION FOR YOU- SO ON THE
EARLY ACTION A IT SOUNDS LIKE
HE'S YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MANY PROJECTS BUT DO
YOU DO YOU HAVE AN IDEA OF HOW
MANY ACRES ARE IDENTIFIED IN
THOSE COMMITTED. PROJECTS WE
HAVE A LIST THE POINT I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBER OF ACRES- I CAN
SEE IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD PROVIDE-
CERTAINLY HAPPY THAT TO- REACH
OUT TO THEM OR YOU COULD ASK
THE- STATE IF THEY HAVE THAT I
KNOW THAT WILL BE PART OF THE
REPORTING SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT- THAT WILL BE FORTHCOMING I
JUST DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY THAT THEY
HAVE AT THIS POINT- YEAH I CAN
ASK THE NEXT PANEL I JUST WANT
TO SEE IF YOU HAD HAD. A
COMPILATION OF THAT- AND THEN.
THE OFFICE YET UNPRECEDENTED
FUNDING- THAT WE'VE BROUGHT
ONLINE- AND THAT'S THE REALLY
GOOD NEWS I THINK BUT BUT I
THINK THE REAL THEME HERE IS THE
URGENCY OF THE SITUATION AND THE
NEED TO REALLY GET- THIS FUEL
REDUCTION MANAGEMENT- PROJECTS
MOVING. AND EXPEDITING THEM-
BECAUSE WE WANT TO AVOID THE
NEXT PARADISE. YOU KNOW THE NEXT
BERRY CREEK THE NEXT GREENVILLE-
SO URGENCY AND SPEED. N. AS IN
THE NARROW WINDOW THAT WE HAVE.
WITH LONGER FIRE SEASONS NEED TO
DO THIS WORK. YOU KNOW YES
STARTING IN NOVEMBER. YOU KNOW
GOING INTO THE INTO THE SPRING
AND THEN YOU HAVE YOU KNOW
WINTER MONTHS IT MAKES IT HARD-
SO WE HAVE THIS NARROW WINDOW TO
GET. THIS WORK DONE- AND WHEN WE
BROUGHT THIS UP ABOUT THE NEED
TO STREAMLINED PROCESS SEES THE
ADMINISTRATION OFTEN POINTS TO
THE CAL B. T. P. PROGRAM AS-
WELL THAT'S THE- THAT'S THE
PROGRAM THAT'S REALLY GOING TO.
SPEED THROUGH AN STREAMLINED
SEQUEL ANOTHER PROCESSES TO MAKE
THESE PROJECTS HAPPEN. SO IF I
COULD JUST ASK YOU HOW OFTEN IS
THAT PROP THAT PROGRAM BEEN
USED. FOR THESE PROJECTS HAS IT
ACTUALLY RESULTED IN A
STREAMLINED PROCESS. FOR THEM
AND HOW MANY ACRES HAS THAT
PROGRAM ACTUALLY. HELP TREAT IN
AN EXPEDITED WAY IF THERE IS
SUCH AN EXPEDITED PROCESS. YES
THAT'S A RELATIVELY NEW PROGRAM
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
LAUNCHED AND SO IT'S ONE THAT IT
HASN'T BEEN USED AS AS WE DID AS
WE TRY TO LOOK INTO THIS A
LITTLE BIT SINCE THE LAST
HEARING WEARING THEIR THIS ISSUE
WAS ALSO RAISED I'M STILL
HAVEN'T BEEN USED- VERY. VERY
WIDESPREAD WAY I THINK IT'S
MAYBE ABOUT FOURTEEN PROJECT OF
OUR CALL CORRECTLY ALTHOUGH I
HAVE TO LOOK BACK AT MY NOTES TO
DOUBLE CHECK ON THAT BUT IT'S A
RELATIVELY- RELATIVELY SMALL
NUMBER OF PROJECTS THAT HAVE
USED IT AS FAR PROUD BECAUSE IT
IS SO NEW- WE DIDN'T FIND CLEAR
YOU KNOW CLEAR DATA SHOWING THAT
IT HAD AND- I THINK THAT CAN BE
EXPEDITED PROJECTS BEGAN ITS
IT'S VERY EARLY DAYS HERE. AND
SO IT'S UNCLEAR I THINK A LOT OF
ONE ONE OF THE THINGS WE HEARD
WE TALK TO PEOPLE IS THAT-
THERE'S SOME LEARNING CURVE
ASSOCIATED WITH LEARNING AND HOW
TO USE THE CAL B. T. P. KIND OF
PROCESS AND HOW DID AND HOW DID
YOU- SORT OF NAVIGATED A LITTLE
pMORE WIDELY USED AS WELL AS-
MORE HELPFUL IN EXPEDITING
PROJECTS- IN THE COMING YEARS
BUT THEY'RE SORT OF IT'S SORT OF
TBG ON THAT EXACTLY HOW EXACTLY
HOW HOPEFUL IT WILL BE AT THIS
POINT. THERE ARE PROJECTS THAT
WE CAN GET INFORMATION FOR A LOT
OF HIS PROJECTS- BASICALLY WHAT
WE CAN GATHER WITH THAT THOSE
PROJECTS GENERALLY WOULDN'T HAVE
USED UP DONE A FULL ER ANYWAY A
LOT OF THOSE WOULD HAVE DONE TO
BE MITIGATED TACK OR SOMETHING
SOMETHING THAT WAS SIMPLER SO.
YOU KNOW AGAIN AND CAL BTP MAY
SAVE SOME TIME FOR MORE
COMPLICATED- KIND OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS OR LIKE
THE- BERMAN PROCESS MAYBE LESS
SO IF PROJECTS WERE SMALLER AND
ABLE TO USE- A CERTAIN ALREADY
MORE AND STREAMLINED PROCESS SO
IT PROBABLY DEPENDS ON THE
PROJECT ALSO AGAIN IT'S EARLY
DAYS TO SEE BUT WE DIDN'T SEE
I'M AT THIS POINT A LOT OF A.
LOT OF EVIDENCE ON I'M NOT. AND-
SORRY YOUR QUESTION WITH THE
EIGHT TREATED I DON'T HAVE THAT
NOW RIGHT- SO I HAVE ADD TO
CHECK AND IF I COULD GET. TO YOU
ON THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR- REMAINING
PANELISTS NOW AND I THINK WE
HAVE- TO LET'S SEE. HOW WOULD
YOU DESCRIBE THE AFTER ALL THE
REMAINING PANELS OKAY SO WE HAVE
SIX REMAINING PEOPLE AND I THINK
WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS HERE FROM-
ALL OF THEM AND THEN- THEY'LL
STICK AROUND TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AFTER ALL THE PRESENTATIONS OF
BEEN MADE. SO WE WILL- PROCEED
NOW TO HEAR FROM. JESSICA MORSE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM- AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S REALLY AN HONOR
TO BE HERE WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP IN WORKING WITH US
ON THE AYE TACKLING A WILDFIRE
CRISIS AT SCHEDULE I'M NOT SURE
PRESENTATION NEED TO DATE CODES
IN THE SKIES. THE CHECK HE ASKED
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS YEAR'S
WILDFIRES- A LITTLE BIT OF
INSIGHT INTO STRATEGY BEHIND OUR
INVESTMENTS AND ALSO BREAK OUT-
OUR APPROACH TO WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE AND THAT'S BEEN THE
BULK OF THE TIME TALKING THREE
WHO ARE INVESTMENT ALONG THE
LINES OF THE STRATEGIES OF THE
RESULTS WERE STARTING. TO SEE.
THANK ASSURE COMPLIANCE.
BACKGROUND AS ALL YOU KNOW EVERY
CALIFORNIA AND HAS BEEN
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED BY THE
WILDFIRE CRISIS FROM LOSING
COMMUNITIES AND HOMES I'M TO
HAVE A LOVED ONE IS DISPLACED TO
I'M CHOKING ON THE SMOKE COMING
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES EVERY
POLICY IN CALIFORNIA IS ALSO
BEING IMPACTED BY THE FIRES- IN
A WHEN YOU THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED-
THE DIXIE FIRE AND THE CALIBER
FIRE IN THE TAMARACK FIRE ALL
BURN IN CALIFORNIA'S UPPER
WATERSHEDS WE HAVE FIRES OVER
THE LAST TWO SEASONS THAT
DEVASTATED BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY PERCENT- OF OUR LARGE
JOINTS WELL YEP POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SEEN- IT
THESE FIRES IMPACTING. AT AN
ENTIRE WATERSHED SCALE THE DIXIE
FIRE FOR EXAMPLE IS THE LARGEST
SINGLE- BUT WILDFIRE IN STATE
HISTORY AND IT BURNED ST THREE
THE FEATHER RIVER WATERSHED
WHICH IS THE HEADQUARTERS FOR
THE STATE WATER PROJECT I WE HAD
NEVER HAD IN STATE HISTORY FIRES
BURN UP AND OVER THE PLANET
CREST OF THE SIERRA NEVADA UNTIL
THIS YEAR IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT HAPPENED TWICE
WITH THE DIXIE FIRE AND THE
CALDOR FIRE. WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
THAT THESE FIRES ARE
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA'S WATERSHEDS- WE ARE
WITH 60% OF OUR WATER COMES FROM
THIS YEAR NEVADA AND AS YOU CAN
SEE- IN THE HSTORICAL FIRE A
PERSON THAT REGION SINCE
NINETEEN TWENTY- THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
FIRE SEASONS ARE UNPARALLELED-
INDICATING THAT WE ARE NOW SEEN
OUR THE COMPOUNDING. OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE WE ARE WE ARE HAVING
CATASTROPHIC FIRES WE'RE HAVING
HEAT DROUGHT RIGHT CONDITIONS-
ON TOP OF DENSE FUEL LOADS READ
EXTREME FIRE BEHAVIOR WHICH
BURNS NIGHT AT HIGH SEVERITY I
HAVE TO THE DIXIE FIREBIRD HYSAN
WHICH MADE IT BIRDS OUT- THE
AKALA AND DOWN INTO THAT TOP
SOIL NOT ACTUALLY WENT FURTHER
EXACT STROKING. BY BY OUR
WATERSHEDS SO WE'RE NOW SEEING
WITH THE FIRE CRISIS ARE
COMPOUNDING CLIMATE CYCLES- AND
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
CLIMATE CHANGE THERE. SOME HOPE
THEY'LL BE BECAUSE WHAT WE KNOW
THAT ON THE- ACROSS FOR WHAT. WE
CAN ACTUALLY CHANGE THE
STRUCTURE. OF THE FOREST YOU
BECOME YEAH AND VIRUS. EVEN IN
THE HIGH DRIVE CAN. ON THAT WE
ARE EXT. SO I I'VE SHOWN YOU
RIGHT HERE ON AN OVERLY GOT
FOREST WHERE YOU GET LATTER FEW
UP INTO THE UPPER TREE CANOPY.
BURNS OUT THE ANTI WATER- WHERE
IS A YOU GET FORCE INTO. I THEN
THE FIRE IN I IN LOW BIRDS UNDER
. AND YOU HAVE HEALTHY AND HOW
BECAUSE FOR. SO AKAL SHE'S- I
FINE A DAY. AND IT'S PROTECT FOR
TO COLOR THING CAL. BUT THERE
ARE TOOLS THAT WE ARE BRINGING
FROM THAT SHE TO BE ABLE TO HELP
US. THE INCREASE IN CRIME CHANGE
SYMPORTER MEMBER WE CANNOT DO IT
ALL. FIFTY SO PERCENT OF. FOR
LAND ARE AND MANAGED BY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT 3% ARE OWNED BY
THE STATE AND 40% ARE PRIVATELY
HELD. LAST SUMMER IN THE SUMMER
OF TWENTY TWENTY WE ARE SHE HAS
SIGNED. A SHARED. FREMANTLE THE
FEDERAL. THAT A LOT TERM. BASED
YEARS. FOR ACHIEVING CALL ME.
CALL RIZZO- FOR TWO. LAST THIS
ARE EARLY YEAR. THROUGH COUPLE.
AND WORK STATE AND OUR FEDERAL.
HOW RELEASE BEAT WHILE FORCED
RISEN AT PLAN FOR MORE. FORCED
RESILIENCE TASK. THIS REALLY OUT
THIS. SOLUTION AND THE TO
ACTIONS WE TO TAKE. WHERE THE US
SERVICE OUR FEDERAL PARTNER AND
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS TO BE ABLE TO
TACKLE THIS CLIMATE CRISIS AT
SCALE. OUR INVESTMENT OF ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THE
PHILS CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
THAT SHARED STEWARDSHIP- THOSE
TARGETS AND GOALS ONE U. FOREST
SERVICE AND IT'S- AND WE ARE.
EAGERLY ANTICIPATING THE
INCREASE DOLLARS FROM THE U. S.
FOREST SERVICE SHOULD ALSO BE
ABLE TO INVEST- WITH ICE AT THIS
SCALE. SO WE NEED TO TACKLE THIS
CRISIS TOGETHER AND WE ARE
STARTING TO TACKLE THIS CRISIS
AT SCALE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS THE
FIRST TIME WE SAW- DEDICATED
FUNDING FOR WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
IN CALIFORNIA. SB NINE A ONE AND
THAT WAS A BASED BUDGET ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR. THIS YEAR WE INVESTED ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
BETWEEN THE EARLY ACTION FUNDS.
AND AT THE BUDGET YEAR DOLLARS
AND THIS CREATED A HUGE
FOUNDATION FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
START TACKLING THIS CRISIS AT
GAIL. EARLY ACTION DOLLARS WERE
CRUCIAL WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
THE LEADERSHIP AND INNOVATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE RECORDING
EMERGENCY APPROPRIATION IN
PLACE. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
WILDFIRES DO NOT CAUSE OR THE
BUDGET CYCLE AND STILL GETTING
US THOSE. EARLY IN US TO GIVE
THANK. AT LAST A BASS I. SCALE
THE SHOVEL READY PROJECTS TYPE.
THAT WERE READY TO GO OUT THE
YOU'RE ON THE GO AND YET MOVING
. AND THOSE IN BACK IN OVER TWO
SIXTY PROJECTS THAT LARGE WITHIN
A MONTHS. ALSO ENABLED US TO
START A NEW. SINCE YOU'RE THE
ONE WE GOT THE DOLLAR COMMITTED
YET SUCH AS I'M NOT ALLOWED TO
GET US MONTH START. TO GET THOSE
CROSS ROLE. SO THOSE IN THINGS
LIKE- BUT CLIMATE. FONG TO GET
WHICH LOAN THE- BUSINESS LOAN IN
THIS SPACE- IT ALLOW US TO JUMP
. ON ACTION FOR PRO. WHY V. HOME
HARDENING DEFENSIVE SPACE.
PROGRAM IN ADDITION. OUR THE
ACROSS THE STREET TO DELIVER
WHILE RESILIENCE. WE ALSO THEN.
ON IN BEING HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS ROUND UP ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION THOSE
WERE IN. IN THAT ARE BRING US TO
A ARTS STE. I'M THESE ARE GONNA
BE LARGER. AND THE ALSO INVEST
IN SOME OF THE STRUCTURE- AREAS
THAT ARE GOING TO ALLOW US
DELIVER RESILIENCE COULD. IN THE
LONG TERM. BEING LED BY LOCAL
COLLABORATIVE GROUPS- SO THAT WE
ARE NOT TAKING A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH. TO THE STATE I'M
AND ALSO REALLY JUMP STARTING
THE BUSINESS SECTOR AGAIN. OR
TAKING THE WOODY BIOMASS COMING
OUT OF THESE FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS AND TURNING THAT INTO
SOMETHING MORE USEFUL THAN OPEN
PILE BURNING. WE STAR ALREADY
HAVE SEEN- EARLY RESULTS FROM
THESE EARLY ACTION DOLLARS. AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE L. A. L.
MENTIONED WE AMBASSADOR EARLY
ACTION DOLLARS ANTICIPATING THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE- A JUMP START ON
A YEAR- THAT MOST OF THESE
PROJECTS TAKE A YEAR TO START TO
FINISH. BUT I WAS AMAZED. THAT
ARE I'M CONSERVANCY STATE
ENTITIES CAL FIRE WORKED
INCREDIBLY HARD AND GOT SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS STARTED AND SOME
OF THEM FINISHED IN RECORD TIME-
THIS IS CORRECT PICTURE OF THE
PROJECT. NOW BEEN DONE BY THE
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY DOWN
ON THE SANTA BARBARA AREA. AND
WHEN I ALSO FIRE- HIT AN AREA
THAT THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY HAD WATCHED A
GRAZING PROJECT THIS SPRING WITH
THOSE EARLY ACTION DOLLARS. YOU
CAN SEE THAT IT ACTUALLY SAVE
THE PRESERVE AND- AND STOP
BURNING THE AREA THAT WAS BURNED
OUT WAS ABOUT THREE FEET OF
MUSTARD. I'M ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THAT FENCE LINE- ON A
NEIGHBORING PROPERTY THAT HAD
BEEN CLEARED OUT SO THIS- EARLY
ACTION INVESTMENT ACTUALLY CAME
INTO PLAY THIS WILDFIRE SEASON
WE SAW THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE YOU SOME OF THEIR EARLY
ACTION DOLLARS. UNTILMARCH-
OVER FIFTY PROJECTS- AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO PICK SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS AFTER THE CALDOR FIRE
JUST STOP ROSHAN AND PROTECT.
REALLY BAD. SO THESE DOLLARS ARE
MAKING A HUGE IMPACT. I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO BREAK DOWN THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING IN
A WILDFIRE RESILIENCE WHAT IS
WILD BECAUSE LIKE ACTUALLY LOOK
LIKE. FOR COMMUNITIES. AND- AND
HOW ARE WE. INTERACTION BEST I
SCALE SO THERE REALLY THREE.
FINE A WILDFIRE RESILIENCE THAT
GO. AND WE NEED TO BE IN. IN
AROUND COMMUNITY I L. TO BE ABLE
TO START HAVING- I'M REALLY OUR
CA. NOT JUST YOUR BUT- I'M IN
THIS AGE OF CRIME CHANGE SO
INVEST ALMOST THREE FRONT FIRST
REALLY UP. LAW LAND. WHERE WE
ARE WORST. THE NASH CHOIR A CALL
SHE TO LANDSCAPES SO WHEN IS BY
MISSION. WHEN THEY'RE ON IS A
LIE STRIKE. THAT IT. AT ITS
WITHIN ITS- NO AND IT'S RIGHT
FIRE RETURN INTO. SO THAT IT.
HAS A RESEARCH THE IMPACT ON THE
FOLLOW. RATHER A DENNIS ONE. THE
NEXT AREA IS AROUND CAN. IN THAT
Y. LAND IN. THIS IS WEARING
AGAINST FUEL BREAKS AND IN. FIRE
FIRE THAT TACTIC ADVANTAGE TO BE
ABLE TO SLOW FIRE ON ME AND-
FIRES. OR STAY A FIRE IF THEY
HAVE THAT A BILL. I'M THE LAST
AREA IS IN IN HER. INSIDE
COMMITTEE. SO THAT ALL. AND
DEFENSE SPACE. WE'RE WE ARE
HELPING COMMUNITY. BILL LAST
ROUND YOU IN- SO THAT THOSE
WILDLAND FIRE THEN JOE BECOME
URBAN IN. WE ALSO INVITE IN
COURT PRINCE AS WELL TO ENSURE
THAT ACROSS ALL THREE FRONTS
WILD RESILIENCE WERE ACTUALLY
MAKE AN IMPACT THAT IS LONG TERM
I'M FOR THE NEXT HUNDRED YEARS
FOR. THAT IS ALSO DRIVING UP ON
MY WORK AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITIES
AND IS REALLY ANCHORED IN
REGIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND SO
INVESTMENTS IN THESE
FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENTS ARE ALSO
REALLY CRUCIAL TO ENSURING THAT
WE ARE SCALING UP OUR EFFORTS
FOR WILDFIRE. IT'S WHAT'S
EXCITING IS THAT WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE EARLY IMPACTS AND THAT
HE'S INVESTMENTS WE'RE MAKING
ACROSS THE RESPONSE OF FIRE
RESILIENCE ARE PAYING OFF. I'M
AND THE CALIBER FIRE IS A REALLY
GREAT EXAMPLE I'M AS OLD YOU
KNOW THAT FIRE THAT BURNED UP
HIGHWAY FIFTY FROM POLLOCK
PINES. OVER THE ECHO SUMMIT OPEN
OVER THE CREST OF THIS YEAR AT
DEFINITELY SHE WILL- AND THE DOW
INTO THE TAHOE. AND WHY IS- BUT
I YOU KNOW CASH MAY A FIRE WE'RE
GETTING HIGH. WHAT WE SAW THAT
THE INTERVENTIONS THAT WERE ON
THE GROUND FLAYED ALIVE ROLE
FROM A PROGRAM CALLED FIRE
DOCTORS. ALONG HIGHWAY FIFTY
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE BY
THE RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT THROUGH FUNDING FROM
CAL FIRE YOUR NEVADA CONSERVANCY
AND YOUR SUPPORT SERVICE- THAT
ALLOW THE COMMUNITIES APOLOGIZED
- AND- FIFTY QUARTER MANY
COMMUNITIES AND HOMES TO BE
SAVED WE ALSO SAW A PRESCRIBED
FIRE OUTSIDE OF KIRKWOOD CALLED
THE PEOPLE'S BURKE. AT MAX WHEN
THE CALIBER FIRE HIT THAT AREA
ACTUALLY STEER AROUND THE CABLES
FIRE ON GIVING FIREFIGHTERS A
TACTICAL ADVANTAGE- NEED THE
COMMUNITY OF KIRKWOOD SAID THOSE
LANDSCAPE SCALE INVESTMENTS DO
YOU HAVE A BIG IMPACT. ON THE
BEHAVIOR OF THESE MEGA FIRES WE
ALSO SAW FUEL BREAKS AROUND- THE
AREAS OF. MYERS AND CHRISTMAS
BALLY HOW IMPACT AS- I'M SO THE
PHONE I'M SURE YOU RIGHT HERE
THIS CRAP THANK THE GROUND. IF
YOU CAN SEE IT IS WHERE FIRE.
THE ORANGE AND YELLOW IS WAY
PART IN QUITE HIGH. SO THAT'S
WHERE YOU GETTING THOSE HUNDRED
PLUS FLAME LINKS AND THIS
VEHICLE AREA. I'M WHICH AS YOU
CAN SEE ALL THE NAY. THOSE ARE
WORK OF FUEL BREAKS FUEL. THAT
HAD BEEN MADE. BY I DO FOR STATE
AND PARTNERS FIRE. THANKS IT.
TAHOE REGIONAL PLANNING. THE U.
S. SERVICE TO PARKS I'M IN A ROW
THAT TOPPLED. FIREFIGHTER ON THE
GROUND REPORT THAT WE- THOSE
THAT WERE THAT WERE FIFTY PLUS
WHAT FLAME LIKE LET FIFTEEN
STORY BUILDING. WHEN THEY THOSE
FUEL BRAKES ANY THE STREET IF
YOU'RE BREAKING AN AREA JUST
KIND AND NOW. TREE. IT DROPPED
TO FIFTEEN IN SOME DE TO NEAR.
SO FIRE WERE ABLE TO TAKE ITS-
OUT IN THOSE AREAS COMMUNITY AND
ALSO DONE A GREAT JOB ON
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PARDON. AND
EARLY IN WHICH- GIVING FOR. AN
OPERA TO A STAND- AND PROTECT
THOSE CAN. AND HOME WERE LOTS IN
THE TAHOE BASIN. SO WE KNOW
THESE IN. WERE SO I WANT GIVE
YOU SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW WE ARE
INVESTING ACROSS THOSE THREE
FRIENDS OUT. OF RESILIENCE-
BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN IT IS ACROSS FORTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS ACROSS OVER
TWENTY DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS SO
THERE'S HUGE PARTNERSHIPS
ENGAGED HERE AND SO WE HAVE A
LOT OF TAILOR PROGRAMS. TO MEET
THE DIFFERENT LANDSCAPES- AND
GROUPS THAT ARE IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA- THAT WE NEED TO BE
ENGAGED TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE THIS RESILIENT
LANDSCAPES- AND FIRE RESILIENCE
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE SO ON
THAT LANDSCAPE LEVEL CRIMES-
THERE'S LOTS OF TOOLS THAT
WEREN'T. BURKE MASTICATION ANY
PRESCRIBED FIRE THEY OFTEN ALL
GO TOGETHER- BUT THIS IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF ONE OF THESE PROJECTS
WORKING IN V. EIGHT- MORE
COMPLEX FIRE OUTSIDE OF THE TOWN
OF QUINCY- I'M- HERE TO.
CONSERVANCY HAD INVESTED IN YOUR
ACTION PROJECTS- UNDERNEATH
THOSE GREEN TREES YOU SEE AND-
ARE. NEED MORE COMPLEX FIRE HIT
IT WAS CLEARLY BURNING AT HIGH
SEVERITY UNTIL IT HIT THAT
FUELED BY A MODIFICATION AREA
WITHOUT COURSE HAD BEEN BENT.
AND FIRED GROUNDED OUT AND
BURNED UNDERNEATH THE TREE
CANOPY THAT'S THE GOAL WE'RE
GOING FOR IS TO BE ABLE TO
HOWEVER COURSE STAND OUT. SO
THAT WHEN THE FIRE BURNS THROUGH
A BIRDS UNDERNEATH AND THE
TREES- AND THE ECOLOGY IS LEFT
STANDING- AS OPPOSED TO THE HIGH
SEVERITY THAT YOU SEE ON THE
LEFT. ARE EARLY ACTION DOLLARS
ARE HAVING. THIS THE FIRST TIME
THAT WE NEED TO DIRECTLY- STATE
OAKLAND TO BE STATE PARKS.
OFFICIAL WHY. HAVE BEEN GREAT
FROM FIRE. TO BE ABLE TO YOU
FEEL ACTION. ON NEARLY. THE
EARLY ACTION DOLLARS AND THE BY
YEAR TO. NOW CREEK TO PROBE.
MORE EFFICIENT WHILE ANSTIEG
PARKS MISSION WHILE MUCH NEARLY
- OVER FIFTY FIVE- IN RIGHT TIME
. INCLUDE INCREASED- A FEW
REDUCTION- AROUND THEIR AREAS
AND STATE PARKS- IS LAUNCHING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DOING ANY WORK
INCLUDING EVER ON CALAVERAS BIG
TREES TO PROTECT SME OF OUR OUR
MONARCH CIRCLE YES. I'M IN THAT
AREA AS WELL I'M SHOWING YOU A
PICTURE OF WHAT THE FUEL LOADING
LOOKS LIKE- BEFORE. IN THERE.
AND SO WE HAVE A LOT OF PROGRAMS
THAT ARE INVESTING IN THESE
RESILIENT LANDSCAPES SO FORCED
HEALTH GRANTS FROM CAL FIRE.
DRAMATICALLY SCALED UP- WE HAVE
PROGRAMS FOR SMALL FOREST
LANDOWNERS THE FORCED
IMPROVEMENT FOR SMALL
LANDOWNERS- SUMMED AND ACRONYMS
THE FACT OR AT. AND THAT PROGRAM
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS A HUGE
SCALE INVESTMENT- BECAUSE MALL
COURSE OF LANDOWNERS ACTUALLY
MAKE UP ABOUT 26% SO THOSE ARE
FOLKS THAT HAVE FIFTY ACRES ONE
HUNDRED ACRES A THOUSAND ACRES-
SO THE SMALLER PLOTS. AND THESE
GRANTS HELP THEM TREAT THEIR
LANDSCAPE SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THIS PATCHWORK IMPACT I'M AND
INSTEAD ARE HAVING CONTIGUOUS
HEALTHY FORESTS IN THESE AREAS.
I'M MORE ALSO INVESTING IN OUR
FORCE OUR REFORESTATION NURSERY
ARE URBAN FORESTRY PROGRAM AND
LAUNCHING A NEW PROGRAM TO
INVEST. IN A TRIBALLY LED
INITIATIVE- THAT IS PARTNERING
WITH THE INDIGENOUS- TRIBAL
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL. THAT IS
PART OF OUR REGIONAL FORTUNE.
RAMPS THIS IS A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROBE. THAT ALLOWS TRIED
TO TELL WHAT THEY WANT TO DO ON
THE LAN. I'M IN A TRIBE LED. I
HER PROGRAM I'M THAT THEY CAN
HAVE TO THEN COMPETE FOR ALL OF
OUR THERE. L. A. TO CAN FOR OF
OUR GREAT BUT THIS IS. A
DRAMATIC TRIBE PROGRAM AND WERE
SEEN- AND TO. WITH THEM AND THEN
THE HUNDREDS OF FIVE BELOW THAT
ALL TODAY THE STATE. DEPARTMENT
WHILE PRO. SO THOSE LATE SCALE
INVESTMENT ARE INVESTING ACROSS
OWNERSHIP TYPES AND- AND LAND
TYPES. WE ARE ACTUALLY ACHIEVING
IT CAN TO AND- BECAUSE WHILE.
ARE NOT. AT BOUNDARIES. JERRY
WAS INVESTMENTS CAN YOU SO THIS
ISN'T A OF KIND OF A GRAPHIC OF
WHAT SHE DID FEEL LOOK LIKE- AND
IT'S BEEN OUT- ROAD. OFTEN IT TO
FIREFIGHTERS IN A VACUUM IT
CREATES A SAFE PLACE FOR
FIREFIGHTERS TO TAKE A STAND AND
CREATE THOSE TACTICAL ADVANTAGES
DURING A WILDFIRE SO WE ARE
INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CONTINUING THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK
ON THE FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS
ARE INCREDIBLE TOOLS TO GET-
LOCAL COUNTIES FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS- TO BE ABLE TO DO. ARE
NOT JUST FUEL BREAKS BUT ALSO
FOUGHT HARD NAY DEFENSIBLE SPACE
WORK- AND THEN THE POOREST
REPORT PROGRAM THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
THE EXECUTE A LOT OF THE SKILL
BREAKS- AND FORCE HEALTH PROJECT
IN. AND AROUND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE LAST
COMING AND HOME- THIS IS WHERE.
PEOPLE DO TO SPACE THERE MAKE IT
EASY TO DO THEIR HOMES- DURING
FIRE AND AS WE KNOW HOMES. ON
THE INSIDE OUT DURING A WILDFIRE
SO EMBERS GETTING IN THROUGH FOR
ROOF SO EDUCATE HOME- AND GIVING
THEM THE TOOLS TO DO HOME
GARDENING WORK IS REALLY CRUCIAL
SO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS.
I'M INCLUDING THIS FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS I MENTIONED
EARLIER- THAT THEY ARE OFTEN
HELPING ON THE EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH WE ARE INVESTING IN
YOUSIF WILDLAND FIRE FIGHT AT UC
FIRE ADVISOR. PROGRAM THROUGH
THE UC EXTENSION PROGRAM HAS
BEEN HELPING OUT WITH THE MASTER
GARDENERS PROGRAM ON DEFENSIBLE
I FACED AS DISPENSABLE SPACE. I
THE CALL STEVE- WHERE THEY'RE
HELPING PEOPLE DO. OR DEFENSE
SPACE HOMES I'M AARON I'M ALSO
ENSURING THAT FIRE WAYS
COMMUNITIES FIRE SAFE COUNCILS.
HAVE EXPERTS TO BE ABLE TO LEAN
ON TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
INTEGRATING THE BEST SCIENCE
AROUND HOME HARDENING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE LANDSCAPE- PROTECTION THAT
THEY'RE DOING- WE ALSO HAVE
INVESTMENTS A DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTORS- SURGED BACK PROGRAM
WITH THIS BUDGET YEAR DOLLARS AN
EARLY ACTION. TO GET OUT AND
WORK WITH HOMEOWNERS I'M AND
THEN A NEW INITIATIVE WHICH WAS
A LOW INCOME DEFENSIBLE SPACE
PROGRAM SO THOSE HOMEOWNERS THAT
THE EDUCATION TOOLS I'M ARE AND
NOT TO GET THEM TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT- THIS IS A TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT THAT
WE ARE PARTNERING. WITH FEMA- TO
UNLOCK SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM FEMA FOR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PILOTS TO BE ABLE
TO DO DIRECT INTERVENTIONS FOR
HOME TURNING FOR LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT PROGRAM IS
LAUNCHING. ON WE'RE ALSO
INVESTING ACROSS THE STRUCTURAL
AREAS I MENTIONED SO. I JUST
WENT THROUGH THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE THOSE THREE FUNDS HAVE
DIRECTIONS BILLIONS WHERE WE'RE
WE'RE LOWERING THE FUEL
INTENSITY AND THAT FIRE
INTENSITY ON THE LANDSCAPE
RETURNING THOSE NATURAL FIRE
ECOLOGY IS WE'RE INVESTING
AROUND COMMUNITIES. FOR THAT- SO
THAT FIREFIGHTERS HAVE THE
TACTICAL ADVANTAGES AND
COMMUNITIES HAVE SAFE ESCAPE
ROUTES DURING WILDFIRES AND THEN
INVESTING INSIDE OF COMMUNITIES
TO MAKE HOMES LESS IGNITION
PROBLEM WHEN THOSE BIG NUMBERS
ARE COMING IN. ON SO THE LAST
AREAS ARE REGIONAL INVESTMENTS
AND ALSO SITES IN BUSINESS AND
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH SO WE
HAVE ALISON JOLLY ON THE PANEL
TODAY WHO'S GOING TO GO INTO A
LOT OF DATA. ABOUT THE REGIONAL
FOREST AND FIRE CAPACITY
SHOWGROUND. PROGRAM REALLY
ENCOURAGED- MOST OF OUR
INVESTMENTS SO WE ARE INVESTING
INVEST IN- THE REPORT CONTRABASS
IN DISTRESS LOCAL COLLAB. I'M
THAT ARE STE GRAY DOLLAR LIKE
THOSE FORCED AND BY PREVENT
GRANT DOLLARS THAT BIG TICKET
ITEMS AND ALSO FOR STATE GERMAN
DOLLARS. THE GO TO. INTO WELCOME
. REGIONAL STRAT. I'M ENTERS CAN
. YOUR GETTING THIS WILDFIRE
FUNDING OUR ANCHOR KERR. IN
REGIONAL FOR FIRE TO PASS PROBE
. THE EARLY ACTION DOLLARS IN
THE BUT YEAR DAHLE. GOT WHY
INVEST. IN THIS REGIONAL EMPIRE
COULD PROGRAM SO WE HAVE SORT OF
LARGE REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH ARE CONSERVANCY ANCHOR WE
DON'T HAVE SOME BREACH- AND-
WHICH ARE OFTEN ASKED OF THE
CONSERVATIVES WILL THAT KIND OF
BREAK OUT AND THEN WE HAVE A
LOCAL COLLABORATIVE. LIKE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
FOR THE NOTE NORTH COAST
PARTNERSHIPS THAT MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS I'LL GIVE YOU A
COUPLE EXAMPLES SO THAT THIS
ISN'T QUITE SO ABSTRACT SO EARLY
ACTION DOLLARS WE'RE REALLY
IMPACTFUL WHERE THEY INVESTED.
IN A REGIONAL COLLABORATIVES
THAT ALREADY BEEN SET UP UNDER
THIS REGIONAL FORCING FIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM SO THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE FROM THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY- WHERE
THEY HAD BEEN INVESTING IN A
REGIONAL STRATEGY IN THEIR AREA
AND SO WHEN THEY GOT EARLY
ACTION DOLLARS IT COMPLEMENTED
CALIFORNIA FORCED HEALTH GRANTS-
AND THEY WERE ABLE TO YOU KNOW.
DO YOU ASK YOUR ACTION ALONG
HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE WITH THE
EARLY. ACTION DOLLARS. TRINA'S
SOME OF FINE. THEY SAT EARLY.
PROTECTION PROGRAM WHICH THEY
HAVE DEPLOYED AS EARLY AS FOURTH
OF JULY. I'M AND WE'RE IN TO
STOP. SIMILARLY FIRE- AND- THEY
WERE ABLE TO ALSO THAT READ
INVESTMENT ACROSS THESE LANDS
SCALE. AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE FAR
LEFT GEORGINA'S LOADING. AND
HELP- RESTORATION. I'M ANOTHER
GREAT EXAMPLE IS THE SAN DIEGO
CONSERVANCY INVESTED IN A
PARTNERSHIP THAT ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED WHEN HE ASKED SAN
DIEGO RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT. SCHERING YOUR MAP. OF
THE SAN DIEGO AREA WITH ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS
THAT'S WHY HE'S REGIONAL
INVESTMENTS ARE SO CRITICAL
BECAUSE IF WE ALLOW IT TO EACH
JURISDICTION OPERATE IN A SILO.
THAT PATCHWORK AND WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO A FIRE WOULD JUST
BIRD STREET UNIT PATCHWORK ON BY
A COHESIVE APPROACH ANCHORED BY
THE SAN DIEGO RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT. AND
PARTNERED. WITH THE SAN DIEGO
CONSERVANCY. YEAH FUNDING
PROMISED FORCES PASS PRO. TO
DESIGN OUR REGION STRATEGY
SEVERAL YEARS AGO I'M A THEY
ALSO WILL GIVE AND STAFF AND- TO
BE A TO SEE UP THAT REGIONAL
STRATEGY AS WELL. SO THAT WE ARE
ACTION DOLLAR TEEN IN THE SAN CA
. AND CALIFORNIA FORCED GRANTS
WERE IN TO BOTH COME IN AND
MAKING THE- IN LAST. IS REALLY
TRIED ARE ALSO REALLY CREWS. TO
OUR SPECIAL PARTNERSHIP WE ARE
USING THESE AS A JOB GREEN ARROW
THAT SAYS GOVERNMENT INVEST.
HERE YOU SEEN SAN DIEGO THE FOR
SERVICE ALSO MEETING BACK. THIS
REGIONAL. WHICH GETS US SOME
WORKING. IN ACROSS THE- REGARD
OF WHEN. TYPE AND SO AND WE ARE
SEEING THIS REPEATED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND OUR EXPANDED
INVESTMENTS IN THE REGIONAL
FORCING FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAMS
ARE REALLY ANCHORING THOSE
INVESTMENTS SO THAT WE WILL SEE
THIS AS- THE NORM- I ALSO WANT
TO TAKE A MINUTE AND THIS'LL BE
STUDENT. LAST FIVE MINUTES HERE-
TO TALK THROUGH THE OTHER AREAS
THAT WE'RE DRIVING ECONOMY AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT HERE SO
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
WITH THESE PEOPLE ARE ACTION
PROJECT IS WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
THE DEATH YOU ALL. ON THIS IS
ALSO ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE'RE
HAVING IN THAT MOST OF OUR MEALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
INVESTING IN MILL CAPACITY THAT
IS- THAT THEY THEY'RE DOING POST
FIRE SALVAGE SO THERE IS A LOT
OF DEAD WOULD DROP CALIFORNIA
AND WHAT DO YOU. THE DOESN'T
HAPPEN OF BOTH. THAT EITHER WAY
WILL BE. CHILD OR BE A HAZARD-
IF YOU CAN SEE THIS PHOTO I'M
STILL IN THE CORNER THERE JUST
AS A SENSE OF SCALE. THIS IS ONE
OF MANY SLASH PILES ON THE IN
AND AROUND THIS YEAR REGION- AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THEY HAVE
TO GET.ENTIRE AND CHIU. DURING
SOME OF THESE BIG FIRES ENSURE
THAT THESE DIDN'T BECOME- HUGE.
THEMSELVES AND SO CREATING. FOR
THAT WOODY BIOMASS CREW. AND
WE'RE TALKING AGNOSTIC BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A LOT OF
SOLUTIONS TO GET THERE BUT WE
ARE INVESTING IN THE CLIMATE
CATALYST FUND WHICH IS GETTING
LOW INTEREST LOANS. TO PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO START OUT ON MY FROM
MILLS JOB MOST CROSS LAMINATED
TIMBER- THE BIO. FUEL ARE
PROJECTS THAT WILL CONVERT THOSE
WOODY BIOMASS PILES INTO- ON THE
START OF CRUDE OIL OR BIODIESEL
THAT WERE CONVERTED INTO. YOU
ALL OUT AND NOW WE ALLOW UP TO
EIGHTEEN STORY BUILDINGS MADE
OUT OF COMPRESSED- TIMBER WHICH
I WHICH IS REPLACE A SCHEDULING
CONFLICT. CONSTRUCTION ON EVEN
MY CRIMINALS SO NOW WOULD THAT
CAN BE USED- CAN I CAN ACTUALLY
BE USED TO HELP MEET THE HOUSING
AND- AND RECONSTRUCT SOME OF
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
LOST. WE'RE ALSO INVESTING IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOP. ACROSS THESE
AREAS FROM THE CONSERVATION
CORPS- CHU A PROGRAM CALLED THE
CHIPS PROGRAM WHICH WORKS WITH
TRIAL. THANK YOU. IT'LL ARE.
THEM THE WORK FORCE- THERE CAN
NOT TO TRY ABOUT ALPINE. SOUTH
KOREA READ IN A POINT JUST THIS
FUEL PRO AWAY. I'M IN SO AND
ALSO COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND ALL
YOU KNOW. JEWISH THAT WE ARE
CREE CAREER PATHS. ARE COMING IN
AS YOU'LL SCORE. AND ABLE TO.
I'M THE ATTIC FROM IN THE ENTIRE
. BECAUSE WE WORK AT. LEVEL IF
WE JUST DOLLAR AT THIS CRISIS
WITHOUT INVEST IN THE BUSINESSES
TO BE ABLE TO EXECUTE THESE
PROGRAMS AND THE WORK FORCE TO
PEOPLE TO BE ON THE GROUND OR
DURING THE WORK WE WOULD JUST BE
DRIVING THE CAR. THE COST OF PER
ACRE THE COST. ON HER HOUSE AND
SO WHAT WE WANTED YOU. INVEST IN
A ROBUST WORKFORCE THAT TURNS
THIS FIRE CRISIS. AND YOUR
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES. SO WE'RE-
CROSS ALL OF THESE AREAS FROM
THE CLIMB CALLOUS FUND- REALLY
EXCITING PROGRAMS IN OPR I PILES
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE BEEN
INVESTING IN WITH A BUNCH YEAR
IN OUR ACTION DOLLARS. THE AYE
LET'S WOULD BE FOR. BECAUSE WHY
OF THE- WE'VE BEEN HAVING IN ITS
- THE ANTI SIX. THAT CAN CAN.
THIS WHAT HE MEANT. IS CREE A
SUPPLIED CAN. SO CREATING V. I
LIKE THAT WORK FOR A SAN- SURE
FEET STOCKBROKER. THAT WILL BE
TO GIVE OUT TWENTY YOUR CAR. I'M
AWARE ARE GRAY TEAM PREVIOUS
COULD ONLY ABOUT TWO HERE ONE OF
EXCITING THINGS LETTER SO DE-
THIS BY. IS THAT FOR A LOT OF
THE PROBE. THERE'S ACTUALLY
SEVEN YOUR LIFE ON THE DOLLARS
WHICH MEETS. ARE THOSE THAT ARE
DOING LARGE WATER SCALE STUDIES
SHOWED WATERSHED SCALE PROJECTS
THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY- SPENDS
ATTY CAN ACTUALLY GET OUT SEVEN
YEAR CONTRACT. I'M ON THE
FEEDSTOCK COMING OUT I'M AND
ALSO SEVEN YEAR CONTRACTS ON THE
WORK FORCE SO WE CHANGED SOME OF
OUR BUSINESS PRACTICES TO BE A
STABILIZER IN THIS ECONOMY. I'M
FOR THE STATE AND JUST REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN
ENABLING US TO DO THAT- SO WE'RE
ALSO INVESTING IN PERMIT
EFFICIENCIES- AND A REMOTE KIND
OF THING. OUR THAT THAT- AND IT
WE CHANGE THE COUNTY T. PIZZA
NOW BE A THREE FOR ONE CONTRACT
SO ARE A THREE FOR ONE PERMIT
INCLUDES. THE FIRST TIME YOU
HAVE SEE QUIET WATER BOARD AND
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
PERMITS- CONDENSED INTO ONE
APPLICATION AND- A- TWO MONTH
PROCESS ON THE GROUND. SO SO
THIS IS REALLY START WE ARE
REALLY STARTING TO SEE AN IMPACT
ON THE GROUND AS WE'RE SCALING
UP THESE EFFORTS. EVEN TALKING
ABOUT PART- AND WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP AND
THE LEADERSHIP- THIS OF BE
ATHLETIC. SHE'LL BE ABLE TO
ENABLE US. TO HAVE THE TOOLS AND
RE- SAYS TO MEET CRISIS I SCALE
- FOR COMMUNITY AND- IT AWAY
THAT. ONLY DELIVERS FOR STILL.
FOR A COMMUTER SHOULD. STRONG
ACCOUNT IS AND STRAW COME. AND
STRONG A CALLER. FOR THE NEXT
TEN. THANK YOU. THAT'S ALL.
THAT'S THAT'S A LOT- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE PRISON- I'M
STILL I IT'S GOT TO A WHILE TO
ALL OF THAT- OUR- NEXT TO
SPEAKER ON THIS PANEL IS- CHIEF
TOM PORTER. THE DIRECTOR OF CAL
FIRE AND I JUST WANT TO SAY AND-
INTRODUCING THE- CHIEF PORTER-
WHO HAS RECENTLY ANNOUNCED HIS
RETIREMENT- WHAT A PLEASURE IT'S
BEEN TO WORK WITH YOU CHIEF-
AFTER THESE- CALLED TO FEW YEARS
SO I'M SURE IT SEEMS LIKE- OF A
MULTITUDE OF YEARS SAID- TO YOU
AT ANY TIME AS CHIEF- BUT TO ME
IT'S BEEN A RELATIVELY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. BUT YOU'RE A
SERVICE TO THE STATE AND
EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS OF THEIR
HOMES THEIR LIVELIHOODS IS- ARE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED AND- I
KNOW LOTS OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
MISS YOU UP MYSELF INCLUDED.
THANK YOU. NUMBER BLOOM AND-
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND ON
ALL OF YOU MOVE THEIR PERSONAL
WELL AS AS- LISTENING IN- IT HAS
BEEN QUITE A RIDE AND- I AM
HUMBLED TO HAVE ANOTHER CHANCE
AND THANKFULLY A CHANCE TO
ADDRESS ALL OF YOU TODAY AS
FRIDAY WILL BE MY LAST DAY- IN
STATE SERVICE ON END OF THE DAY
I WILL BE HANGING UP MY BADGE
AND MOVING HOME TO TAKE CARE OF
PARENTS AND MOVE ON TO OTHER
THINGS BUT I WILL BE THINKING OF
YOU ALL- DAILY- AS THIS IS MY
LIFE'S WORK. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU IN YOUR
EFFORTS TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROBLEM- THAT I'VE SPENT A
CAREER- WORKING TOWARD AN
UNDERSTANDING AND ADAPTING MY
OWN MANAGEMENT- THOUGHTS AND
IDEAS ABOUT HOW WE- FIX THE
PROBLEM. AND I HAVE TO- COMMAND
. IMMENSELY JESSICA MORSE WHO IS
IN MY TERMS RELATIVELY NEW TO
THE SPACE OF FOREST MANAGEMENT
AND ALL THE HOLISTIC APPROACH
THAT NEEDS TO BE- UNDERTAKEN TO
GET US WHERE WE NEED TO GO AND
HER PRESENTATION WAS VERY VERY
ON POINT WITH EVERYTHING. THAT I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO DO AND IT'S
PART OF OUR COLLABORATION AND
ARE WORKING ON THE CROSS
GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THE SMARTEST BEST
SCIENTISTS HELPED US TO
DETERMINE WHICH WAY TO GO AND
HOW TO GET THERE AND SO. WITH
THAT- IT CAN'T BE UNDERSTATED
THE VALUE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
WILDFIRE- AND FOREST RESILIENCY
TASK FORCE. THAT GROUP OF WHICH
I AM A CHARTER MEMBER- IS REALLY
SETTING THE COURSE WITH NINETY
NINE TASKS THAT ARE IN PLACE AND
WE ARE MOVING ON. MUCH OF WHICH
COVERS WHAT JESSICA JUST-
COVERED IN HER PRESENTATION AS
WELL AS ITS DOVE TAILED INTO-
PREVIOUS BUDGET REQUEST THE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION A BILLION
EXCUSE ME. EASY TO MESS THAT UP
WITH SOMETHING I'LL TELL YOU IN
A MINUTE. BUT THE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION GALLONS OF THE- THE TASK
FORCE TASKS OR DOVETAILED AND
FUTURE RAFTS- THAT WE- EXPECT
WILL BE- IN FUTURE BUDGETS WILL
ALSO BE DOVETAILED INTO THAT
PLAN. SUPER EXCITING- AND SO.
COMING BACK FOR JUST A MINUTE
WHY WHY AND HOW HAVE I COME TO
THIS CONCLUSION. SIMPLY THIS- I
COME FROM A DEEP LINE UP FOR ST
STE. MY GREAT GRANDFATHER WAS IN
. ONE OF HE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
. FORESTRY CLASS AT THE BILTMORE
ESTATE IN NORTH CAROLINA. HE
ENTERED INTO THAT AFTER A
CONVERSATION WITH GIFFORD
PINCHOT HE LEFT HIS SURGICAL
BUSINESS HE WAS A SURGICAL
DOCTOR AND HE LEFT THAT BECAUSE
HE BELIEVED SO MUCH IN WHAT
GIFFORD PINCHOT WAS TALKING
ABOUT. MULTI USE MULTI VALUE.
SAVE NATURAL RESOURCES FOR THE
NATIONAL GUARD. MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER ENTERED THE BILTMORE
FORESTRY SCHOOL IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN.
IF YOU CAME TO CALIFORNIA AS THE
FIRST. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FORRESTER. IN THE NIGHT IN THE
EIGHTEEN NINETIES. AND SPENT
SEVERAL YEARS TRANSPLANTS WERE
IN BACK BETWEEN COAST TO COAST
WASHINGTON DC. CALIFORNIA AND
HIS HIS ASSIGNMENT WAS TO SURVEY
THE PUBLIC LANDS AND IDENTIFY
THESE FOREST RESERVES. FROM THIS
THE BORDER WITH MEXICO TO THE
BORDER WITH CANADA. HE DID THAT
ON HORSEBACK. AND SO I CARRIED
THIS WITH ME. MY ENTIRE CAREER
AND I'VE- I'M A STUDENT AND A
HISTORIAN OF WHAT WAS HAPPENING
OVER THAT PERIOD OF TIME. MINING
WAS AHEAD OF THAT RIGHT SO WE
HAD THE MINERS. PUTTING WOOD
INTO SMOKE IN THE AIR FOR
SMELTING IN DESTRUCTION IS ON
THE LANDSCAPE UNDERGROUND'S TO
KEEP TUNNELS FROM COLLAPSING.
AND DOING IT TAKING EVERYTHING
THAT WAS CLOSEST AND EASIEST TO
GRAB. THEN WE ALSO HAD HUMAN
CAUSED FIRES INCREASE. WE HAD
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT THIS THIS
KIND OF EUROPEAN SETTLEMENT POST
. HUMAN FIRE STARTING THAT WERE
NOT MEANT FOR MANAGEMENT OF THE
RESOURCES AS THE FOREBEARS OF
CALIFORNIA INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DOING FOR THOUSANDS OF
YEARS PRIOR TO THAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT AFTER NOW ALMOST WITH THE
SPANISH. A CENTURY OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION. AND A CENTURY OF
PUTTING- LEGAL ACTION AGAINST
PEOPLE WHO WERE STARTING FIRES
INCLUDING INDIGENOUS. UP TO THIS
POINT OF MINING. THEN MOVING
FORWARD A RECOGNITION THAT WE
HAVE TO SAVE THESE RESOURCES FOR
THE NATIONAL SECURITY AND
NATIONAL MEETS. THAT'S WHEN THE
FOR SERVICE BEGINS I'M NOT GONNA
TAKE IT A HUNDRED YEARS FORWARD
WHAT I'M GONNA TAKE YOU TO
NINETEEN TEN. USE IN NINETEEN
TEN. AGAIN HOST. SETTLEMENT WE
SAW BE WORST FIRE SEASON IN
HISTORY. CALIFORNIA HAD FIRES
BUT CALIFORNIA WASN'T THE FOCUS
IT WAS IN THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST
OUT TO IDAHO LITTLE BIT OF
MONTANA AND THEN UP INTO THE
BRITISH COLUMBIA. SEVEN MILLION
ACRES BURNED. SEVEN MILLION
ACRES. THAT WAS IN FIVE STATES.
SO NOW FAST FORWARD. NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE. INTERESTING YEAR
THAT'S THE FIRST YEAR THAT I
STARTED FORESTRY SCHOOL AT UC
BERKELEY. I DIDN'T KNOW MY
GRANDFATHER HAD BEEN IN IN A
FORESTRY SCHOOL HUNDRED YEARS
PRIOR BUT I DO NOW. AND I DO
KNOW THAT THERE'S SOMETHING IN
ME THAT DROVE ME TO THIS
PROFESSION THAT DROVE ME TO-
WHAT I BELIEVE WE NEED TO BE
DOING TO PROTECT OUR RESOURCES.
AND PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES. ALL
PROTECT OUR FORESTS AND
WATERSHEDS. SO FORESTRY SCHOOL.
THAT'S OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO
RIGHT SO THIRTY PLUS YEAR CAREER
FOCUSING ALL MY ATTENTION NEVER
HEARING OFF OF THE FORESTRY PATH
SINCE THAT TIME. I COME TO YOU.
HAVING SEEN HER A TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AND TEN YEARS
AFTER THE BIG BIRD. THAT DWARFED
THE BIG BIRD. WE ALMOST MET THE
BIG BURNED ACREAGE JUST IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE. JYJ'S HUGE
CHANGE AND SWING THE POPULATION
WHEN MY GREAT GRANDFATHER CAME
TO CALIFORNIA WAS AROUND ONE
POINT TWO MILLION PEOPLE. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWENTY MILLION
PEOPLE YEAH OVER FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE. WE'VE GOT A DIFFERENT
SCENARIO WE HAVE TO THINK OF
THINGS IN A DIFFERENT WAY. IT IS
ABOUT STATE PROTECTING THE
RESOURCES IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING
THE PEOPLE IT'S CRAP ABOUT
PROTECTING- AND HARDENING
COMMUNITIES AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IN WAYS THAT MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER NEVER COULD HAVE. WE
HAVE THE SCIENCE. AND THE
BACKING OF GOOD MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES AND THE ABILITY TO
ADJUST OUR MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
OVER TIME. AND USE THE TASK
FORCEWORK AND THE NINETY NINE
TASKS THAT ARE THERE AND IT
LOOKED GREAT THANK FULL BUDGET
REQUEST THAT WERE EVER BUDGETS
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON WITH
CURRENTLY. TO ADAPT ARE MANAGED
AND EVEN GET BETTER OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. AND CARRY THIS
INTO THE FUTURE. AND THOSE ARE
THE THINGS THAT EXCITE ME ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE I'D ALSO MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO LEAVE AT THE MOMENT
BUT I AM VERY VERY EXCITED ABOUT
WHERE THINGS ARE HEADED COME
BACK TO GET ME AS THE STATE FIRE
CHIEF AND AS THE STATE FORESTER
I GET A CHANCE TO INTERACT
NATIONALLY WITH MY COUNTERPARTS.
IN PARTICULAR. WITH THE STATE
FORESTERS. I HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THEM
THANKFULLY ACTUALLY CO THAT HAS
BROUGHT US CLOSER TOGETHER
BECAUSE WE'RE ABLE TO MEET MORE
WITHOUT TRAVEL. AND WE HAVE BEEN
MEETING AND TALKING. AND IT IS
ABSOLUTELY STRIKING. THAT
NATIONWIDE. STATE FORESTERS ARE
SEEING VIRTUALLY THE SAME ISSUES
ACROSS THE BOARD. NOT ONLY ARE
WE SEEING THE SAME ISSUES. WE'RE
HAVING THE SAME INTEREST AND
EXCITEMENT ABOUT WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS FINALLY
GOING TO INVEST. IN THEIR LACK
OF MANAGEMENT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. ABOUT THEY
STARTED WITH STRONG MANAGEMENT
THERE'S BEEN SOME THINGS THAT
ARE SLOW THINGS DOWN WE NEED TO
GET BACK ON TRACK I SEE IT THE
INVESTMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ASK. WORKING TO GET
BACK ON TRACK. IT'S NOT UNLIKE
WE'VE BEEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE JUST A COUPLE YEARS
BEHIND. SO I EXPECT THAT THIS
INVESTMENT NATIONWIDE. AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS GOING TO
BE SOMETHING THAT REALLY
ELEVATES. THE PRACTICE OF
FORESTRY AND FOREST MANAGEMENT A
NATIONWIDE THIS IS A TIME THAT
FORESTRY IS IN A REVIVAL MODE
THAT I COULDN'T EVEN HAVE
IMAGINED WHEN I STARTED INTO THE
PRACTICE OF FORCED WE ARE AT A
POINT IN TIME WHERE WE ARE
SEEING A TIDAL SHIFT. THAT IS
MUCH LIKE THE BEGINNING. AT
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE. NIGHTS
EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS PERIOD
AND WE HAVE TO. HAVE TO SEIZE
THAT MOMENT WE NEED TO PUSH
FORWARD WE NEED TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE GONNA
ADAPT AND GET BETTER OVER TIME
SO PERFECT IS NOT THAT STRONG
WHAT WE'RE STRIVING FOR IN THE
FIRST GO. WE ARE STRIVING TO GET
THINGS DONE AND ADAPT OUR
MANAGEMENT AND GET BETTER AND
BETTER AND BETTER SO MY GRAND
KIDS AND YOUR GRANDKIDS CAN SEE
THE FOR US THAT WE ALL GREW UP.
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO ME. WITH
REGARD TO- KIND OF SPECIFICS.
THEIR BADNESS SOME INVESTMENTS
AND THIS COMES BACK TO THAT
WORST WORKFORCE- IN SOME
RESPECTS WE WE'VE DONE
INVESTMENTS AND YOU'VE HEARD
PRESENTATIONS ABOUT THE FIRE
ADAPTED FIFTY PROJECT HIGHWAY
FIFTY GOING UP THROUGH OUR
PLACERVILLE SO- SLY PARK AND
THEN ON UP TO LAKE TAHOE-
JESSICA COVERED VERY WELL KIND
OF THE EAST SIDE OF THAT AND THE
SOUTHEAST SIDE OF THAT FIRE.
WELL AS IT BURNED UP INTO THE
BASEMENT. WHAT IS. NOT AS WELL
COVERED- BUT IS AT LEAST AS
EQUALLY. GREAT IS ALL OF THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE IN AND AROUND
SLY PARK. I ADAPTED FIFTY WORK
ON ALL LANDS PRIVATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WATER DISTRICT A DAY
IN THE FOREST SERVICE BROWN ALL
IN IN CONJUNCTION WITH EACH
OTHER AND CONNECTED TO EACH
OTHER. THAT WORK KEPT THAT FIRE
FROM BURNING BACK INTO
PLACERVILLE SLY PARK PLACERVILLE
AND POSSIBLY EVEN DOWN IN EL
DORADO HILLS WHERE THESE FIRES
HAVE BEEN BURNING ALL OF THAT
WAS POSSIBLE. AND I SAW THAT ON
SOME OF THE MAPS THAT WERE
PROPOSED FOR THE- FIRE
PROGRESSION THAT COULD HAPPEN
OVER A SEVEN DAY PERIOD. WE
STOPPED IT THE ONLY WAY WE
STOPPED IT WAS BECAUSE OF THE
FUELS WORK THAT HAPPENED DONE.
THE BILL BACK EIGHT YEARS WE
STARTED THAT PROJECT ROUGHLY
EIGHT YEARS AGO. IT TAKES TIME
TO GET THERE. WE STARTED THAT
PROJECT THAT WE HAD. ONE ONLY
ONE CONTRACTOR LOCAL TO
CALIFORNIA THAT BID ON THE
PROJECT WORK THE REST CAME FROM
OUTSIDE THE STATE. OVER EIGHT
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ADDING MONEY TO
THIS. GUESS WHAT THERE ARE NOW
OVER EIGHT CONTRACTORS LOCAL
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS BIDDING
ON THESE PROJECTS EVERY SINGLE
TIME. YEAH WE'RE STILL BRINGING
PEOPLE IN FROM OUTSIDE THE STATE
BECAUSE WE NEED TO WE HAVE SO
MUCH WORK TO DO AND WE GOT THE
MONEY TO DO IT WE NEED TO KEEP
DOING THAT BUT WE BY INVESTING
AND CONTINUOUSLY INVESTING WE
ARE SEEING. THE GROWTH OF LOCAL
BUSINESS LOCAL PEOPLE DOING THE
WORK THAT'S PROTECTING THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES WHICH- AGAIN THIS
THIS IS SOMETHING. THAT I HAVE
BEEN. HOPING FOR MY ENTIRE
CAREER. YOU KNOW I SPENT MOST OF
MY CAREER INSTANCE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN IN THE IT WITHIN
HEALTHCARE. ALLEN I WOULD HAVE
KILLED TO HAVE. AS MANY LOCAL
CONTRACTORS AVAILABLE AS THERE
ARE IN IN EL DORADO COUNTY- IN.
ALL OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LET
ALONE ONE COUNTY WE JUST DIDN'T
HAVE A WE IMPORTED. CONTRACTORS
FROM MORE SAN JUAN NEVADA CITY
SONORA TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
THE EARLY TWENTY TWO TWO
THOUSAND IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
THE BEETLE KILL AND THE FIRES
THAT WE WERE HAVING THEIR- SO.
COME BACK TO THOSE PROJECTS WERE
GREAT THERE'S- TWO THOUSAND
THREE WHEN I REMEMBER THE CEDAR
FIRE. YES LEAN THE LARGEST FIRE
IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. THAT
FIRE BURNED INTO FUELS PROJECTS
THAT WE HAD DONE INTO.
PRESCRIBED BURNS THAT WE HAD
DONE IN THE STATE PARK. WE
AMERICA STATE PARK. FOUR HUNDRED
ACRES OF TIMBER FOREST. HÌNH
FOREST BIG OLD TREES LOOK LIKE
ANYWHERE IN SIERRA. WE'RE SAVED
THE ONLY STAND OF TREES SAVED IN
THAT FIRE ON THAT ON THAT STATE
PARK WAS BECAUSE WE DID A FOUR
HUNDRED ACRE PRESCRIBED BURN. ON
THE OTHER SIDE IN CHAPARRAL
CHAPARRAL PROJECTS THAT WERE
FUEL BREAKS PRESCRIBED BURNS AND
OTHER THINGS KEPT THAT FIRE FROM
MOVING FURTHER SOUTH AND
SWEEPING INTO- COMMUNITIES ON
THE ON THE SIDES OUTSIDE THAT
WOULD HAVE. CONNECTED WITH
ANOTHER FIRE THAT WAS BURNING IT
WAS ONLY FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
THE TIME BUT THAT WAS THE- TIME
MINE FIRE THOSE FIRES COULD'VE
AND PROBABLY WOULD'VE BURN
TOGETHER IT HADN'T BEEN FOR
FUELS PROJECT WORK. THAT WAS
DONE ALONG THE- THE INTERSTATE
EIGHTY CORRIDOR SO. WHAT WE NEED
TO DO GOING FORWARD WHAT IS THE
ONE THING THAT WE HAVE. WHITE
RACKED THE NUMBER THAT. MY
ASSERTION TO YOU IS WE HAVE WE
ARE CRACK IN THE NOT ON EVERY
SINGLE THING SAVE ONE. AND WE
ARE STARTING TO WORK WORK ON
THAT ONE. THAT IS REFORESTATION
. AND JESSICA JESSICA MENTIONED
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN INVESTMENTS
WE'RE VERY HAPPY WITH THE
INVESTMENTS IN IN OUR REPORT FOR
STATION CAPABILITIES ARE SEED
BANK AND OUR CEILING
CAPABILITIES. BUT REFORESTATION
IF WE DON'T PUT THAT AT THE
FOREFRONT PARTICULARLY WITH THE
LARGE FIRES WE HAVE AND THIS IS
BY AND LARGE. A FEDERAL ISSUE WE
HAVE OUR SPACE WE ARE PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS INDUSTRY'S GONNA TAKE
CARE OF ITSELF PRETTY MUCH. BUT
WE NEED TO GET TREES BACK IN THE
GROUND. IT'S TOO MUCH IT TOO
MANY OF THESE FIRES HAVE BURNED
INTENSELY AND BURNS THE SEEDBED
RIGHT OUT OF THE SOIL WE NEED TO
ACTIVELY GO BACK AND PUT TREES
IN THE GROUND THAT'S GONNA TAKE
SOME EFFORT AND TAKE SOME
ATTENTION AND SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO DO IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS
DOWNSTREAM SO. THAT'S ONE THING
THAT I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
MORE- MORE IN AND MORE INVEST
IN. SO WE'RE TAKING YOU DOWN
THIS ROAD AND I STARTED A LITTLE
BIT IN THIS SPACE. BUT I WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT THAT DEEPLY
AFFECTS THE STATE'S FORRESTER
AND I CAN SAY THAT FOR ANOTHER
THREE DAYS PROBABLY AND THEN
I'LL BE THE REPORT RETIRED STATE
FORESTER. AND I THINK THAT IS.
ACTUALLY THE MOST PROUD THING
THAT I HAVE- SITTING IN THIS
POST STANDING IN THIS POST. BUT
MY CAREER ONLY FOCUSED ON
FORESTRY FOREST MANAGEMENT AND
ALL THAT GOES WITH THAT THE
MULTI DISCIPLINARY. KIND OF
SPACE THAT THAT TAKES. IT SAYS
IT WITH EVERY FIBER OF MY BEING
THAT WE ARE ON THE RIGHT PATH.
THINGS ARE HAPPENING. AND
THEY'RE HAPPENING IN THE RIGHT
WAY TO GIVE US A FOOTHOLD. TO
KEEP ON GOING AND IT'S ALL OF
OUR- RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP IT GOING. WE NEED
TO KEEP IT GOING. AND YOU'VE
YOU'VE ALL HEARD ME SAY THIS I
BELIEVE. IF NOT NO MY
ADMONISHMENT MY ADMONISHMENT IS. EVERY ACRE IN CALIFORNIA CAN
AND WILL BURN SOME DAY. AND I
BELIEVE WHOLEHEARTEDLY. THE LAST
FIBER OF MY BEING. THAT GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM'S I ALREADY SAT BY
HIS TASK FORCE WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCY TASK FORCE AND
THE NINETY NINE TASKS THAT ARE
THERE ARE PUTTING US ON THAT
ROAD. WHAT DOES ON THAT ROAD TO
BE A READY CALIFORNIA FOR
WILDFIRES. THANK YOU. WELL I
THANK YOU CHIEF THANK YOU- FOR
THE HISTORY LESSON THAT TO BY MY
CALCULATION WHICH NOBODY SHOULD
RELY ON- TOOK US BACK A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO YEARS- TO THE
PRESENT THANK YOU FOR THE
INSPIRATION AND THANK YOU FOR-
ALL OF YOUR YEARS OF SERVICE-
I'M SURE YOU'LL USE SAID THE
NEXT THREE DAYS- IF EFFICIENTLY
AS YOU DO WITH WITH WITH ALL OF
YOUR TIME BUT I HOPE YOU'LL
PAUSE- TO LISTEN TO THE-
GRATITUDE OF THOSE THAT YOU WORK
WITH AND OF THOSE WHO ARE-
RESIDENTS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO WHO- OWE YOU A
DEBT OF GRATITUDE FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU. CUP WE'RE
GOING TO. MOVE I HOPE YOU'LL
STICK AROUND FOR QUESTIONS-
GREAT THANK YOU- OUR NEXT-
SPEAKER AND I'LL I'M GOING TO
ASK. OUR OUR NEXT FOR SPEAKERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
PRESENTATIONS ARE. A CONCISE
OTHERWISE GONNA RUN OUT OF TIME
HERE- BUT OUR NEXT FIGURES MATT
DIAZ SAYS. AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION WELCOMES
ARE. THANK YOU. RIGHT AFTER
DINNER I THINK YOU'RE MY NOT ON
. TRY THAT. YEAH. AND NOW WE'RE
HEARING THAT LIGHTS NOT ON TRY
PUSHING THE BUTTON. I'M NOT A
HOLD FOR YOU SEE THAT'S A VERY
FAR I BE ABLE TO TRY ALSO. NO.
FRAZIER DID I MAKE DID I MEAN
YOU AT. IS IT WORKING NOW. TO
THINK WHEN YOU SPEAK. I'VE ONLY.
TRY AGAIN. ARE YOU GOING TO BE
ON TRACK. YOU CAN TURN THE ONE
ON THE OTHER SIDE ALL RIGHT
THERE. TURN THAT OFF. THE. IT IS
A WORK OF. GOOD JUST ONE TWO. GO. IF THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT. I
WILL BE ASSISTING TO OUR- SURE
THOSE COMMITTEE INTO SOME OF
VALLEY MAY DS THE PRESENT
ACCOUNT FORESTRY ASSOCIATION AND
I- JUST WANTED TO SAY I EXPRESS
GRATITUDE TODAY FOR- CALIFORNIA
BE REACHED OUT TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTS THE
GREATEST MAJORITY OF THE FOREST
PRODUCTS SECTOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. INCLUSIVE INCLUSIVE
OF THE OF ALMOST ALL THE MILLS
OF THE NEAR PLANTS COGENERATION
PLANTS AN APPROXIMATE THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES ACROSS
THE STATE. I DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE
ONE BRIEF SECOND TOOK DOLLARS
CHIEF PORTER ARCHIE PORTER'S
BEEN A COLLEAGUE OF MINE A
FRIEND OF MINE FOR A VERY LONG
TIME SO I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HIS OUR RETIREMENT I
KNOW HE'S NOT A MAN OF FANFARE
BUT OF THOMAS TO A LISTING I
JUST WANT TO SAY I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE. AND I WOULD ALSO
SAY THAT THE TIME THAT I SPENT
WORKING WITH CHIEF PORTER DOES
REPRESENT THE- PARTNERSHIP WHICH
THAT'S IS NECESSARY THAT
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN. INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE IS CLEARLY. HIS GOAL
OR THEIR IS CLEARLY CRITICAL
ROLE OVER THE OF LAST COUPLE
YEAR IN THIS HAS BEEN. WITH WHAT
COULD BE NOTHING LESS IN TURMOIL
AS IT AS IT RELATES TO WILDFIRE
CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OVE THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIRST SEASON IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FIRE SEASON PARDON ME- IT NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
. NATIONAL FOREST LANDS ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE EXPERIENCED. HIGH
MORTALITY- OR WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER HIGH SEVERITY WILDFIRE
OR MODERATE SEVERITY WILDFIRE.
AND AT THIS POINT- THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT THAT THAT'S
WELL REPRESENTED MOTION SIR I
WELL I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
PARTNERSHIP IS WELL KNOWN THAT
WE NEED A AND GOT. A ROBUST
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IN ORDER
TO MEET OUR GOALS OF TREATING
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES ON
STATE PROPERTY OR STATE STATE
AND PRIVATE LANDS AS WELL AS
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES ON.
FEDERAL LANDS BUT WE ALREADY
TRUE TRIAGE STATE. THE NUMBER OF
DEAD TREES OF WHICH THIS
INDUSTRY IS TRYING TO METABOLIZE
ON IT'S ONLY AND I WAS STANDING
OUTSIDE ON. PRIVATE AREN'T
EITHER A PRIVATE OR- PUBLIC
LANDS- IS THE TREE IS THE MAIN
GOAL OF OUR ASSOCIATION AT THIS
AND MEMBERS OF OUR ASSOCIATION.
FOR INSTANCE IN THE DIXIE FIRE
ALONE. UP ON PRIVATE LANDS
NEARLY ONE POINT SIX BILLION
BOARD FEET HAS BIRD THAT IS ON
THE PRIVATE LANDS ONLY THAT IS
NOT WITHSTANDING ANY PUBLIC
PLANS. ARE STATE PROCESSES ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION BOARD
FEET IN A GIVEN YEAR. THE POINT
BEING THAT THAT ONE
CONFLAGRATION HAS RESULTED IN
MORTALITY OF MORE BOARD FEET ONE
FELL SWOOP AND WE ARE ABLE TO
PROCESS ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE.
IN A ONE THANK AND THAT AND THAT
BEEN THE PERIMETER OF THE DIXIE
FIRE. IT'S LITERALLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO CLEAN IT UP AND IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO PROCESS IT AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT. AND AGAIN WITH
THE WITH THE PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DESIRE FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO
MEET OTHER GOALS WE HAVE SET
FORTH- IT'S GOING TO BE VERY
CHALLENGING. SO WE A LOT ABOUT
THE POINT FOR BILLION. FOUR
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET AND I WILL SAY.
WITHOUT HESITATION CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS THAT ALLOCATION OF
FUNDING- I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THAT WOULD BE THE BASELINE
FUNDING THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
INTO THE FUTURE TO TRY TO COMBAT
THE ISSUES OR THE CRISIS THAT
WE'RE FACING- WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT FIRE
PREVENTION IN THE SPACE OF
FORESTRY- WE KNEW THE FIRE
PREVENTION FOR DECADES AND FUND
IT WOULD NEED TO BE FUNDED AND
EXECUTED- BUT WE'VE NOW GOTTEN
TO THE POINT WHERE POST FIRE
RECOVERY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
PLAY A POINT. ARE IS GONNA HAVE
TO PLAY A ROLE IN FUTURE
ALLOCATIONS AS RELATES TO THE
BUDGET. AND BEYOND THAT WE NEED
TO START LOOKING AT ALL THE
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX I WOULD
ALSO SUGGEST POST FIRE RECOVERY
COUPLED WITH BIOMASS. BIOMASS
INDUSTRY TO GET IT UP AND
RUNNING AS A BRIDGE AS WE LOOK
INTO INVESTMENTS INTO FUTURE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WILL COME TO
SCALE. WE HAVE SEVERAL IDOL
BIOGAS PLANTS OF THE STATE
CURRENTLY AND EVEN WITH ALL
BIOMASS FACILITIES UP AND
RUNNING ARE WE STILL DON'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO GET WHERE WE
NEED TO BE BUT TO HAVE I DON'T
BOMBYCILLIDAE ASSUMES- SHORT
SIGHTED. TO A CERTAIN EXTENT- WE
DO WORKFORCE- JUST GOT MORE SAID
TOUCHED ON IT- WE NEED FOR
FUTURE INVESTMENTS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE BREAKS WE
HAVE A GREAT OUR PROGRAM IS
SHASTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I SAY
REPLICATION OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAMS TO OTHER. INSTITUTIONS
OF THE J. C. STATUS SYSTEM
SPREADING THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE A SOLID STEP FORWARD.
AND I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
THAT IN TODAY'S WORLD WE OPERATE
IN CALIFORNIA UNDER FIRE
PROTECTION SYSTEM AND I KNOW
THAT WE'RE TALKING TODAY ABOUT
FIRE PREVENTION. BUT WE CANNOT
DECOUPLE THE DISCUSSION OF
SUPPRESSION AS WELL- WE NEED TO
HAVE A ROBUST SUPPRESSION FORCE
I THINK IT'S PRETTY WELL
UNDERSTOOD THE CALIFORNIA SHORT
SEVERAL HAND CREWS THIS YEAR TO
THE TO THE PROBABLY SEVENTY TO
EIGHTY AND CREWS. THAT SAME
PATTERNS EXIST WITHIN OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS INFRASTRUCTURE
AS WELL AND I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT BACKFILLING THAT
THAT. AIM TO SHORTAGE SO THAT WE
CAN GET ON THESE FIRES AND GET
THEM OUT SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER DURING FIRE SEASON. AGAIN
WE'VE INVESTED ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN THE PREVENTION AND IF
WE HAVE A ROBUST SUPPRESSION OF
FORCE THAT'S ABLE TO GET THESE
FIRES OUT EARLY THAT MEANS OF
ACRES WILL BE RETAINED AND THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY INVEST THE MONEY
AND THAT WE'RE INTENDED TO
INVEST IN FIRE PREVENTION.
BURNING. HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES A YEAR. I HIGH INTENSE
. IS TAKING FOR BURKE. OF AND WE
NEED TO BE. PUTTING THESE FIRES
OUT EARLY DURING FIRE SEASON SO
THAT WE CAN INVEST IMPROPERLY AS
IT RELATES TO- FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES. I'VE ALSO HEARD A
LOT ABOUT VINCE VERSUS SUCCESS
TODAY. AND AGAIN I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR CALIFORNIA IS A VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INVESTMENTS
MADE IN THE SPACE OF FIRE
PREVENTION AND WILL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THAT. BUT THE BENCHMARKS
OF SUCCESS I BELIEVE COULD BE.
ARE FOCUSED ON LAST HIGH
SEVERITY ACRES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN AS SOON WE ARE IN AN
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS DOWNSTREAM
WATERS. THE LONGS OF THE FOLKS
IN THE BAY AREA AS WELL
SACRAMENTO AND LA BASED SAID. I
MEAN THIS WITH WILDFIRES BUT A
PART OF FORESTRY FOR A VERY VERY
LONG TIME. HISTORICALLY WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO METABOLIZE THAT WE
ARE AT A CRISIS THAT HAS GONE
BEYOND THE BOUNDARIES OF THE
FOREST PRODUCTS SECTOR OR THE
NATIONAL FOREST AND IS NOW
AFFECTING EVERYBODY IN THE STATE. AND TAKING ACTION TO TRY TO
CHANGE. ASPECTS OF OUR SYSTEM
BEFORE THE ONSET OF THIS THAT'S
FIRE SEASON WHICH I REMIND
EVERYBODY IS REALLY ONLY MONTHS
AWAY. SO THAT WOULD CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS AND I APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- WILL PROCEED NOW WITH-
JOHN ANDERSON FROM MENDOCINO
HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANY WELCOME
SIR. THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
BLOOM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND SOME OF THE MEMBERS SHALL
OCCUR- MY NAME IS JOHN ANDERSON
DIRECTOR FORCED POLICY FOR
MISSING ON HUMBOLDT REDWOOD
COMPANIES. HI TWO ONE I THINK
CHIEF PORTER FOR A SERVICE- IT
WE'RE GONNA MISS YOU AROUND HERE
BUT HOPEFULLY WON'T BE A
STRANGER. AND LYFT CHIEF PORTER
I TOO AM A PROUD FORRESTER- IT
BUT IT'S BEEN PAINFUL TO WATCH
OUR FOREST DETERIORATE DO THESE
WILDFIRES- WHERE WILDFIRES HAVE
HAVEN'T REMOVED OVERSTOCK STANDS
OR SEEN THE DROUGHT KILLED
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION OR SO DEAD
TREES EVEN WHEN THAT. AND THAT
THAT'S TO THE OVER STOCKING OF
THE FORESTERS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION TACTICS. THAT OTHERS
HAVE TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY-
THE FUNDING IS ON PRESIDENT- BUT
- ARE NEEDED ENSURE THAT THIS
FUNDING ACHIEVED GOALS FOR WHICH
THEY WERE ESTABLISHED. SO TODAY
I JUST WANT TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON-
FOR TOPICS PERMIT EFFICIENCIES
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR GETTING TO
THIS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES. A LITTLE BIT ON BIOMASS
LITTLE BIT ON FEDERAL LANDS. SO
IN CALIFORNIA IF WE ARE GOING TO
THIN OUT OF FOREST- TO REDUCE
FEELS AND WE'RE GOING TO
COMMERCIALIZE SOME OF THOSE
TREES WE HAVE A THREE. PERMIT
PROCESS HAT IS DUPLICATIVE- WE
HAVE TO APPLY FOR THE TIMBER
HARVEST PLAN WITH CAL FIRE WE
HAVE TO GET. A DEEPER DUPLICATE
A PERMIT FROM THE WATER BOARDS.
AND ALSO FROM DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. AND THERE'S BEEN
AND NUMBER OF EFFORTS- NONE OF
WHICH I HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL AT
STREAMLINING THAT PERMIT
COMBINING ALL THREE OF THOSE
PERMITS INTO ONE NOT HAVING
THREE STATE AGENCIES DO THE SAME
THING. SO I'M GLAD TO SEE IN THE
BUDGET THAT THERE'S FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO. STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS FOR PERMIT EFFICIENCY-
BUT WE'VE HAD A BAD TRACK RECORD
OF TRYING TO GET THEIR THERE'S
BEEN. FIVE PASSED DIRECTIVES. TO
STREAMLINE THE PERMIT PROCESS
THE FIRST ONE WAS. EIGHTY
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO AUTHORED BY
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE.
THAT REQUIRED AGENCIES TO
IDENTIFY AND IMPLEMENT
EFFICIENCIES IN THE REGULATION
OF TIMBER HARVESTING BUT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN. LIKE I SAID ANY
IMPROVEMENTS ON THAT. FOUR OTHER
ONES BROWN A FORMER GOVERNOR
BROWN HAD AN EXECUTIVE ORDER-
THAT. MANDATED VARIOUS AGENCIES
TO SYNCHRONIZE AND EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS. GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN
TWENTY TWENTY- CHARGE THE-
THAT'S RESOURCE IS AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT ACTIONS TO INCREASE
THE PACE AND SCALE ENVIRONMENTAL
REST- RESTORATION- IN IN THE-
WILD FIRE FOREST RESILIENCY
ACTION PLAN AND THAT CAME OUT IN
JANUARY HAD A- KEY ACTION THAT-
STATED THAT. THE PERMIT
SYNCHRONIZATION WORK PLAN SHALL
BE COMPLETED BY THE END OF THE
YEAR. THIS YEAR. AND SB FOUR
FIVE SIX BY LAYERED CALLED FOR
PERMANENT SYNCHRONIZATION AS
WELL THAT WAS JUST APPROVED. SO
GIVEN THAT WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN
ANYWHERE ON THIS- THE COMMITTEE
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER SOME KIND
OF REPORTING MECHANISM. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WOULD REDUCE SPEND
THOSE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PERMANENT SYNCHRONIZATION THAT
IT GETS DONE THIS TIME. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ON GETTING TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHONE YOU HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THIS-
HEARING THAT- WE'RE HAVING A
HARD TIME GETTING TO HOW MANY
ACRES AND HOW MANY PROJECTS HAVE
BEEN DONE AND SO WE NEED A POINT
PERSON TO BE IN CHARGE OF ALL
THE VARIOUS PROJECTS THAT ARE
GOING ON BY VARIOUS AGENCIES
CONSERVANCY IS FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS AND HAVE THAT PERSON
HAVE THE AUTHORITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OVERSEEING
GETTING TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES PRIORITIZING PROJECTS
MAKING SURE THEY'RE GOING IN
AREAS AND WE DON'T HAVE THIS-
PATCHWORK OF. PROJECTS GOING ON
- WE'VE GOT THIRTY THREE MILLION
ACRES OF FORESTS IF WE CAN'T GET
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A
YEAR. THAT'S HARD TO SEE WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE ANY DENT IN THIS
ISSUE SO WE NEED A LARGE
LANDSCAPING. PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED- NEED TO HAPPEN
NOW AND IT'S BEEN A EXPEDITED
MANNER- WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
BIOMASS TODAY. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A TON OF IT MILLIONS
OF TONS OF BIOMASS- MOST THE
TIME THIS IS BURNED OUT IN THE
WOODS AND THAT DOESN'T HELP OUR
MISSION'S GOALS HERE IN THE
STATE- AND SO WE NEED TO GET THE
THAT INTO A BIOMASS FACILITY.
AND BY OUR ESTIMATE WE NEED
ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO GET THAT
MATERIAL TO A BIOMASS FACILITY-
SO THAT'S- CONSIDERING THE COST
OF WILDFIRE THAT'S CHEAP
INSURANCE. AND THEN- FEDERAL
FOREST LANDS- CHIEF PORTER
TOUCHED ON REFORESTATION AND YES
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE JUST
IN BETWEEN- TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN- FOR SERVICE
LAS SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND ACRES OF FOREST THAT
BURNED TO A DEFORESTED CONDITION
AND ONLY TWENTY NINE PERCENT.
WERE REPLANTED AND OF COURSE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THAT'S- MORE OF A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER SO- IT WOULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL FOR THE STATE TO COME
UP WITH SOME KIND OF MATCH
FUNDING TO HELP OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS GET THOSE REFORESTED
BACK TO. THEIR CARBON
SEQUESTERING ABILITY SO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THESE ISSUES. AND
WILL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THAT-
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT SPEAKER IS LAINNYA QUINN
DAVIDSON FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. OKAY MORNING
EVERYONE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR INCLUDING ME IN THE HEARING
TODAY I'M HONORED TO BE HERE- MY
NAME IS LINDA QUINN DAVIDSON AND
I AM INSPIRED BY IS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BASED
UP IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND WHILE
I'M PHYSICALLY. LOCATED HERE ON
THE NORTH COAST- I WORK ON FIRE
RELATED ISSUES ACROSS THE STATE
AND EVEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
REALLY MY PRIMARY PASSION
FOCUSES PRESCRIBED FIRE WITH THE
BENEFICIAL USE OF FIRE AS A
TOOL- SO I DON'T HAVE TO TELL
YOU HOW IMPORTANT PRESCRIBED
FIRES YOU'RE SEEING ALL THE
COVERAGE IN THE MEDIA AND- I'M
SURE YOU ALL KNOW HOW HOW
CRITICAL IT IS FOR OUR FUTURE
WITH FIRE HERE IN CALIFORNIA- I
THINK THE STARFIRES ALMOST
BECOME HOUSEHOLD TERMINOLOGY. IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND REALLY FOR GOOD
REASON- YOU KNOW IN MANY PARTS
OF THE STATE IT'S THE MOST
ECOLOGICALLY APPROPRIATE AND
COST EFFECTIVE TOOL THAT WE HAVE
FOR MAKING OUR LANDSCAPES AND
COMMUNITIES MORE RESILIENT- IN
THE FACE OF THINGS LIKE WILDFIRE
AND DROUGHT AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ALL HAVE
THE CHANCE TO SEE THE STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCES JUST
FINALIZING BUT I CAN HONESTLY
SAY IT'S ONE OF THE BEST PLANS
I'VE SEEN ON THIS TOPIC I'M
REALLY HAPPY WITH THAT
PRIORITIES AND STRATEGIES THAT
ARE OUTLINED THERE AND MUCH OF
THAT CONTENT CAME DIRECTLY FROM
THE PRESCRIBED FIRE PRACTITIONER
COMMUNITY WHICH I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT- SO YOU KNOW
THIS LAST YEAR AS YOU'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE OTHER SPEAKERS.
THIS LAST YEAR WAS REALLY
MONUMENTAL FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE
RELATED WORK- IN IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE ADDRESS SOME OF
THE MAJOR BARRIERS TO PRESCRIBED
FIRE LIGHTING LIABILITY
INSURANCE EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
AND PROJECT FUNDING AND I WAS SO
GLAD TO SEE SO MUCH ATTENTION
AND INVESTMENT DIRECTED OFFICE
FIRE RESILIENCE WORK ON PUTTING
THE FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAMS TO
JUST COME. AND IT HEALTHCARE
LEADS- HATED FOR THE JUST CALLED
MENTION AND OF COURSE THE
REGIONAL PARK PASS PROGRAM THAT
I THINK WILL TALK ABOUT AFTER I
. DONE HERE AND THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ALL. GETTING TO UNITY THE
SUPPORT. THAT TO REALLY TO
ACTION THE PUBLIC LEVEL. AND IS
SO IMPORTANT AS WE- TRY TO
TOWARD THE GOALS WE HAVE A- THE
STATE. I WAS ALL REALLY HARD TO
SEE TE INVEST. IN THE WORK WE
DO WITH YOU KNOW. OF AGRICULTURE
AND NATURAL. FOR THE LAST YEARS
I HAVE. ON EXTRA ADVICE AND- THE
SOLE FOCUS IS ON. AND YOU CAN
AND- BEING ONLY BY I IN HARD TO-
YOU KNOW WE- OF VISORS SOMETHING
. TO WE SERVE REALLY CRITICAL
ROLE A OF CONNECTION BETWEEN
SCIENTISTS. COMMUNITIES
REGULATORS- AGENCIES
POLICYMAKERS TRIBESMAN MANAGERS
WE'RE KIND OF AT THE CENTER OF
ALL THAT WE HAVE ALL THOSE. YOU
KNOW TRUSTING RELATIONSHIPS AND-
WE WORK ON DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
FIRE SUPER COMPRESSED GOT FIRED
FUELS MANAGEMENT TO HOME
HARDENING IN COMMUNITY PLANNING.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC POLICY-
WE'RE JUST REALLY KIND OF JUST
YOU KNOW ABLE THAT. ADJUSTER
WORKS TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. AND
SO I THINK THAT THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE NOW HAVE THE SUPPORT
WE NEED TO BUILD A BIGGER
STATEWIDE PROGRAM. AROUND FIRED
VISORS AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
HIRING THREE MORE PEOPLE INTO
POSITIONS LIKE MINE SO I WON'T
BE THE ONLY PERSON- AND WE WILL
ROLL OUT MORE POSITIONS IN THE
COMING MONTHS SO. THESE
FIREFIGHTERS ARE GOING TO BE A
REALLY HUGE ASSET ACROSS THE
STATE I'M WORKING ON DIFFERENT
ISSUES DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY
ARE YOU KNOW SOME MIGHT BE MORE
URBAN MORE RURAL. AND I'M REALLY
KIND OF ADOPTED THAT THE NEEDS.
I ALSO. LIKE THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR CORPORATION IT WAS NEEDS
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
PRESCRIBED FIRE LIABILITY PILOT
PROGRAM. WHICH WILL BE LIKE A
STATE BACKED CLEAN SPONSOR
PRESCRIBED FIRE. AND THE LACK OF
INSURANCE HAS BEEN A HUGE ISSUE
FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE WORK IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE STATE BANK
BEGINS FUND IS GOING TO BE
ESSENTIAL. FOR MAKING SURE THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE PRACTITIONERS
CAN DO THE WORK THAT THE STATE
NEEDS THEM TO DO. SO I THINK
THIS WAS A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE
OF CALIFORNIA BEING REALLY
CREATIVE IN HOW WE APPROACH IS
COMPLEX ISSUE- I MEAN INSPIRE
AND INSURANCE ARE CALM. THINGS
TO DEAL WITH RIGHT NOW. AND WE
WERE TO. LIKE REALLY NEED ACTION
AT THE RIGHT TIME SO THIS CLAIMS
. IN THE CHANGES TOWARDS FIRE.
LAW THAT WE TO SEND DODD SENATE
BILL THIRTY TWO. THESE HAVING.
BROAD FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
INCLUDING FROM RANCHO TRY. AND
GROUPS TIMBER IN. SIGN
KNOCKABOUT. UNITY MAN- YOU KNOW
JUST READ SHOW THAT HE'S IN. IN
POLICY ACTION. ARE BLAH SO. AND
PRIOR THIS PERSON FIRE WORK HUGE
PRIORITY. FOR DIVERSE GROUPS AND
HEALTH. REALLY BUT I. WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WHILE WE NEED TO
INCREDIBLE AND BRING. BEST USED
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO. AND MONEY
IS A CRITICAL PART OF SOLUTION
BUT IF THE ACTUAL EMPLOYMENT. OF
THE PROGRAM THAT WILL AFFECT THE
NEEDED. SO THERE ARE A FEW THAT
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU. FOR ONE
IN TWENTY EIGHT. TWELVE SIXTEEN
HUNDRED OF THE- OF THE STATE
CERTIFY BURNED BY PROGR. TO
CERTIFY AND PROVIDE A- FOR PRIDE
PRACTICE. TO PLANET IMPLEMENT
PROJECTS. AND I SERVED ON THE
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
FOR THAT PROGRAM. WHICH WAS
FINALIZED BY THE STATE EARLIER
THIS YEAR A COUPLE YEARS TO
DEVELOP THAT CURRICULUM AND TO
YOU KNOW MOVE IT TO THE NEEDED
APPROVALS. I HOSTED THE FIRST
CLASS HERE IN MAY AND I WAS THE
ONLY CLASS THAT'S HAPPENED SO
FAR. AND EIGHTEEN EXPERIENCED
PRESCRIBED FIRE PRACTITIONERS
INCLUDING NINE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED BURN BOSSES. WORK FULL
CAREERS AND FIRE. I JUST POINT
I'M SEVEN MONTHS LATER. NOT A
SINGLE PERSON TO BUY CLASSES
BEEN CERTIFIED BY THE STATE. AND
WE MISSED A TON OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION.
THERE IS A HUGE NEED FOR
QUALIFIED BROWN BOSSES TO PLAN
AND IMPLEMENT PROJECTS AND TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE
DEPARTMENT LANDOWNERS. BUT
WITHOUT THE STATE CERTIFICATION
AND THE PROTECTIONS THAT CAN
PROVIDE. MANY OF THOSE FOLKS ARE
NOT WILLING TO GO OUT AND DO
THAT WORK. THERE IS AN URGENT
NEED TO IRON THIS OUT AND I'M
PLANNING TO WORK WITH CAL FIRE
AND CONTINUE WORKING STATE FIRE
TRAINING TO ENSURE. THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS A SUCCESS. BECAUSE
ABSOLUTELY S. FOR THIS. OF ALL
INVESTING FOR ME IN THIS OF WORK
- LIKE. WILL BE COMPARED. AND
TRACK WITH A VOTE OF THIS. SO
AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S JUST WORK
ON. THIS IS SUCH A PIVOTAL OF
THE PIE WE JUST NOT GONNA GET
WORK DONE. YOU KNOW THE INVEST
THAT WE'RE- ARE NOT TO OUT. TO
LAY OUT A THE GROUND IF WE
FIGURE PIECES OUT WE REALLY HAVE
TO BE. BROWN THIS WORK WE NEEDED
TO. OUR CULTURE. MINISTRY
PROBLEM. AT THE SAME TIME MAKING
USE. INVESTMENTS AND WE KNOW THE
AGE CAN'T DO WITH THE WORK ONE.
THEY NEED TO MAKES FOR ALL. HER
AN EX TO BE INVOLVED. SO- I JUST
WEST ONE OF YOU AGAIN FOR THE
GREAT WORK IN THE VISION YOU ALL
UP FOR AROUND FIVE. AND BRING
THEM OF THE I MAKES. AT UNIVERSE
FONG. ARE RESOURCE FOR YOU WE'RE
ALL HAPPY TO INFORM. TO YOUR
EFFORTS IN FACT. THANKS SO MUCH
. THANK YOU MUCH SURE. LAST IS
TO. ALISON FROM THE WATER.
RESEARCH AND TRAINING. MEETINGS-
MY NAME IS ALL. JOHN AND- TO YOU
TODAY AS THE RE. OR AND FIRE
CAPACITY PRO. DIRECTOR OF THE
WATERSHED RESEARCH TRAININGS.
FIRST I THINK TERRIBLE ARRESTED
COMMITTEE. YEAH TO SPEAK WITH NO
TODAY. THE WATERSHED. IS A NON.
ORGANIZATION LOCATED AT. COUNTY
WE'VE BEEN IN THE BUSINESS OF
FOR A REST. QUALIFY WILL. AND
WE'RE- DEVELOPMENT FOR ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS NOW. I TRIED
TO TELL YOU THAT WERE ONE OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN TRINITY
COUNTY. WE PLAN AND IMPLEMENT
FOREST HEALTH WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PROJECTS. YOU'RE AND
YOU'RE OUT. WE CALLED NUMEROUS
BY GRANT TO. WITH THE RANGE OF
STATE FEDERAL. INVESTING WELFARE
LEAD. WE ALSO WATERSHED AMERISUR
OF YOUR ROLE OF THE STATE AND I
LEVEL. DID YOU FROM WORKING ON
THE TELL WHILE. FORESTRY TEST
FORCE AND IT'S VERY WORKING TOUR
PART. WITH THE OF CONSERVATION
ON ARCHITECTURE AND
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE REGIONAL
FOREST AND FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM
OR ARE FSC. NATIONALLY WE RUN
THE FIRE ADOPTED COMMUNITIES
LEARNING NETWORK. MY ROLE THE
WATERSHED CENTERS OVERSEEING OUR
ARGOSY PROGRAM. IN ADDITION
OVERSEEING THAT PROGRAM I
RECENTLY COMPLETED ANOTHER
TOWARD TRAVELING WITH ONE OF
ONLY SIXTEEN TYPE ONE FEDERAL.
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAMS IN THE
COUNTRY. I TWO A HALF YEARS OF
OVERSEE THIS ARE OF SHEEP. YEAH
ANOTHER SUMMER FALL WORKING ON
ONE. ACROSS THE WAY. INCLUDING
WORKING ON THE DIXIE FIRE. AND
QUITE FRANKLY ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL BEING A FORMER RESIDENT OF
GREENVILLE MYSELF. THERE SO MANY
THINGS I WISH I'D HAVE TO TALK
WITH YOU ABOUT TODAY. FIRST I
APPRECIATE ALL THE INCREDIBLE
STRIDES THAT THE STATE IS
MAKING. YES OUR WILDFIRES
CONTINUE TO BREAK RECORDS BUT SO
DOES OUR COMMITMENT TO FACE THE
PROBLEM HEAD ON. WITH THESE
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE MAGNITUDE OF
FUNDING BEING ALLOCATED TO FIRE
THE MULTI FACETED NUANCED
APPROACHES OR SOMETHING TO BE
VERY PRODUCT. SIGNIFICANT SUMS
LIKE WHEN YOU MENTION TO TRIBES.
GREAT STRIDES WITH PRESCRIBED
FIRE LEGISLATION. THINKING AHEAD
AND HEARING IMPLEMENTATION FUNDS
WITH CAPACITY BUILDING AND
PLANNING FUNDS. NO OTHER STATE
OR FEDERAL AGENCY TO MY
KNOWLEDGE HAS HAD THE FORESIGHT
TO INVEST SO HEAVILY IN WILDFIRE
CAPACITY IN PARTICULAR AGAIN
THINK ABOUT THAT SEAT AND ARGOSY
PROGRAM. THE PAST EIGHT ELECT A
LEADER MAKING SOME GREAT SO FOR.
REGARDING THE CHILD THAT I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS ON TODAY. LET'S GO
BACK IN TIME TO NINETEEN. AT THE
ONSET OF THE ARCHIVE SEE PROGRAM
MIGHT ORGANIZATION COMMISSIONED
A THIRD PARTY CAPACITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENT SEEKING TO ANSWER THE
BASIC QUESTION. WHAT DO ENTITIES
WORKING IN A LANDSCAPE LEVEL ON
FOREST FIRE WORK WITHIN
CALIFORNIA MOST NEED. TO SCALE
UP THEIR WORK. ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON REPORTED NEEDS OF SELVES
PAUL OVERHEAD. ALSO KNOWN AS
INTER OR ADMINISTRATIVE SPENDING
SUPPORT. NOW YOU TO THE CHASE
AND SAY OVER IS. PROFIT OVERHEAD
IS MONEY KEEP ON THE LIGHTS THE
FUNDS THAT COVER ADMINISTER
STAFF. IN WHO MANAGES THE BOOKS
THE PERSON WHO CUTS THE CHECKS
OFFICE SPACE COMPUTERS UTILITY
BILLS STOPS WHEN THEY CAN'T BE
BUILT TO PROJECTS FOR CRITICAL
PARTS OF THE JOB LIKE ATTENDING
STAFF MEETINGS PERFORMANCE
REVIEWS STRATEGIC PLANNING. ONE
I DIDN'T FOR A MINUTE IF YOU
COULD NOT ATTEND MEETINGS THAT
WERE PARAMOUNT TO YOUR WORK
BECAUSE YOU DO NOT HAVE A WAY TO
BILL FOR YOUR TIME. THAT IS WHAT
SOME OF MY WILD FIRE COLLEAGUES
DEAL EVERY SINGLE WEEK. BILLS
FOR THINGS LIKE LEGAL AND
ACCOUNTING. AUDITS LIABILITY
INSURANCE REPAIRING PUBLICATIONS
. RESPONDING TO CALPERS
SOLICITATIONS. INVOICING
OVERHEAD IN THIS CONTEXT IS THE
SUM OF EXPENSES THAT ALLOW
ORGANIZATIONS TO FUNCTION LIKE
THE HIGH CAPACITY PARTNERS. BUT
I KNOW THE STATE WANTS TO BE IN
BUSINESS WITH. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS STANDARDIZED
METHODS OF WORKING WITH THEIR
PARTNERS TO UNDERSTAND THE COST
OF DOING BUSINESS IT'S
RECALCULATED EVERY ONE TO FIVE
YEARS. THAT COSTA COMES IN
AGREED TO PERCENTAGE AGAIN BASED
ON ACTUAL EXPENSES AND THAT
ORGANIZATION BILLS THAT RATE
WHEN WORKING DOCUMENTS AND
AGREEMENTS WITH FEDERAL
AGENCIES. THIS IS CAUGHT IN
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T ENTER COSTS
REDEPLOYMENT OR NIAGARA FOR
SHORT. MANY OF THE SAME NUMBER
STRIVES C. COUNCIL AN RC. WORK
ALLEGED TO GET THE FUNDING YOU
ALL OF OUR- PREVIOUS AND EARLY
ACT. ARE NOW OF THOSE GROUP.
THAT YOU'RE COUNTING ON TO DO
THE WILDFIRE WORKSHOP. AND RELY
THEIR- WHAT SHOULD CENTERS
CURRENT MAKERS 2380% HOW DID
DOUBLE CHECK WITH MY BOSS FROM
BIRCH DURING THAT THEY WAS A
LITTLE NERVOUS BUT I WANT TO
HAVE TO KNOW. AND MY BE TO WORK
WEST SICHUAN THREE POINT
EIGHTEEN. MANY OF OUR TRUSTED IN
. PARTNERS OVERHEAD RATES IN THE
TWENTY OR EVEN HIGHER. YOU KNOW
OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM RIGHT IS ON
THE- AND THEN LOCAL FIRE.
HEARTBREAKS OR EVEN THAN THAT.
AGAIN THAT'S THE RATE OF DOING
BUSINESS. EVERY WATERSHED CENTER
ENTERS THE- THAT OVER IT TAKES
WHILE PERCENT. WHICH IS THE KERN
HEALTH OVER RATE. YOUR LOSING A
OF SENSE ON THE DOLLAR. IN ORDER
TO THE DOORS. HEY RON TIME AND
BILL PAY. EITHER HAVE TO OPERATE
IN THE WHOLE. OR SPEND THESE
STUFF TO PASS TO FIND PRIVATE.
FOR GETTING. THAT JENNER PROFIT
. INSTEAD OF. ON THE PRESS WORK
THAT I KNOW THE STATE COUNCIL.
OUR PARTNERS INCLUDING SOME TRY
WITH THREE IN THE FOR. NEWS
THIRTY CENTS ON THE DOLLAR
ENTERING INTO A CO FIRE AGREE.
WELL WE ARE SO THANK TO BE LONG
TIME HEALTH GREATER RECIPIENT
PARTNER. THAT LOST IS TRANSLATE
TO. OF DOLLARS WHEN DEALING WITH
THE MOST MILLION GRANT. THIS IS. CONVERSELY THERE BEEN YEARS
WHEN I COME 70% SO THE YEARS IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO. THE CAPTIVE
STATE PER. THE STATE WOULD HAVE
BEEN OVER. SO NOW THAT I'VE GOT
YOU. PER EARLY ACTION OFFICE
FUNDS THE FIRST TIME THAT WE IN
MY- THAT ESTATE WHAT PART. IS
ALL NEEDS TO CHARGE ACTUAL OVER
RATES. THEY'RE KEEPING SIMPLE
THERE ARE HONORING GROWTH ALL IN
WITH AND OTHER TOP OVERHEAD
TWENTY. THIS IS A GREAT. AND
MORE AGE NEED TO FOLLOW. THANK A
WIN WIN EVERY INVOLVED THE GRANT
HE DOESN'T DRINK TO PASS. AND
THE GRANT DOESN'T REST OF APAC.
THE LAST ONE I WANT TO MAKE
ABOUT OVERHEAD RATES REALLY WORK
ABOUT. TEAM THAT'S COME UP THAT
TIMES TO AND I NOTICED. ON BASIS
SINCE OUR- ON THE JOB TRAINING.
IS A CORNER OF WORK TO. IN THE
THAT MANY OR- SUPPORT THEIR
STOCK DOING. IS OVER. WHETHER
THAT'S ATTENDING A BIRD BALL
COURSE MEDIA MENTION STUDY FOR
AN EXAM TO A REGISTERED.
FORESTER PERTAINING WHILE THEY
EXPRESS ARC WELDING. FOURTEEN A
SIMPLE ALL. LIKE MOST PROVIDE.
FOREST IN FIREWORKS NEED
CONTINUED EDUCATE ENTRY TO
DELIVER HIGH PROJECTS. IN ORDER
TO MEET THE STATE'S Y. IN SCHOOL
I URGE THIS COMMITTEE ENSURE THE
FUTURE. FUNDING REGARDLESS THE
AGES OR OF THE PROGRAM AND ITS
ALLOCATED TO ALLOW ORGANIZATION
TO CHARGE THEIR ACTUAL RATE OF
DOING BUSINESS. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S MATTHEW KEEP THE
SEMPORNA FASHION. BUT WITHOUT
THIS CHANGE MANY OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS YOU SEEK TO WORK
WITH SIMPLY MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD TO DO BUSINESS WITH YEAH.
THIS IS A SIMPLE YET CRITICAL
WAY TO SUPPORT THE WORK THAT I
KNOW WE ALL WANT TO SEE HAPPEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH. THANK THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS FOR- THE
VERY INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION
THAT- THAT WE'VE HAD OVER THE
LAST HOUR OR SO DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS MR GALLAGHER. THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN AND- I DO HAVE. A
FEW QUESTIONS I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU WANT TO. RIGHT AWAY DOLLARS
RUN THROUGH THEM AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW I RECKON THERE'S- REMIND TO
SOME OF YOUR ONE ASK WAS TO. I
DO AND I DON'T PEOPLE WENT
PRETTY LONG IN THEIR
PRESENTATIONS WAS A LOT IN THERE
AND AS THE CHAIR SAID THERE'S A
LOT TO GO THROUGH THIS. A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND SO I'D
APPRECIATE IF JUST I WANT TO GET
THROUGH SOME THINGS AND IF YOU
COULD TRYING KEEP YOUR ANSWERS.
I GUESS IS CONCISE AS POSSIBLE
SO WE CAN GET THROUGH. SOME OF
THIS- I WANT TO ALSO THINK-
CHIEF TOM PORTER FOR HIS GREAT
SERVICE TO OUR STATE- AND I
APPRECIATED THAT THE HISTORY
LESSON- YOU KNOW AND- AS A
STUDENT OF HISTORY MYSELF- IF WE
HAVE BEEN MNAGING OUR FOREST-
LIKE PENSION- TAUGHT. WE'D BE IN
A MUCH. BETTER PLACE TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA. A PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS WE'VE BEEN MANAGING
THEM ACCORDING TO THE PHILOSOPHY
OF JOHN MUIR. AND THAT HAS BEEN
PART OF THE PROBLEM- BUT TO THAT
POINT I MEAN AGAIN URGENCY I
THINK IS THE ISSUE WE GOT MONEY
- THAT WE CAN INVEST SIGNIFICANT
MONEY TO INVEST. BUT HOW ARE WE
DOING ON GETTING PROJECTS DONE
WE KNOW THAT WITH THE FIRST.
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN A LONG TIME
IN COMING WE HAVEN'T DONE THIS-
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES WE
HAVEN'T BEEN IN THAT PENSION.
CONSERVATION MULTI USE
MANAGEMENT FRAME OF MIND WITH
HOW WE MANAGE OUR FORESTS- AND
WE'VE GOT A LOT TO MAKE UP FOR
RIGHT SO- LAST YEAR. IT CAME OUT
THAT YOU KNOW WITH WITH THAT
FIRST INFUSION OF DOLLARS THAT
WE GOT. WE GOT ELEVEN THOUSAND
ACRES TREATED THAT THOSE ARE THE
FACTS SO WHAT I WANT TO GET INTO
IS HOW ARE WE DOING. SO FAR WITH
EARLY ACTION SO TO- MISS MORRIS
YOU IDENTIFIED TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
PROJECTS- THAT HAVE BEEN FAST
TRACKED WITH THE EARLY ACTION.
MONEY COULD WE GET A LIST OF
THOSE PROJECTS IS ONE THING I'D
LIKE TO SEE IF THE COMMITTEE
COULD GET A LIST OF THAT AND
THEN HOW MANY ACRES. IS THAT
TRANSLATE TO ONCE THOSE PROJECTS
ARE COMPLETED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND- HAPPY TO SHARE THE LAST-
WE'VE SHARED IT WITH THE L. A-
AND SO HAPPY TO SHARE THAT- WITH
ALL OF YOU AS WELL- AND- ACRES
ARE GONNA BE REPORTED BACK FROM
ALL OF OUR PARTNERS- ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS AND- SO WE HAVE A
LOT OF PLANNING ACRES BUT AS- WE
KNOW ON THE GROUND- ONE CELL
WILL REPORT THAT BACK OUT ONCE
THEY'RE COMPLETED. THANK YOU DO
YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE THE OF THE
PLANNED ACRES I MEAN WE'VE GOT A
PLAN IN PLACE. AND I THINK WE
HAVE A GOOD PLAN- BUT HOW MANY
ACRES ARE WE ESTIMATE WILL BE
TREATED ONCE HE'S EARLY ACTION
PROJECTS ARE DONE AND THEN I
MOVED TO THE- THE MORE SCALED UP
PROJECTS. ARE GOING TO BE PART
OF THE NINE OR NINETY EIGHT
MILLION. SO IN THE PLANET. ACRES
WITH LOOKS. SORT OF THE ENTIRE
PRINT OF THE PROJECT- WHICH IS
WHERE YOU DO YOUR ENVIRONMENT.
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS WHERE YOU
DO YOUR IDENTIFICATION OF WHAT
AREAS YOU'RE PROTECTING-
IDENTIFY WHERE YOU'RE GONNA
PUTTING YOUR CHILDREN ACTION-
AND THEN WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY
CALCULATING ACRES TREATED- IS AS
COMPLETED THE WAY WE ACTUALLY
TRACK THAT IS ACTUALLY BASED ON
PHYSICAL VEGETATION REMOVED. SO
IT'S ONLY ABOUT A THIRD OF THE-
THE ACRES THAT YOU'RE PLANNING
ON- IN THE TREATMENT SO- WE'RE
GONNA REPORT OUT AFTER WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE- ACRES HI
AFTER THOSE PROJECTS ARE
COMPLETED. AND WILL BE GETTING
THOSE BACK FROM OUR PARTNERS AT
THE END OF THE YEAR. OKAY WHEN
THE PROJECT FOR COMPLETING INTO
SOME QUESTION WHAT'S THE- OF
THAT. A FOR NOW. I WOULD URGE
YOU ARE STATE FORESTER WHO MIGHT
BE ABLE TO EXPLAIN THIS MORE AT
AND I'M TRYING TO GIVE YOU A
TECHNICAL EXPLANATION BUT- I
DON'T UNDERSTAND I NEED TO GIVE
YOU AN EASIER ONE. AND I
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN TREATED I THINK WE'VE
BECOME REALLY FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT'S TREATED AND WHAT'S
PROTECTED- BUT THAT'S ANOTHER
PART OF THIS WE NEED REAL
TRANSPARENCY ON. YOU KNOW WHAT
ARE THOSE THINGS WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENCES AND TREATMENTS. AND
WHAT IS ACTUALLY PROTECTED AT
THE END OF THE DAY. RIGHT AND-
WHAT JESSICA ELUDED TO WITHOUT
SAYING. AGAIN THE STOP ORDER.
STATE FORESTER AND FIRE CHIEF
HEALTHCARE. BUT IS THAT THAT
THOSE ACRES WILL BE RECORDED AS
THEY COME IN- THAT IS THE WAY
THE PROCESS WORKS. I GET YOU
WITH THE ESTIMATE BUT THE
ESTIMATE- I DON'T HOW. AND WE
CAN PROVIDE THE LIST. AS JESSICA
MENTIONED ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE
THERE AND THE DETAIL THAT'S IN
THOSE PROJECTS. WELL THAT'S WHAT
WE HAVE AT THIS POINT. OKAY SO
WE DON'T HAVE AN ESTIMATE AT
THIS POINT- HOW ABOUT A MAN ARE
YOU GUYS THINKING ABOUT DOING A
MAP BUT DIGITAL MAP OF THE STATE
THAT WOULD SHOW. BECAUSE I THINK
A BIG PROBLEM HERE IS
TRANSPARENCY AND REALLY KNOWING
. WHAT WE ARE DOING ON THE
GROUND- WITH THIS MONEY.
SOMETHING THAT WOULD SHOW LIKE.
YOU KNOW WHERE THESE PROJECTS
ARE LOCATED HOW MANY ACRES. ARE
ULTIMATELY BEING DONE THERE AND
THEN WHAT TYPE OF TREATMENT YOU
KNOW IS A PRESCRIBED FIRE IS IT
SENDING. ARE THESE PRIVATE
PROJECTS OR THESE YOU KNOW THESE
PRIVATE YOU KNOW. LANDOWNERS OR-
COMMERCIAL LOGGING OPERATIONS
ARE THEY- FIRE SAFE COUNCIL
PROJECTS I MEAN. IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU GUYS ARE THINKING
ABOUT PUTTING TOGETHER BECAUSE I
THINK THAT BE REALLY HELPFUL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE BUT ALSO FOR THE
PUBLIC TO JUST SEE. WHAT ARE WE
DOING WHAT TYPES OF PROJECTS ARE
THEY WHAT IS IT TRANSLATE INTO
IN TERMS OF OVERALL ACRES
PROJECT- PROTECTED IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU GUYS ARE THINKING
ABOUT. YES THAT HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED- WE HAVE A CAL MAPPER
WHICH IS. A PROGRAM THAT CAL
FIRE USES FOR THE CALCULATOR
PROJECTS AND THE GRANT PROJECTS
THAT ARE THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR- DIRECT GRANT. GRANTEES
THAT PROGRAM IS BEING EXPANDED
UNDER THE- THE TASK FORCES-
TUTELAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF. THE STATE-
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
UTILIZE TO CAPTURE THOSE- IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT COMPLETELY FLUSHED
OUT WITH ALL BUT THE
PARTNERSHIPS YET BOB. IS THE
PLACE WHERE THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN. WHO CAN WIN MIGHT BE UP
AND RUNNING YOU THINK- CHIEF.
WELL WE'RE WORKING ON IT-
CURRENTLY AND IT'LL IT'LL
PROBABLY BE IN THE NEXT YEAR- TO
GET IT FLUSHED OUT AND THEN TO
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE DETAILS
AND- NOT MAKING SURE THAT WORK
COUNTY. FOR APPLES ANOTHER NEW
WANTS TO WHAT YOU JUST ASKED- IN
IN DAHLE STATEWIDE MAP IS THAT
PART OF THE- STEWARDSHIP
AGREEMENT THAT- WE HAVE WITH THE
FOR SERVICE THAT JESSICA
MENTIONED IN HER PRESENTATION AT
THE VERY BEGINNING. AS WELL AS-
TASK UNDER THE TASK FORCE OF THE
NINETY NINE IS TO HAVE A JOINT
PROJECT LIST AND JOINT PROJECT
MAP THAT SHOWS. ARE OVER TIME
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT S.
ASPARTIC PRIORITIES AND DOING
PROJECTS ON THE LANDSCAPE THAT'S
UNDER DEVELOPMENT AND PART OF
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM SO WE'RE NOW
WE'RE NOW KIND OF DOVETAILING
INTO THEIR TIME ONE. THAT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S COMING TOGETHER
SOMETIME IN FEBRUARY OR MARCH.
YES YOU CAN- AND THEN BACK TO
MISS MORE. I AM VERY INTERESTED
IN BY. MEANT THAT'S GOING TO BE
A PART OF THIS IS REALLY GETTING
PLANTS UP AND HAVING A PLACE TO
TAKE WOULD BE WASTE- YOU
MENTIONED THAT IN THE WITH THE
NINE OR NINETY EIGHT MILLION-
THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO JUMPSTART
BIOMASS PROJECTS CAN YOU.
SPECIFY PROJECTS THAT RIGHT NOW
ARE BEING TARGETED FOR BEING
JUMPSTARTED- YOU IN DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
NOW WITH THIS MONEY. SURE THING
IN THAT CLIMATE CATALYST FUND
WHICH IS A TECHNOLOGY AGNOSTIC
SO IT'S CREATES LOANS FOR
ANYBODY THAT IS WANTING uSTART
A PROGRAM THAT WOULD UTILIZE-
WHAT HE BY MASTER FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO START A MASS
TIMBER FACILITY- OR IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO START- PYROLYSIS- OR
DOING SOMETHING MORE TRADITIONAL
LAKE UNTIL- SO ANYTHING THAT IS
FINDING HIGHER YOU SEVEN OPEN
PILE BURNING OF THIS MATERIAL I
WOULD BE AVAILABLE IN THE
CLIMATE CATALYST FUND- WHICH IS
JUST WATCHING THAT WAS FIVE
FUNDED IN SEPTEMBER AND I AND IS
GOING BEFORE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BANK- AND THEY'RE ALREADY
STARTING TO TAKE IN AND THEY
HAVE THEIR LIFE ON THEIR WEBSITE
TO TAKE. ENQUIRIES AND
APPLICATIONS FROM AYE FROM
INTERESTED BUSINESSES THAT ARE
READY TO START UP- OTHER
INVESTMENTS IN THE BILASPUR SO
IF FIELD ARE THINGS LIKE I LIKE
I MENTIONED THESE- FEEDSTOCK
AGGREGATORS SO SAD FIVE PRO
AROUND THE STATE ARE TRYING TO
RETHINK THE WAY WE MOVE BIOMASS
AND THE WAY WE GIVE OFF SUPPLY
GUARANTEES SO THAT IT CREATES A
MORE STABLE BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT
TO START UP- THESE AT LARGE
CAPITAL INTENSIVE BUSINESSES
THAT WILL GET US TO SCALE WE CAN
START YOU SAYING AT THE FOREST-
MATERIAL. MORE EFFICIENTLY. OKAY
AND THEN JUST YOUR ADVENTURE
THAT SOME PRO FOR JOHN STARTING
I MEAN THERE'S- ONE THAT OF OUR
TAKEN A- OF SOME OF THESE. IN
OUR AND OUR- STARTED STARTING
BREAK OR WERE GETTING DOWN THE
ROAD ON THEM. SO THE CLIMATE
KALISPELL IS JUST ROLLING OUT I
MEAN I CAN POINT TO PREVIOUS
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE- FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S A MILLION
DOLLAR. GRANT FROM THAT- TIMBER
FINE FROM THIS YEAR ABOUT A
CONSERVANCY. THAT WENT CHIU- I
MIL UP IN CRESCENT MILLS. THAT
IS OPENING UP AS WE SPEAK AND-
ALLOWS THEM TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
LIFE ON. THE DIXIE FIRE
FOOTPRINT RIGHT FROM GREENBELT
ABOUT FIVE MILES DOWN THE ROAD
MILLING. AND THE BRING IT BACK-
TO HELP THE CONSTRUCTION OF
GREENVILLE I MEAN THAT SHORTENS.
YOUR ON TRAVEL TIME AND ALSO
OPENS UP- YOU KNOW SOME SMALL
MILL CAPACITY- WITH WILL THAT'LL
TAKE IN LARGE I AM- TREES- IT
RIGHT IN THE MEDIAFIRE.
FOOTPRINT OKAY. AND THEN- SO
ANOTHER PART WE TALK ABOUT
FEDERAL STATE PARTNERSHIP AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT-
BUT WE ALSO YOU KNOW WE KIND OF
BELIEVE OUT OF THAT PRIVATE AND
I THINK AS YOU MENTIONED THERE'S
FORTY PERCENT. OF THE LAND THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS PRIVATELY
OWNED EITHER BY YOU KNOW- TIMBER
COMPANIES ARE SMALL LANDOWNERS-
SAY MAKE UP 40% OF THAT WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO HELP STREAMLINE THE
PERMITTING PROCESS BECAUSE THAT
WAS SOMETHING IDENTIFIED. BY
MISTER ANDERSON IS THAT WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THAT BUT RIGHT NOW
YOU GO TO A T. H. P. AND EVEN
WITH CAL TREES PROGRAM- YOU GET
THE THV PERMIT BUT THEN IT'S NOT
STREAMLINED WITH SAY WATER BOARD
PERMITS- OR OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
PERMITS- HOW CAN WE MAKE THAT
JUST ONE PROCESS SO THAT. WE CAN
SPEAK FAST TRACK THESE PRIVATE
PROJECTS WHICH ARE A BIG PART OF
THE ISSUE. SO WITH CALTRAIN IS
ASKED WITH THE TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS THERE'S A COUPLE OF YEARS
A PERMIT SO YOU'VE GOT- A LOT
OF. COMPANIES ARE RIGHT NOW
USING THE EMERGENCY AN EXEMPTION
PERMITS WHICH HAVE GONE ON THE
ONLINE TO THIS ONLINE PERMITTING
PROCESS THAT WE CALL CAL TREES-
AND THAT HAS ABOUT A FIVE DAY
TURNAROUND. SO FOR ALL THE
SALVAGE LOGGING THAT'S GOING
FORWARD WHICH IS THE MAJORITY OF
OUR TIMBER HARVEST HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW. THERE'S A
VERY FAST TRACK FOR THAT- WE ARE
WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD TO HAVE
CAL TREES TRANSITION. TO BEING
THAT SORT OF SINGLE APPLICATION
AND THAT JOINT STREAMLINED
PROCESS. THIS IS ONE OF THE
ACTIONS CALLED OUT IN THE TASK
FORCE- AND I AND WE HAVE THE
WORKGROUP ESTABLISHED. AROUND IT
THAT ARE MOVING FORWARD- AND
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN PROGRESS.
FROM YEAH AB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO
WITH THE CHAMBER FIND WE'VE SEEN
THE MEDIAN TIME OR- GREEN TREE
CAMERAS REVIEWS. GO DOWN FROM
SIX MONTHS TO ABOUT THREE
MONTHS- AND- AND SO IN THAT
TREND HELD OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS WHICH IS. I'M GOOD
PROGRESS MORE REMEMBER THAT SAID
THAT JUDGING HER AS PLAINTIFF A
C. CORP ONE POINT. AT THE MARCH
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING NOW WE- ARE
PERMITS TO. IS WHAT WE IN THE
EARLY ACTION. SO I THE- R. THEY
COUNTY P. I MENTION EARLIER THIS
pWHO ARE. YOU KNOW SPEAKING- AND-
IT A TWENTY MILLION EIGHT. PER
EMPIRE. RIGHT ACROSS ALL OF THE
NEW FAT HIGH. IS LANDING STATE
SO SOCIALLY ANYTHING THAT THIS.
IS FOR. A FIRE- HAS THIS. SECRET
BEFORE SEACOAST. AFTER UP TO
YEARS IF YOU DO HAVE. SOME TYPE
OF A MORE. EXEMPTION OR- OTHER-
FASTER I CATCH. THIS IS THE CAL
. BY DOING CREATED BY YOUR
MENTAL REVIEW. WORKING THE
ADVICE. CAN A BOY IT DOWN. TO
DOING JUST NEED THE COR BASIC-
AND I JUST PUTS ON THE- IN ALLAH
. WHICH ANYBODY. ANYTHING WITH
YOUR PROJECT HAS TO DO ANYWAY. I
AND THIS- AND BRINGS THAT PROP
DOWN TO ABOUT TWO MONTHS- DON'T
ALLOW US TO A THE STEPS. OF
THOSE EMPIRE PROTECT. WITHOUT IN
THE LANKY. BUT WHAT'S REALLY
IT'S- IS IT IS A FULLY
SYNCHRONIZED PERMIT. THAT PART
OFFICIAL. FULLY INTEGRATED THE
PER STEVE- INTO. WITH THE COUNTY
P. SO THAT ANYBODY APPLYING FOR
ACROSS. CAN'T ACTUALLY HAPPEN
EMPIRE IN THAT'S HOW. THAT WOULD
. A FISH WILDLIFE PERMIT- THE
STATE WATER BOARD SAID TO MY
DOLLARS THAT WE FIND. EARLY
ACTION. AND ABLE. TO STOP BY.
WITH NAMES LIST S. WIDE HER NAY
THAT IS FULL SYNC. WITH THE
CALIBER. SO IT'S AUTOMATIC. HUGE
TIME SAVER. IN THIS PROCESS I'M
IN ANOTHER THING WE DID SO THAT
PEOPLE ARE MORE COMFORTABLE
USING IT- AND ENSURING THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE THAT. IS
THAT WITH THE EARLY ACTION
DOLLARS OUT WE ROLLED OUT A
CONTRACT TO DO FORTY PROJECT
SPECIFIC ANALYSIS SO ESSENTIALLY
FORTY- CAL BTP APPLICATIONS- IN
DIFFERENT LANDSCAPE TYPES AND
GEOGRAPHIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SO THAT ANYBODY IS GOING
TO BE USING CAL BTP PROJECT-
DOESN'T HAVE TO START FROM
SCRATCH THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE.
ALREADY DONE PROJECT TEMPLATES-
IN YOUR REGION FOR THEIR
VEGETATION THAT THEY CAN JUST
FOLLOW I'M REALLY CLEARLY AND
TAKE THE STEPS. IN ACTION STEPS
THAT ARE OUTLINED- WHEN DOING
THEIR PROJECTS SO IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY FAST- PATH TO GETTING
C. CHOIR AND A FULLY
SYNCHRONIZED PERMIT. OKAY IS WAS
THAT WAS THAT WAS A REALLY LONG
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION. BUT I
WHAT I THINK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS SO CAL BTP
ALL START THERE- YOU'RE RIGHT IN
LA- JUST REPORTED TO US IN THIS
HEARING. THAT IS NOT REALLY
BEING UTILIZED VERY VERY MUCH
AND- AND AS YOU SAID IT ONLY
COVERS A STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA. WHICH IS A SMALL PORTION
OF THE ACRES THAT WE NEED- TO
ALTERNATELY TREATED IT'S
IMPORTANT PORTION. BUT THE
PEOPLE APPLYING FOR THAT ARE
MOSTLY CAL ARE MOSTLY FIRE
COUNCILS. NONPROFITS PUBLIC
ENTITIES TRYING TO DO THAT WORK.
AND THEY'RE REPORTING TO ME. AND
OTHERS THAT THE PROGRAM IS TOO
INFLEXIBLE AND BURDENSOME. AND
THEY END UP OPTING FOR OTHER
METHODS. AND SO VTP IS NOT BEING
UTILIZED. AND IN FACT
STREAMLINING. PROJECTS IN THAT
AREA SO THAT'S A PROBLEM RIGHT
NOW WITH V. T. P. WHAT I WAS
REFERRING TO- YOU KNOW. T. H.
FEES YOU KNOW TIMBER HARVEST
PLANS THAT PRIVATES- SO YOU KNOW
PRIVATE LOGGING COMPANIES OFTEN
DO T. H. P.'S TO DO THEIR- TO DO
THEIR- COMMERCIAL TIMBER.
HARVEST- THEY A TAKE A REAL LONG
TIME- AND OFTEN THE FOR IS THE
GET A T. H. PERMIT YOU READY TO
MOVE FOR AND THEN THE Y. BOARD
COMES IN A SAYS ONE I GOT TO GET
A PERMIT FROM US OR SOME OTHER
ENTITY GETS ANOTHER AND SO THE
WHAT THE STREAMLINING MONEY THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED BECAUSE FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THEN WITH
THE WITH THE DIRECTION FROM
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO GOING BACK
TO TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE. HOW
DO WE STREAMLINED THAT SO THAT
THEY CAN GET A T. H. P. THAT IS
THAT CAN INCLUDES ALL THOSE
PERMITS SO YOU CAN MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT WORK. AND THEN FOR THE
SMALL LANDOWNER THEIR BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS THE COST OF DOING THE
THP ITSELF IS SO GRAT THAT IT
IT MAKES NO FINANCIAL SENSE TO
DO IT. AND SO YOU HAVE A- ON THE
PRIVATE LANDSCAPE THAT'S THE
BIGGEST IMPEDIMENTS TO DOING.
MORE OF THE WORK THAT I THINK WE
ALL AGREE NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND
SO I MEAN ARE WE DOING SPECIFIC
THINGS TO. MAKE THAT HAPPEN YOU
KNOW TO STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS
ON THE THP SIDE. FOR BOTH YOU
KNOW COMMERCIAL OPERATIONS IN
SMALL LANDOWNERS. THEN AFTER
QUESTION I'LL ASK- IF FOR ANY OF
OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS WE
CAN COME BACK TO THE TO
GALLAGHER IF YOU HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I WANNA
MAKE SURE WE GET EVERYBODY AND.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER SO AND LET ME ANSWER
KIND OF BOTH PARTS HERE SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE- WERE AT.
NOT COMPLETING BUDGET DOLLARS
SO. THAT THE CURRENT
STREAMLINING MONEY IN THE BUDGET
IS SPECIFICALLY FOR- A WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE PROJECTS- THAT ARE
LIKE FUEL REDUCTION AND
STRATEGIC FUEL BREAKS AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE- AND SO THOSE
ARE ALL PERMITS STREAMLINING
AROUND THE CAL DTP. SO I'M NOT
FUNDING TO MILLION IS FOR THE
STATE WATER BOARD. WHICH FUNDS
THEIR STAFF SO THAT THEY DO NOT
CHARGE. AN EXTRA FEE FOR THE
AUTOMATIC ENROLLMENT PERMIT AND
THAT GETS US AGAIN. THE FIRST
FULLY SYNCHRONIZED- PERMIT IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS A AT LEAST
BIRDS PERCEIVE OR PROCESS I
DON'T IS BECAUSE I TO MY LINK.
BUT IT'S- IT IS IT IS THE CDC
CHOIR. WATER BOARDS AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE PERMITS ALL IN ONE
APPLICATION WITH NO FEET. I'M
AND THAT'S WHAT YOUR INVESTMENT
HAS HELPED US DELIVER AND- AND
DO SOMETHING INCREDIBLY
INNOVATIVE IN THIS SPACE. WHAT
SUPPORT FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. AND AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE L. A-
MENTIONED. THIS PROCESS IS
INCREDIBLY NEW. SO THE STATE
WATER BOARD JUST PASSED- THAT
AUTOMATIC ENROLLMENT THIS JULY.
SO THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY NEW
PROCESS. AND AND DEAN YEAH IT
FORTY FIVE TEMPLATES THAT ARE
GOING TO HELP MAKE THIS. MORE
USER FRIENDLY AND EASIER FOR
PEOPLE. TO NAVIGATE- ARE ROLLING
OUT AS WE SPEAK. SO IN THE NEXT
YEAR OR TWO WE HOPE TO SEE THIS
BEING. THE NORM THIS IS A MUCH
FASTER PROCESS. AND I AND WE ARE
EXCITED TO SEE IT ROLLING OUT I
THINK. THAT I JUST JACK
CONFIRMED WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THERE'S- CURRENTLY YOU KNOW JUST
DIE SEVENTEEN PROJECTS- IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS HAVE USED. CAL
T. P. AND WE ANTICIPATE TO SEE A
LOT MORE. ROLLING OUT IN THE
FUTURE- AS THESE PROJECTS ARE
FUNDED. AND- AND AS THESE ARE-
LAID OUT. WEST ON THE CHAMBER
HER OKAY IS FUNDED BY THAT IS.
BACKROOM STREAMLINING PROCESS IS
TACK WE HAVE THAT FOR MANAGED
TASK MORE AS WE SPEAK A
MECHANISM TO THERAPY IS CALTRAIN
THIS ONLINE STUFF TIME WE'VE
HOWEVER IN ONLINE SEEK A QUITE A
LINK APPLE. CURRENTLY THAT THIS
THEY TREES ONLINE NUMBER HARVEST
PROCESS- IS PROUD. THE PMR IN A
PERMITS OUR FOR HARPER WHICH
AGAIN I'M TAKE ABOUT FIVE DAY
TURN- AND WHAT WE'RE MORE TO SEE
IS THE MA THAT WE THE CAL BTP.
WILL MULTI AGENCY SINGLE PROCESS
THEN AFTER OVER TO THE HARVEST
PLANS WHEN I WITH THE CAL TREES
ON APPLE PROCESS SO WE ARE
EXCITED TO BE MOVING IN AFTER.
AND AND GRATEFUL FOR THE
COLLABORATION TO GET THERE
BECAUSE WE ARE REALLY COMMITTED
TO ENSURING THAT GREEN TAPE AND
PROCESS DOESN'T SLOW DOWN- OUR
PROGRESS. NO THAT'S GOOD AND SO
THE INTENT IS TO SAY. THE
PROCESS THROUGH K. TREES AS WE-
RIGHT. YEAH THAT IS THAT IS THE
GOAL GREAT SECUREMENT. THANK YOU
BUT WELL MR FONG AND THEN MISTER
SMITH. I THINK THIS CHAIR- FIRST
LET ME JUST THANK- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AS WELL- WENT OUT
OF MY- ACCOLADES- YOU CERTAINLY
HAVE HAD A LOT TO DEAL WITH OVER
THE PAST A FEW YEARS BUT OF
COURSE THROUGHOUT YOUR WHOLE
CAREER- JUST A JOB TO- TO DEPUTY
TO. THE DEPUTY SECRETARY MORSE.
THE GOAL IS STILL FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES- TREATED FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THAT
CORRECT. THE SCALING UP TO THAT
SO WORKING THAT'S THE GOAL LAID
OUT BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OKAY
SO WHERE HOW MANY ACRES HAVE
BEEN TREATED SO FAR AS IS THAT
IN THE STATE. SO I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE FORCE MANAGEMENT
TASK FORCE IS LAYING OUT THE
MILLIONAIRE- STRATEGY AND- AND
IS HELPING US IDENTIFY WHICH
OCCURS COUNT WHICH OCCURS- AND
HOW WE ARE GOING TO GET TO.
THOSE THOSE ACRES AND CHIEF
PORTER MAY WANT TO ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN TERMS OF-
WHERE WE ARE RELATIVE TO THE
TARGET. SURE I JUST WANNA KNOW
WHERE WE ARE NOW MOVING FORWARD
SO CHEAP WATER OR OR- OR MISSED
MOST OF WHAT HOW MANY ACRES HAVE
BEEN TREATED. NUMBER FONG LET ME
LET ME- ANSWER THAT AS- BEST I
CAN- WHAT CAL FIRE IS TREATING
CURRENTLY AS I MENTIONED IS
GOING INTO CAL MAPPER WE HAVE A
CLEAR- PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT THAT
IS. WHAT WE DON'T HAVE THE IS-
SPECIFIC NUMBERS FOR ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS- BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
RECONCILING APPLES APPLES TO
APPLES- TYPE OF- ACCOUNTING. BUT
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN- ESTIMATED TO
BE AT ON ON THE ON THE STATE
SIDE IS BETWEEN. TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ALLEN. THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY. THOUSAND ACRES ON THE
STATE SIDE. ON THE FEDERAL SIDE-
THEY'VE BEEN ESTIMATING A RIGHT
AROUND THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TO THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY. FIVE
BUT YET BUT THIS YEAR. YES CALL
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWO ONE-
DISCLOSED AND LYFT ALL NUMBERS
ARE LOWER BECAUSE OF THE FIRE
ACTIVE SO I HAD THE. TWO FIFTY
TO THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND. TWO THREE ON TWENTY
THOUSAND ACRES- TREATED HOW MUCH
OF THAT IS PRIVATE AND HOW MUCH
HOW MUCH OF IT IS NOT PRIVATE-
WHAT WHAT THE THREE THE THREE
FORTY THREE SIXTY THAT I
MENTIONED IS ALL FEDERAL. THE
REST OF THAT IS IN STATE AND
PRIVATE AND I DON'T HAVE THE
BREAKDOWN ANYTHING THE CALGARY
HOUSING IN CAL MAPPER- BY AND
LARGE IS ON. PRIVATE LANDS WITH
A SMALL PORTION OF THAT ON STATE
LAND AS AS YOU KNOW STATE LANDS
ARE ONLY 3% SURE OF THE- WE GET
. A DOLLAR GET I AYE AND WHAT
I'M FOR TO- AND IT'S IT. A
BASELINE AND I APPRECIATE- YOU
KNOW YOUR WORK I'M I'M JUST
UNDERSTAND. AS WE MOVE INTO AS
WE AS WE WE'VE GOTTEN THROUGH
THE PART WHEN THE WORSE AS YOU
HAD OUTLINED THE ONE OF THE
WORST WILDFIRE YEARS WE'VE HAD.
WHERE WE STARTING FROM. SO I CAN
CLEARLY SEE THE STATE RIGHT NOW
THAT. AT THIS VERY MOMENT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS DONE BUT
TO A FIFTY THOUSAND THREE ON
TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES TREATED
WITH THE MAJORITY OF IT BEING
DONE ON PRIVATE LAND. YES AND
THAT'S THAT'S THOSE ARE THAT'S
AN AVERAGE RANGE OVER THE LAST.
THREE TO FOUR YEARS. OKAY
SUPPOSED TO AND THEN A MY
UNDERSTANDING LOOKING AT THE-
THE CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE FORCED
RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN THAT
ABOUT TWO AND A FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES IS PRIVATE. MOST LIKELY.
FIVE PROBABLY NOT ALL OF THAT
STREET- IN THOSE YEARS BACK SO I
HAVE SORTED INTO TWO BASKETS
FEDERAL. AND PRIVATE RIGHT. WELL
BASICALLY- ALTERNATELY GOING TO
BE CAL FIRE'S- AND THE TASK
FORCE'S RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ACCOUNTING FOR THE STATE PRIVATE
AND IT'LL BE THE FEDERAL THAT
WILL- ACCOUNT FOR THE FEDERAL
OKAY WHAT THOSE AS APPLE'S ALL
INTO THE SAME BASKET SO WE CAN
ACCOUNT FOR THEM AND BE ABLE TO
ADJUST FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S
COUPLE WARM THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR
STATE AND PRIVATE WORK AS WELL
AS ON FEDERAL GROUNDS SO WE SO
WE ARE ABLE TO YOU ARE REALLY-
EIGHT THE PICTURE. AND HAVING
BEEN SOMEBODY WHO LIVES THROUGH-
THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT CAME IN
THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
BEETLE KILL THERE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS PLUS I
THINK IT ENDED UP BEING ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED OVER SEVEN ABOUT
SIX. SIX YEARS- THAT MONEY THAT
CAME IN- WITH THE GOAL POST KEPT
MOVING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON WHERE WHAT KIND OF
REPORTING WE NEEDED TO DO OVER
TIME. WHILE WE'RE WORKING WITH
AS I MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WITH-
SERVICIOS IDENTIFYING WITH THE
TASK FORCE IN PLACE AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I'M WORKING ON
WITH MY STATE FORESTERS ACROSS
THE NATION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ALL HAVE. THE ABILITY TO ACCOUNT
FOR AND UTILIZE PROCESSES WE
HAVE IN PLACE. WHAT I FOUND IS
THAT THE TASK FORCE IS LIGHT
YEARS AHEAD OF ANY OTHER STATE
IN THE SPACE AND WORKING WITH.
THE REGIONAL FORESTER FROM THE
FOREST SERVICE AND THE OTHER
FEDERAL LAND. OUT MANAGEMENT
AGENCIES. MAKE THAT A WE SO WE
ARE. GOING TO DRIVE THIS ON THE
NATION'S WATER. WHAT ARE THE GUY
I. ONE ECHO WHAT THE CHAIRS AND
RESEARCH NEED TO PUSH A FEDERAL
PART FOR FUNDING AND WORK TO BE
DONE ON THE FEDERAL LANDS. I
THINK THE FRUSTRATION THAT THAT
THAT WE HAVE AS- AT LEAST I'LL
SPEAK FOR MYSELF IN TERMS OF HOW
WE'RE- HOW WE'RE- TRACKING WHAT
WE'RE DOING AS A STATE. IS THAT
AND I ASK THAT I ASKED I ASKED
THIS QUESTION TODAY MAYBE YOU
CAN ANSWER THIS AS WELL IS THAT
WHAT IS SUCCESS. I LOOKED AT I
MEAN ALL YOUR PRESENTATIONS OF
AN INDEPENDENT FUNDING IS
IMPORTANT. ALL THE PRESENTATIONS
OF OUTLINED THE AMOUNTS BEING
SPENT. BUT THE AMOUNTS DOESN'T
DEFINE SUCCESS. IT'S THE AMOUNT
. OVERLAID WITH SOMETHING ELSE
AND THAT SOMETHING ELSE AT THE
LOOK AT THIS TIME ANALYZE WHAT
WAS. MENTIONED BY THE VILLAGE OF
ANNA'S OFFICE IS ACRES TREATED.
AND SO ARE WE TREATING THE ACRES
NECESSARY. TO MINIMIZE THESE
CATS ARE QUALIFIERS. AND AT THE
VERY MOMENT AND WHETHER IT'S-
CALVET RADIO OR WHATEVER THEY
OUTLET IS OR EVEN FOR US IS THAT
WE HAVING A HARD TIME. GETTING
THOSE NUMBERS. I GUESS THE
BROADER QUESTION IS CAN WE EVEN
GET THESE NUMBERS IN REAL TIME.
BECAUSE AS AT THE MEET YOU WE
CERTAINLY ARE TRYING TO. ADDRESS
THIS- SITUATION A VERY NARROW
WINDOW I MEAN IS IT POSSIBLE TO
TRACK ACRES TREATED IN A REAL
TIME FASHION HIS CAL MAPPER
THAT- IS THAT THAT THAT PLATFORM. FOUR FUEL REDUCTION
TREATMENTS- RACKING EIGHTY HE-
THE TIMELINE IS ON A MONTHLY
BASIS AND CAL MAPPER IS UPDATED
ON A MONTHLY BASIS. OKAY BUT I
WASN'T ACCOUNT FOR IS LAG TIME
IN REPORTING INTO CAL MAPPER SO
IF INSPECTORS ARE OUT ON FIRES
OR- OR MADE MR INSPECTIONAL-
OVER FIRST ON A PROJECT OR OR
HIT IT THAT DAY BEFORE ACTUALLY.
FIVE HUNDRED ACRES WAS BURNT-
BAND THAT WILL COME BACK INTO
THE NUMBERS LATER SO THAT'S
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS. I IT
BLOCKS THE SCHOOL YEAR CLOSING
WHAT WE HAVE TO RECONCILE OUR
NUMBERS BEFORE WE WHAT I CALL
TOMBSTONE THE ACTUAL NUMBERS FOR
THE YEAR. IN AND AROUND
SEPTEMBER BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE
OTHER FACTORS THAT ARE GOING ON
IN JUSTIFICATION OF THE OF THE
ACTUAL ACRES THAT WERE TREATED
IN THAT FISCAL YEAR SO THAT'S
WHERE YOU GONNA SEE YES. RAPPER
IS GOING TO GIVE YOU AN ABILITY
TO GO ONTO THE CALIFORNIA
WEBSITE OR TAG IN THROUGH THE
TASK FORCE WEBSITE AND SEE WHAT
THOSE NUMBERS ARE INCLUDING THE
NUMBER OF PROJECTS NUMBER OF
ACRES TREATED. ARE THERE WILL BE
QUALIFIERS IN THEIR THAT EXPLAIN
WHAT ALL THAT. HOW COULD. I GET
THAT. WE JUST NEED TO KNOW THAT
THE NUMBER OF ACRES TREATED
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
IMPROVE ON- THAT I GUESS MAYBE
I'LL TURN TO A GO TO MY
QUESTIONS TO MATT AND TO- JOHN
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM- FROM THE ADMINISTRATION I
MEAN IS WHAT SHE'S SAYING
THROUGH. THE MAIL ARE THESE
PERMITS STREAMLINED BY THEY
SYNCHRONOUS. YOU GUYS ARE THAT
YOU GUYS REPRESENT MEMBERS WHO
ARE USERS OF THIS ARE TRYING TO
GET THESE PERMITS AND- TIMBER
HARVEST PLANS- IS THE SYSTEM
WORK. OKAY WORKS- YEAH AS FAR AS
COUNTRIES GOES- THAT CERTAINLY
IS HELPING BUT THAT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME IS JUST AN
ELECTRONIC WAY TO FILE A TIMBER
HARVEST PLAN IT'S NOT
SYNCHRONIZING WITH THE OTHER
PERMITS AND WELL WE HEARD FROM
JESSICA SETS A LONG TERM PLAN SO
YEAH WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
BUT- WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE YET.
YEAH MY CONCERN IS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS AND- WE DO HAVE THIS
TASK FORCE NOW AND THEY'RE
WORKING ON IT SO- THANK. THEM
FOR THEIR WORK THUS FAR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM TO
SEE THIS THROUGH TO COMPLETION.
HOW COULD. I'M IS A DS. I WOULD
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES- IS
PERMISSIBLE LININGS ON THE HAS
BEEN TARGET FOR SOMETIME I THINK
IT WAS MENTIONED FOURTEEN NINETY
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WHICH
PERMIT STREAMLINING WAS WINE-
JUST ONE OF THE MANY PRIORITIES-
THAT PROCESSES BEEN ONGOING FOR
A WHILE AND I WOULD ECHO JOHN'S-
STATEMENT IN THAT- WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MOVE FASTER- WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A BE HOLISTIC IN
TERMS OF NOTING ALL THE
NECESSARY PERMITTING TOGETHER.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS ON
MAKING THAT HAPPEN AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. OKAY SO THEN I GUESS
MY FINAL QUESTION GOING BACK. TO
MS MOORE'S IS. IT THE ONLY
PREDICTOR OF FUTURE BEHAVIOR IS.
PAST BEHAVIOR. THEN WHAT. WHAT
TRUST WE HAVE THAT THIS IS GONNA
WORK. FOR CAL BTP AND CAL TREES. ASKED ABSOLUTELY SO WE'RE WITH
THAT FOR MANAGEMENT FORCE
ALREADY SEEING PROGRESS I IN
THAT DO HAVE THE ACCOUNT
ELECTRONIC PERMITTING- AND-
MAYBE WE CAN ASK I- MSTS TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HIS
PERSPECTIVE ON THE CAL BTP AS
WELL I MEAN THEY BOTH ADDRESSED
I FEEL LIKE WE HAVE TWO MARTYRS
PLANS WE DO HAVE SOME PROGRESS
TO BE MADE AND THAT'S WHAT OUR
ACTIONS WITH THE TASK FORCE THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON
COLLABORATIVELY ON THE QALBI
TIKI IS PROBABLY THAT. THEY'RE
MORE PRESENT EXAMPLE. OKAY SO. A
MUCH BY- BY THE ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS PALACE AB FOURTEEN
NINETY TWO. FROM TWENTY TWELVE-
PROVIDED A CONSISTENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR STAFF AND REVIEW OF
TIMBER HARVESTING ACTIVITIES AND
ONE OF THOSE REQUIREMENTS IS AN
ANNUAL REPORT. DUE ON OR BEFORE
JANUARY TENTH OF EACH YEAR-
REGARDING THE- OUTLINING A
REGARDING THE ACTIVITIES OF ALL
STATE DEPARTMENTS AGENCIES AND
BOARDS. RELATING TO FORCED INTO
REGULATION. RIGHT SO NOT ONLY IS
IT SUPPOSED TO CONTAIN THE
CAUSES ISSUE WITH A VIEW BUT
ALSO THE NUMBER OF PLANTS AND WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN. THIS REPORT.
SINCE. TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO ARE
WE GONNA GET ANOTHER REPORT. YES
THOSE ARE FORTHCOMING- AND YOU
SHOULD SEE THEM IN THE NEW YEAR
AND- WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOU ARE
WHERE YOU OF THEM AND DISCUSSING
THEM WITH YOU. OKAY AND WE'RE
GONNA GET EVERY YEAR. YES
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A BACKLOG-
FROM THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
AND- WE WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
CLEARING THAT BACKLOG. WHEN I
WAS PANDEMIC AND FIRE CRISIS
THAT DIVERTED- EVERYONE AND
WE'RE NOW- BACK ON TRACK SO
YOU'LL BE GETTING A SERIES OF
REPORTS SHORTLY. OKAY SOUNDS
GOOD THANK YOU. MISTER SMITH
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
SHOW UP LATE BUT THE MERCIA
SOUTHWEST I'LL FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT WITH THAT NO QUESTION
JESSICA. IN REGARDS TO BE IN
FIVE YEARS IN THE REAR BECAUSE
THAT MEANS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND BY
JANUARY TENTH. OF TWENTY TWO ARE
WE GONNA GET ALL FIVE OF THEM.
FROM FIVE YEARS BACKLOG. YEAH
WELL WE SHOULD BE CAUGHT UP BY
EARLY IN THE NEW YEAR- THEY'RE
ALL WRITTEN AND IN THE CLEARANCE
PROCESS COMING OUT. SOON SO.
WE'LL HAVE A LOT OF REPORTS AT
TO ENJOY. OKAY AND THEN I JUST
WANT TO PUT IT ANOTHER COULD
ROSE INTO THE CHIEF. AND HIS
RETIREMENT. HOME WELL SERVED
OVER THE YEARS- PROBABLY IS A
GOOD TIME AT THE LAST TWO YEARS
OF WORK IN YOUR OF. TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY IN THESE FIRES THAT
WE'VE HAD IN THIS. FIFTH BUT I
WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE CAL MAPPING. FOR
THE CHIEF. IS THAT ALL ONLINE SO
ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC CAN GO
ONLINE AND LOOK AT THAT MAP AND
SEE AS IT'S UPDATED EVERY MONTH
THAT YOU SAID. YES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YEAH IT IS. IT'S WIRED
AND IT'S AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
AND SO YES. OKAY YEAH SERVICE
FOLLOW UP FOR THAT. AND THEN I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD SWITCHED GEARS
TO. OF MET DIARSE WITHOUT
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION DID I HEAR
YOU CORRECTLY SAID ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION. PEOPLE BOARD FEET
BURNED. SO THE TWO NUMBERS I
THREW OUT OVER ONE APPROX FREE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION BILLION
BOARD FEET ARE PROCESSED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE DATA
THAT WERE RUNNING THROUGH ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS AND THE DATA THAT
WERE RUNNING THROUGH RIGHT NOW
IT APPEARS THAT ON PRIVATE LAND
WITHIN THE PERIMETER OF THE
DIXIE FIRE THAT ONE POINT SIX
BILLION BOARD FEET BURNED. WHAT
IS THE COST OF ONE POINT SIX
BILLION. BOARD FEET. IF THAT WAS
ECONOMY IF WE WAS TABLED UP. OF
MANAGE AND FORCED TO CUT INTO
THE TIMBER WHAT WOULD BE THE
REVENUE TWO OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND DOLLAR
VALUES WELL THAT'S IT THAT'S A
COMPANY THAT THAT IS A BIT OF A
COMPLICATED QUESTION BECAUSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A MARKET
THAT HAS DIFFERENT SPECIES IN
YOUR TAX AND SO ON AND SO FORTH
BUT OUR MEMBERS ARE ESTIMATING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
LOST AS IT RELATES TO THE DIXIE
FIRE ALLOWED NOTWITHSTANDING THE
SHEEP IN THE CALDOR AND THE
NORTH COMPLEX FROM LAST YEAR IN
THE AUGUST COMPLEX FROM THE YEAR
BEFORE THAT LETTER. AND SAID THE
YEAR BEFORE THAT LITERALLY WENT
UP IN SMOKE. YEAH I MEAN WHAT
WHAT THE THAT WHILE FAR IMPAIR
ARE SOLD. ON INDUSTRY NOW THAT
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS ARE ARE
CLEARLY. EVEN CONTEMPLATING
THEIR CONTINUED INVESTMENT FOR
STRING CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
SEVERAL SEVERAL MEMBER COMPANIES
THAT. HAVE LOST NEARLY HALF
THEIR ASSETS IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND ARE. ON THE PRECIPICE
OF BEING WIPED OFF THE MAP TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT AND- YOU KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO THINK ABOUT
THIS AS IT RELATES TO- NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- CASCADES AND SIERRAS
BUT- WE HAVE ONE OF OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES LOCATED IN SANTA CRUZ
JUST NORTH OF SANTA CRUZ
CALIFORNIA. SMALL FAMILY ON MAIL
BEEN THERE FOR. ALMOST EIGHTY
YEARS OF NOT EIGHTY YEARS
ALREADY AND- THE CZ ALIGNING
COMPLEXES. ONE OF IT- EVENTS
THAT HAS SIGNIFICANTLY ALTERED
THEIR ABILITY TO BE. I GUESS
FLEXIBLE OR OPERATE AT ALL IN IN
THE CLIMATE IN WHICH THEY'RE
THRUST SO IF IT'S A PROBLEMATIC
SHOULD CONTINUE INVESTMENT. AND
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY IS I WOULD
SUGGEST. QUESTIONED AT BEST. AND
THEN PRETTY MUCH FOLLOWED UP
WITH THE JESSICA'S COMMENTS THAT
SHE'S TRYING TO STREAMLINE THE
THREE PER PERMIT PROCESS AND
DON'T WANT AND THEN IT SHOULD
TAKE A COUPLE MONTHS WE'VE BEEN
WAKE IT WENT PRETTY MUCH WORKING
ON IT FOR TEN YEARS NOW CAN YOU
KEEP US ABREAST IT INFORMED. IF
THIS PROCESS DOES HAPPEN MAYBE
JUNE OF TWENTY TWO AND NOT
ANOTHER FIVE OR TEN YEARS THAT
WE KEEP KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD SAY AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
BUREAUCRATS THAT WE'RE GONNA SAY
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT HAPPEN WE'RE
GONNA MAKE IT HAPPEN. BUT IT
NEVER HAPPENS. WE CONTINUE TO
TRACK IT WILL BE HAPPY TO.
PROVIDE YOU WITH ANY INFORMATION
AS RELATES TO PROGRESS MADE AND
I WILL NOTE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
IS- IT'S REVOLVING THESE
DISCUSSIONS ARE ONGOING RIGHT
NOW DELAY TO TRY TO MOVE THE
BALL FORWARD. I'M GETTING
THERE'S STREAMLINING PROCESS THE
CARACTERES PROCESS. FULLY MATURE
WHERE WE ARE FULLY INVOLVED IN
THAT OKAY AND THEN THOUGH I'LL
GO AHEAD NEXT UP MISTER ANDERSON
A QUESTION. DIRECTOR OF FORESTRY
POLICY MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY. HOW MANY ACRES DO YOU
GUYS MANAGE. ARE WE MANAGE ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF REDWOODS AND DOUGLAS
FIR OKAY IN MANY FIRES IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS AND YOUR
MANAGEMENT BAKERY TO TAKE CARE
OF- I'M IN NO NOT LAST THREE
YEARS THE LAST TIME WE WERE HIT
HARDEST TWO THOUSAND EIGHT- WHEN
WE HAD ROUGHLY. TWENTY SEVEN
FIRE START OVERNIGHT DUE TO
LIGHTNING SO MAYBE WE SHOULD
CONTACT WITH YOU AND MAKE YOUR
PERMITTED PROCESS IS REAL QUICK
SO YOU CAN GET IT DONE AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE WILL
NOT KEEP. LIKE WE'RE DOING
MANAGING. JUST A COMMENT. FOR
THAT STUFF. BUT I COULD. NOT I
LIKE TO DISCUSSION I SHOWED UP
LATE. BUT I REALLY THINK WE
GOTTA GET TO THE POINT. IN
CALIFORNIA MY ENVIRONMENTAL
FRIENDS. THERE'S NO TREES FOR
THE OWLS. THERE'S NOTE ANIMALS
LEFT IN THE FOURTH DOCTOR. THAT
ARE TAKING CARE OF WE GOT BEARS
THAT ARE COMING DOWN AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. WE HAVE TO GET
BACK TO MANAGING OUR FOREST
CONTAINING IT OUT. SO WE DON'T
HAVE THE GIANT WILDFIRES IS IT
SAID WHEN THE FIRE BROKE DOWN
GOT ON THE GROUND. FIRE DIES OUT
SO FIREFIGHTERS CAN MANAGE IT.
THAT IS A KEY SO HOPEFULLY WE
CAN GET INTO THAT. IN THE MONEY
AND RESOURCES THAT WE'VE- SENT
TO ALL THE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE. THAT WE GET IT DONE. AND
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU- I JUST
HAVE ONE QUICK COMMENT- FOR- MS
QUINN DAVIDSON- AND IT. WHICH IS
ACTUALLY JUST A REQUEST TO BE IN
TOUCH WITH- MY STAFF WORK FOR
MYSELF REGARDING THE INSURANCE
ISSUE. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
RAPIDLY BECOMING A CRISIS I
HEARD ONLY YESTERDAY- FROM A
CONSTITUENT WHO'S- INSURANCE
BILL WENT FROM TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR IN THIS. I THINK
IN MY DISTRICT THERE TENDS TO BE
A LITTLE BIT OF A- ASSUMPTION
THAT- EVERYBODY CAN AFFORD TO
SELF INSURE OR AFFORD THAT KIND
OF A INSURANCE BILL BUT IN FACT-
THIS IS GOING TO FORCE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR HOMES. IF WE
DON'T FIND A SOLUTION FOR IT. MR
FONG DID YOU WANT TO. GET ON ON
ON THAT AND I HAVE A QUESTION I
FORGOT TO ASK- FOR BITCOIN
DAVIDSON AND- YOU MENTIONED THAT
YOU HAD A NUMBER OF- INDIVIDUALS
HAD GONE THROUGH- CERTIFICATION
BUT HAVEN'T GOTTEN APPROVED BY
THE STATE CAN YOU ELABORATE ON
THAT. IN TERMS OF WHAT THE HANG
UP IS OR WHAT THE- IS THERE SOME
WAY THAT WE CAN HELP WITH OR OR
OR FACILITATE THAT BECAUSE WE DO
NEED. FOR BUSES WE NEED MORE
PRESCRIBED BURNING CAN YOU
ELABORATE AND GIVE US MORE
DETAILS ON THAT. YEAH THANK YOU
I'M- SO. I THINK. THE HANG UP IS
PRIMARILY IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
CAL FIRE I THINK THIS IS A NEW
PROGRAM- AND IT'S SORT OF FINE
PEOPLE WHO ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
AGENCIES ACTUALLY. PRIVATE
PRACTITIONERS WHO DON'T WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA DON'T WORK TO THE
STATE. NECESSARILY AND SO I
THINK THERE'S JUST A LOT OF ROOM
TO GROWING PAINS AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO ROLL THIS
PROGRAM OUT. AND HOW TO MAKE IT
MAKE SENSE IF WITH THE SYSTEM
THAT'S IN PLACE- THAT SAID I
THINK IT'S ALSO BEEN KIND OF PUT
ON THE BACKBURNER AND- AND NOT
BEEN GIVEN THE ATTENTION THAT IT
NEEDS AND- THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO WORK WITH CAL FIRE
JUST TO. MAKE SURE TO ELEVATE
THIS AND SAY. YOU KNOW THE
CURRENT SYSTEMS THAT ARE IN
PLACE ARE NOT GOING TO
FACILITATE THIS PROGRAMS WE NEED
TO RETHINK THOSE SYSTEMS
BECAUSE- WE NEED THESE PEOPLE
AND WE CANNOT WAIT ANOTHER YEAR
WE CAN EVEN WAIT ANOTHER TWO
MONTHS- WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN SO. I DAY I KNOW
THEY JUST MET YESTERDAY I
HAVEN'T HAD AN UPDATE ON NOT YET
BUT I REALLY THINK IT'S ABOUT
COMMITTING TO. TO A DIFFERENT
WAY OF DOING THINGS AND IT'S A
LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE PROBABLY
FOR THAT YOU KNOW PROFESSIONAL
FIRE ORGANIZATION. BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
I CERTAINLY. YOUR A VIRGIN AND I
APPRECIATE THE FOR THEM IN.
THANK YOU. MISTER AND I JUST. DO
I TO MOVE TO PUBLIC COM SO WE
CAN. JUST A COUPLE QUICK FALL OF
THE AND ON THE PRESCRIBED FIRE
IN A THE GALLAGHER AT THE OTHER
TO WANTED- A- ALASKA. SO SHE-
SHOULD YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- AND
MR FONG- FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK I THINK- WHEN YOU'RE
COVERED IT QUITE WELL- WITH
RESPECT TO- THE PERSPECTIVES OF
FROM A PRACTITIONER FROM A
TRAINER OF- THE- PERSPECTIVES
BURN BOSSES. WHAT NEEDS TO BE
ALSO A PART OF THIS CONVERSATION
IS THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR AND
THAT. IS THE FIRST CLASS THAT'S
BEEN UNDERTAKEN TO CERTIFY THESE
NON AGENCY- BURN BOSSES WERE
COMMITTED TO THE PROCESS WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING THROUGH-
THE CERTIFICATION ISSUES BUT THE
IF THE ISSUE IS THAT NONE OF
THE- PURCHASE OFFENSE. WERE
CERTIFIED AS MEETING THE MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS BEFORE THE CLASS
STARTED NOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
GOING BACK AND DOING HISTORICAL
RECOGNITION OF THOSE SKILLS AND
ABILITIES THAT. THAT- WHEN YOU
HAVE HAD NOT YOU. HI MISTER
GALLAGHER BACKED YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OUT ON THEPRESCRIBED FIRE SIDE AGAIN- AT I
THINK WE DID SOME GREAT WORK
LEGISLATIVE. LEGISLATIVELY THIS
YEAR THAT'S GOING TO HELP THAT
IMPORTANT TOOL AND I THINK IT'S
A KIND OF REDISCOVERING IN SOME
WAYS THAT IMPORTANT TOOL- IN
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE- IN OUR
PLAN LIKE DO WE HAVE AN ESTIMATE
OF HOW MANY ACRES HE MIGHT TRY
TO- TREAT WITH PRESCRIBED FIRE
OVER THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO. AND
I'M NOT SURE WHO THAT QUESTIONS
DEDICATED TO I WOULD LOVE TO
CHIME IN ON IT FOR A MOMENT AND-
EIGHT AS YOU'RE A LOT IN THIS.
HEARING THAT QUESTIONS AROUND
ACRES AND I AM A SUPER TYPE A
PERSON AND LOVE NOTHING MORE
THAN JUST BEING ABLE TO SIT DOWN
AND COUNT SOMETHING UP- THANK
YOU JUST ONE ADVOCATE FOR YOU
ALL TO REMEMBER THAT THIS
PROBLEM ISN'T AS SIMPLE AS JUST
TELLING ACRES I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT IT'S ABOUT. YES IT'S
ABOUT THE RIGHT ACRES AND
GETTING THOSE ACRES OUT BUT IT'S
ALSO ABOUT A LOT OF QUALITY TO
THINGS THAT ARE HARDER TO MAYBE
WRAP OUR HEAD AROUND BUT
CRITICAL LIKE. BUILDING A
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE TO PLAY
THESE APPROACHES IT'S ABOUT
RESHAPING OUR ECONOMY SO THE
PROFESSIONALS CAN EARN A LIVING
WAGE IT'S ABOUT CHANGING FEDERAL
AND STATE PROCUREMENT MECHANISMS
THAT WE CAN DO THINGS IN A WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE IT'S ABOUT.
ADJUSTING STATE AGENCIES WAY OF
DOING BUSINESS SO THAT YOU'RE
NOT TRAINING CAPACITY BY NOT
PAYING THEM FOR THE ACTUAL
OVERHEAD REACH- I THINK THESE
ISSUES ARE REALLY ABOUT
INVESTING ORGANIZATIONAL
TECHNICAL CAPACITY OF. OVER TWO
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
STATE WHO WANT TO BE AND WHO ARE
PARTNERS TO DO THIS WORK BUT
THERE'S FUNDAMENTAL STRUCTURAL
DESIGN PROBLEMS THAT STOPS THE
BOTTLENECK RIGHT. THAT'S WHEN I
SEE A WATERSHED CENTER WHEN I
SIT DOWN TO ASK OUR FORRESTER
ONE STOPPING YOU FROM TAKING ON
MORE PROJECTS WHAT'S STOPPING
YOU FROM DOING. WORK AT A
GREATER SCALE THAT'S THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION I GOT FROM
THOSE TWO HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THESE SIMPLE. THINGS LIKE
OVERHEAD MIGHT SEEM REALLY I'M
COMPILING IT MIGHT NOT BE AS
LIKE POLITICAL BUT I THINK TAKE
TAKE A STANCE ON IT SOMETHING
LIKE PLANNING OR PERMITTING YOUR
MONEY TO CONCORD SPENT. I JUST
WANT TO SHARE YOU WITH YOU THAT
THAT IS. THE WATERSHEDS
PERSPECTIVE THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THAT'S REALLY STANDING LAMP.
MORE GOOD WORK GETTING DONE-
MALL TYPE APPROACH AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHY. MY INITIAL. ON THE
PROCESS AND LOT OF THINGS STAND
IN WAY- BUT IS THERE AN ESTIMATE
ON LIKE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO DO IN TERMS OF ESTIMATED A
PRESCRIBED FIRE TREATMENTS.
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT. AND IF YOU GET TO
KNOW LIKE WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO
DO OVER THE NET IN THE IMMEDIATE. I CAN CHIME IN ON THAT- AND I
TOTALLY SECOND WED ALISON SAID
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT ACRES
ST. IT'S REALLY ABOUT VESTING
PEOPLE AND OF THE STRUCTURAL
CHANGES BUT- THAT'S SAID THAT
STRATEGIC- PLAN FOR PRESCRIBED
FIRE THAT I MENTION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE. HAS ONE
BEEN WORKING NOT. CLEARLY
OUTLINED SOME ACREAGE TARGETS
FOR DIFFERENT ENTITIES SO FOR
FEDERAL STATE PRIVATE PARTNERS.
I'M SO YOU COULD LOOK TO THAT
AND SEE SOME PRETTY SPECIFIC
NUMBERS THAT ARE LAID OUT- I DID
WANT TO CORRECT ONE THING THAT
THE CHIEF PORTER SAID ABOUT THE-
THE BURN BOSSES BECAUSE- YOU
MENTIONED IT. BUT NO ONE WHO HAD
A FIGHTER TAKING THE COURSE HAD
MET TO MEET THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS AND- THAT'S NOT
TRUE IT'S JUST- WE ACTUALLY HAD
NINE PEOPLE IN THAT CLASS WHO
ARE TYPE TWO. FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED BURN BOSSES WITH
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE SO
ACTUALLY FAR EXCEED THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE STATE
CERTIFICATION. I THINK IT'S
JUST- WE'RE DEALING WITH
MATCHING DIFFERENT SYSTEMS IN.
CALIFORNIA HAS THEIR OWN SYSTEMS
THEY DON'T REALLY- EASILY MERGE
WITH THE FEDERAL QUALIFICATIONS
OR WITH THE- PRIVATE SIDE SO I
THINK. YOU KNOW THE OLYMPIAN
HE'S OR CULTURAL ISSUES THAT
NEED TO WORK AROUND BUT A LOT OF
ITS WITHIN HEALTHCARE CULTURE
AND THAT THEY'RE KIND OF SILO
DON'T HAVE THEIR OWN SYSTEMS IN
PLACE. AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RECOGNIZE
OTHER WAYS OF DOING THINGS.
INCLUDING THAT SOME KIND OF
PRIMARY PRESCRIBED FIRE
QUALIFICATION SYSTEM WHICH IS
THE FEDERAL SYSTEM. SO I JUST
WANT. TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS THAT
WAS IN THERE. TO CLEAR THE WRECK
- I SAID SIR. A HEAD OF TIME.
MEANING SIR. INTO THE PRO. SO
THAT'S WHAT'S DONE THERE WE'RE
WE ARE READY. THOSE AS WE SPEAK-
THERE'S A THE TEAM HAS BEEN
PULLED TOGETHER. WHILE THEY'RE
FOLLOWING THE- PROCESS THAT WAS
PUT IN PLACE BY. THE TEAM THAT
LANIER WAS A PARTNERSHIP THAT
BUILT THIS PROGRAM. IT'S ALL ON
PROGRESS. SO YOU MEANT THAT IS A
QUICK QUESTION TO GET IS AN
ESTIMATE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING BUT
I'LL MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE REALLY
I THINK WE CAN MAYBE DO THIS
QUICKLY REALLY GOT TO WRAP THIS
UP THE- FAST BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
PEOPLE WAITING TO SPEAK AND- I
WANT PM ADDRESS I'M BEING VERY
FAST I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
OTHERS BUT I'M BEING VERY FAST
FIVE HUNDRED HIGH PRIORITY FUEL
BREAKS WE MOVED WE WENT FROM THE
THIRTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE- IN THE
PLAN WE IDENTIFY ONE MOVES UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED WHERE WE HAD ON
THAT CHIEF AND- IT WAS THE
STATUS OF. OF DOING THOSE HIGH
PRIORITY FUEL BREAKS. ON THE-
CAL MAPPER WEBSITE- THE
DASHBOARD SHOWS THE NUMBER OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE IN PLAY- IN. A
VERY US LEVELS OF TREATMENT. ARE
THERE ARE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PROJECTS ON THAT CURRENTLY. IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR AND THERE WERE
LAST YEAR AS WELL SO. THAT WILL
BE THE PLACE TO GO AND TRACK
THAT. RIGHT WHEN YOU CROSS THE
FISCAL YEAR IT'S GOING TO BE A
SMALLER NUMBER JUST AT THE
BEGINNING BUT IT. RAPIDLY RAMPS
UP. OKAY AND THEN JUST ON THE
WORK FORCE VERY QUICKLY A DEGREE
THAT'S A BIG PART OF THIS- MAYBE
TO JESSICA. EXPERTS SORRY.
DEPUTY SECRETARY MORSE- THE- THE
CCC SEEMS TO ME TO BE A VERY BIG
PARTNER. IN HELPING TO DEVELOP
THAT. BUT THEY'VE BEEN ACTUALLY
CUT BACK THAT RECENTLY I MEAN
ARE WE PLANNING TO REALLY. TRY
TO REINVIGORATE THAT AND EVEN
EVEN THE PRISON CAMPS. I THINK
IT'S BEEN A REALLY GOOD PROGRAM
WE SHUT ONE DOWN THIS YEAR- YOU
KNOW THAT'S- YOU KNOW FOR PEOPLE
COMING OUT- THE OF PRISON AND
WANTED TO DEVELOP NEW SKILLS AND
GET INTO LIKE. A TRADE IN THE
FIELD- THAT HAS BEEN AND I THINK
A PROVEN SYSTEM. ONE THAT'S BEEN
RECOGNIZED BUT THEY GOT BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
BUT- WE'RE SCALING BACK ON THAT
ARE THOSE. ARE WE PLANNING TO
KIND OF. RE INVEST IN THOSE
PROGRAMS- ACTUALLY. BY FOR THE
CONSERVATION CORPS IN THE
WILDFIRE SPACE- FROM FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS I IN THEIR BASE
FUNDING FOR FORCED RECORD TO
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
BUDGET. I'M WE ALSO INVESTED
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN CHICO-
THAT RELAUNCHING THEIR CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROGRAM ONE OF THE
CONSTRAINING FACTORS WITH THE
CONSERVATION CORPS. HAS BEEN AND
THEIR LACK OF BED CAPACITY AND
SO THIS HELPS INCREASE-
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THAT WILL-
GET THEM MORE SPACE TO BE ABLE
TO BRING IN NEW RESIDENTIAL
CENTERS- AND EXPAND THE
CAPACITY. WE ARE SO PROUD OF THE
CONSERVATION CORPS PROGRAM I
MEAN IT IS REALLY MODELING-
INCREDIBLE RESULTS ON. BOTH YOU
GETTING US AID WELL TRAINED
WORKFORCE IN THE SPACE BUT ALSO-
SERVE AS SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES
RIGHT HERE THEY ARE BRINGING IN
OFTEN. USE HILL- HAVE HAD FEWER
OPPORTUNITIES- AND THEY ARE
COMING INTO A SPACE WHERE THEY
ARE GETTING STRUCTURE SUPPORT-
AND JUST DOING INCREDIBLE WORK I
AM JUST CONSISTENTLY IMPRESSED.
WITH THE CONSERVATION CORPS
YOUTH THAT I NEED OUT IN THE
FIELD AND THEIR DEDICATION TO
THE S. AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE RETAIN THEM- WITH THESE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT DOLLARS
INTO CAREER PATHWAYS. I'M
ANOTHER LARGE SUCCESSES ACTUALLY
BEEN SOME OF THE TRAINING
PROGRAMS AROUND- FORMER INMATES
SO THE MENTOR TRAINING CENTER IS
A REALLY GOOD MODEL. THAT I
WOULD POINT YOU TOWARDS- THE
WHERE IT'S A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE CONSERVATION CORPS
CAL FIGHTER ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. AND SAID THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IT'S THE
FIRST PILOT WHERE THEY WENT IN
AND- FOUND FORMER INMATES FROM
THE- WHO ARE ON PAROLE AFTER
BEING IN THE FIRE CAMPS. AND
THEY CAME INTO A FULLY
STRUCTURED REINTEGRATION PROGRAM
THAT I'M PROVIDED THEM TRAINING
IN FIREFIGHTER SKILLS AND- AND
ALSO- MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT AND-
AND- JOB SKILLS AND HELP. FOR
COMPLETE HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS
AND SUCH SO THAT THEY WALKED OF
THAT. ON READY TO BE BY THE WORK
FORCE AND IT BEEN A VERY IF.
ANTI RISK PROGRAMS I THAT I AS A
GREAT MY- THANK YOU VERY FOR THE
RESPONSE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO PUBLIC COMMENT NOW- I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
MAKE COMMENTS AT FIRST SO YOU
CAN RAISE YOUR HANDS NOW. AND
THE- PLEASE STEP FORWARD WILL
TAKE YOUR COMMENTS NOW BUT WHILE
YOU'RE STEPPING FORWARD I WANT
OF THOSE OF YOU WANT TO. ADDRESS
US BY PHONE- LET YOU KNOW THE
PHONE NUMBER AGAIN. IT'S ALSO ON
YOUR SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
OVER THE INTERNET. THE PUBLIC
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO AGAIN THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN WITH AN
ACCESS CODE OF ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AND WILL
ACT- COME BACK YOU IN A MOMENT
DUE TO THE LATENESS OF THE HOUR
GOING TO HAVE TO ASK THAT- WE
LIMIT OUR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE
PLEASE. WELCOME SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR AT
NUMBER OF MY NAME IS ROUGH GOAL
K. ON THE- OF SPEAKING AS A
MEMBER OF THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY
MOBILIZATION TASK FORCE THAT IS
LED BY- CAL BERKELEY
COUNCILMEMBER OR FORMER BERKELEY
COUNCILMEMBER CHERYL DAVILA. WHO
HAS GOT TO GET OUR- ELECTED
OFFICIALS CURRENT AND FORMER I
USED TO BE ON THE BOIL SCHOOL
BOARD FILE FOR THAT TASK FORCE.
AND ALSO- PERPETUALLY I'VE BEEN
A LEGISLATIVE AIDE FOR HEALTH
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND
ALSO WORKED. WITH- HE SAN
MEMBER FORMA MARK WILLIAMS OF
WITH SAVE OUR SENIORS NOW- I
APPRECIATE THE- HEARING TODAY
AND THE PRESENTERS OVERALL WE
ARE TO CLIMB EMERGENCY. MANY
CITY THROUGH OFFICE THIS GREAT
STATE PROFESSOR MONICA TO DAVIS
AND MANY CALIPHATE THE QUICKLY
EMERGENCY- AND ESPECIALLY IN A
CITY OF BERKELEY- WE ARE AT
WILDFIRE RISKS- AND MANY THAT WE
CANNOT FORGET THAT THE MOST
WATER PROFESSOR ON HOUSE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE USUALLY ON THE
FRONT LINE FEEDING THE SMOKE. TO
WHEN YOU HAVE WINDS BLOWING
WILDFIRE AND BURST- PEOPLE ON
THE GROUND ARE MOST AFFECTED SO
WE CAN FORGET ABOUT THEM THANK
YOU FOR COULD WRAP UP PLEASE.
AND HOPE WE GET THE CLARA BIRDS
SEE AND GET OUR OWN HOUSE OF
RESIDENCE HEALTH AND HELP FIGHT
THE WILDFIRES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP- WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
OPERATOR. ARE YOU READY FOR US.
ABSOLUTELY WILL PER SCHOOL THE
LINE OF NUMBER TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR CAMERA'S
BRENDAN TAYLOR NUMBER AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION HOUSING
EARLIER DISTRICTS PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN IMPLEMENTING THE
REQUIREMENTS AND MANDATES IN SB
TWELVE SIXTY- FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH CREATED A PROGRAM
TO EXPAND PRESCRIBED BURNING
INCLUDING INCREASED AIR
MONITORING. PUBLIC OUTREACH AND
OTHER RELATED WORK AND THIS
YEAR'S FINAL BUDGET INCLUDED TWO
MILLION FOR CONTINUING THEIR AT
THE TWELVE SIXTY MANDATED. A
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROGRAM WELL THE
FUNDING AMOUNTING TO MODERNISE
THIS PROGRAM IS PROVIDING
CRITICAL STATEWIDE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS AND THAT LEADS TO
BENEFITS AND WE URGE YOU TO MAKE
FUNDING ONGOING AS WELL AS
PREVIOUSLY RECOMMENDED YOU
CONSIDER. AND WE ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER INCREASING FUNDING SO
WE CAN DO EVEN MORE INCLUDING
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM AND
FUNDING TO INCREASE INCREASE NOT
MONITORING PUBLIC OUTRAGE IN
BETTER COORDINATION ACTIVITY
TRACKING ACROSS AGENCIES THAT
REGULATE PRESCRIBED BURNING. AND
LASTLY EMERGENCY RESPONSE IS AN
AREA THAT OBVIOUSLY REQUIRES
INCREASED EFFORTS IN ATTENTION
YEAH BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
FUNDING FOR THIS ACTIVITY AND
RESTRICTIONS ON HOW LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS FUNDING CAN BE USED.
DISTRICTS ARE LIMITED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES AND ASSISTANCE TO DO
THE JOB MILITANCY RESPONSE
RELATED FUNDING WOULD ALLOW US
TO TRAIN AND PROVIDE FOR A
RESOURCES ADVISORS FOR
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD FOCUS ON
MONITORING AND COORDINATION OF
SMOKE ACTIVITIES. DURING ACTIVE
EVENTS INCLUDING PUBLIC OUT
REACHED INFORM PEOPLE OF
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS THANK. YOU
CAN PROVIDED BY. ONE YEAH YEAH
WOULD SAY THAT WOULD BE TO. CHAT
MORE WITH YOU- IN YOUR- ABOUT A
RECALL. THANK YOU VERY FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE
. ANNEX OVERLAND OF TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAJOR MEMBERS
ALLEN TOWARDS THE THREE SIXTY B.
HAPPEN BEING POOREST FOUNDATION
FF WORK STAFF ON CALIFORNIA'S
HUNDRED FAMILY FORCED LANDOWNERS
. I SAID THEY WANT TO REITERATE
WHAT SUFFICIENTLY MANY BY ON THE
STEM POOREST THIS WON'T BE ABLE
TO THE WHILE PART PRICE AT THE
SKI THE MAN- WE THAT ARE CLOUD
SCIENCE IN- DEBBIE SO MORE
REFERENCE THE- SEEP IT. THAT IS
A QUICK PART FOR US AS PRIME
FAMILY MATTERS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING BE CAREFUL THAT TAKE CARE
OF THEIR LAND BUT THEY LACK THE
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL LONG
KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND RESOURCES
REQUIRED TO TACKLE WHAT WILDFIRE
RISK REDUCTION PROJECTS- THESE
FACTORS COMBINED WITH OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES REQUIRE POLICY
SOLUTIONS TO HELP PRIVATE AND
FAMILY LANDOWNERS TAKE ACTION TO
TACKLE THE REST ON THEIR LAND-
THE SECOND SESSION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
LEGISLATORS AND STAKEHOLDERS. ON
DEVELOPING A HUMAN TACKLE
SOLUTIONS MAXIMIZING THE
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT THE STATE
HAS MADE TO DATE- LOOK FORWARD
TO- WORKING- ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLKS ON THE GROUND TO REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK MISTER
CHAIR AND ALL THE MEMBERS
PRESENT DANGER IN- MORE. ON THE
SUPPORT ISSUES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER. WILL LINE-
GOOD SIXTY BALIKA UP THE TOWER
LIGHTS IT'S WHICH A PARTNERSHIP
OF LOCAL SPECIAL DISTRICTS
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS UP TO
DELETE DISTRICTS WORKING TO UP
FOR THE IMPLANTATION OF BIBLICO
- NORMALLY PERMIT PROGRAM ON THE
CALIFORNIA SIDE I MAINLY WANT TO
PASS ALONG THAT LINE HIS
APPRECIATION FOR THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE RESOURCES AGENCIES
INVESTMENT AND- WELL WHAT PART
OF THE. ACTIVITIES IN THE IN THE
TAHOE BASIN. RECENTLY COPY TALK
SERVER- THE SPA ARE GOING TO
ALLOW TO EXCEL THE WILL TO OF
THE LIKE TAHOE BASED FORCED PLAN
. WHICH WAS DEVELOPED. BY A
CALLED THE TO OF- FUEL FIRED
FUELS TEAM WHICH COMES OF THE
FEDERAL. TRIBAL AND CONSERVE AND
LAND MANAGEMENT IN THE TOP. I
WITH THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE RESOURCES
AGENCY ON FUTURE OF- INVESTMENTS
IN OUR FACE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AARON READ
REPRESENTING PROUDLY- SCALFARO
LOCAL TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS- WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATION THE
GOVERNMENT IN WORKING ON
PREVENTION WE REALIZE THAT IS A
REALLY LONG TERM EFFORT- WE HAVE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DEAD
AND DYING TREES IT WILL TAKE
DECADES TO CLEAN UP THE POOREST.
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR THAT FOR A
LONG TIME UNFORTUNATELY IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN BY THE PRESSING
CRISIS THAT HAS TO BE DEALT WITH
IN THE COMING SESSION IS A LACK
OF STAFFING I CALPERS OR
FIREFIGHTERS ARE ON THE FIRE
LINE FOR A MONTH AT A TIME
SOMETIMES EVEN LONGER THAN THAT
WE GET ONE DAY OFF THEIR BACK ON
THE FIRE FOR ANOTHER MONTH.
THEY'RE TOTALLY EXHAUSTED- THIS
IS GOING ON NOT JUST THIS YEAR
LAST YEAR BUT FOR SEVERAL YEARS
NOW- WE'RE GROSSLY UNDERSTAFFED
WE NEED MORE FIREFIGHTERS ON THE
FIRE LINE AND THAT IS AN URGENT
REQUEST BUT THIS COMMITTEE TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT- AS WE APPROACH
THE NEXT BUDGET- IN THE
DELIBERATIONS ABOUT THAT- THE
ONLY INCREASE WE HAD THIS YEAR
WAS THAT WE- GOT THE SEASONALS
THE SAME AMOUNT. THIS YEAR AS WE
HAD LAST YEAR WE JUST GOT HIM A
LITTLE BIT EARLY THAT'S IT WE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL HELP
THIS YEAR NONE LAST YEAR IT WAS
IT'S ALL THE MONEY'S GOING TO
PREVENTION OF VERY LITTLE IS
GOING TO THE DEPARTMENT WE NEED
TO CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC THERE'S
ENOUGH MONEY THERE'S A HUGE
SURPLUS. AS WE'VE READ ABOUT- IN
THE BUDGET COMING UP WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE TAKE CARE OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TWENTY FIVE WE'VE AHEAD.
SURE MEMBERS DANIEL BRADHAM OF
THE CLUB CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE THE AND THAT THAT THE
GUY AND THE LEAD IT'S MADE AND
COMMUNITY HARMING AND DEFENSIBLE
SPACE WORK WE KNOW THAT BE ARE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO SAVE
LIVES AND PROPERTY DURING A
WILDFIRE. THEREFORE WE BELIEVE
THAT FUNDING FOR FUEL REDUCTION
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE CURRENT MILE
BAND AND THEN THE WAY WE- SHOULD
BE TIED TO FUNDING THAT ENSURE
THAT A CRITICAL MASS OF HOMES
AND NEARBY COMMUNITIES. ARE HARD
AND HAVE SUFFICIENT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE THAT SO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE IS SPENDING MONEY. IT'S
MONEY. AND WAYS THAT ARE DARREN
TO MAKE COMMUNITIES SAFER DURING
INCREASINGLY COMMON WIND DRIVEN
FIRES. WHEN THE STATE IS
SPENDING MONEY IN THE WILDLAND
FOR ECOLOGICAL PURPOSES IT
SHOULD PRIORITIZE MANAGEMENT
THAT WILL PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND CLOSELY MIMIC
NATURAL WILDFIRES. IN THE
NORTHERN PART STORAGE TO STAY
SHOULD PRIORITIZE PRESCRIBE AND
MANAGE FIRES. FINALLY WE HEARD A
LOT TODAY ABOUT BIOENERGY AND
WHAT PRODUCT PRODUCTS WHICH DAY
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING NON
EMITTING USAGE FOR BIOMASS
ADDITIONALLY THE STATE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THE BIOMASS
UTILIZATION PROJECTS THAT
BENEFIT FROM PUBLIC FUNDING. ARE
ACTUALLY USING BIOMASS BUT IT'S
COMING OUT OF THE FOREST AS A
RESULT OF ACTIVITIES THAT WILL
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY OR
COLLEGE. THE STATE CURRENTLY
SOURCES RATEPAYERS TO PURCHASE
ENERGY FROM BIOMASS FACILITIES
AT EXORBITANT PRICES IN THE BIO
GRAHAM PROGRAM. YET THESE
FACILITIES BURN ALMOST ENTIRELY
COMMERCIAL MOCKING WASTE WHICH
IS NOT REMOVED FOR WILDFIRE.
MITIGATION OR PUBLIC SAFETY.
NEEDLESS TO SAY THE IS NOT GREAT
TAX. OR GIGI R. AFTER SHOULD BE
SPENT CAN YOU. TO WORKING WITH
THAT COMMITTEE- YEP WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ADDRESS THESE CRITICAL ISSUES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS. PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU
HAVE ABOUT THREE MORE COMMON
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI LINE EIGHTEEN COULD NOT BE
HEARD IN COMMITTEE YEAH I HAD
SOME PROBLEMS CALLING AND
PLEASE- AT LEAST RIGHT I'M GLAD
TO SEE- I WILL PROCEED WITH MY
VERY GENEROUS TWO MINUTES. I AM
GLAD TO SEE THAT YOU FINALLY
DECIDED TO HAVE THIS MUCH NEEDED
HEARING AFTER CANCELING THE
AUGUST EIGHTEENTH HEARING WITH
ALMOST NO NOTICE I AM CALLING AS
A DISPLACED PERSON FROM THE
TUBBS FIRE WHICH TOOK PLACE IN
OCTOBER SEVENTEEN. AS A RESULT
OF TO HELP MY FAMILY OF SIX
INCLUDING FOUR CHILDREN WERE
FORCED TO RELOCATE LOCATE FROM
SELLING COUNTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WHERE WE LIVE FOR NOW THE GIVEN
THE PREVENTABLE AN ONGOING
SITUATION WITH THESE GENOCIDAL
FIRED. WE THANK ALL THE TIME
ABOUT LEAVING CALIFORNIA
PERMANENTLY AS ANY NUMBER OF HER
FRIENDS ARE OUR TOP WHO HAVE
SIMILARLY BEEN IMPACTED BY THESE
FIRES IF GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAD
MADE WILDFIRE PREVENTION A
PRIORITY FROM. DAY ONE IN OFFICE
AND MANY PROMISES SEN EXEMPTING
THE FOURTH CLEAN UP AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION PROJECTS FROM SEEK
WHAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
PRIORITY PREWORK REQUISITE IN
ORDER TO PREVENT DEADLY WHAT WHY
DON'T FIRE BUT AT THE MOMENT
NEWSOME IS APPARENTLY ON THE
EAST COAST ON A BOOK PROMOTING
TOUR. THIS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF THE ON GOING UNACCEPTABLE
BEHAVIOR OF THIS GOVERNOR IT HAS
MANY OF US CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN PROFOUNDLY IMPACTED BY THE
FIRE. WELL THE OTHER ATROCITIES
COMMITTED BY THIS GOVERNOR
WATCHING IN HORROR AS THIS
CORRUPT PEOPLE MAJORITY
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN IN TOTAL
WILL BE THE NEW STUDY'S.
CONCLUSION REMAINS. THANK YOU
FOR TO WIND EIGHT PLEASE CALL.
HELLO MY NAME IS GORDON HE LIAM
THE CHAIRMAN OF REBUILD. .COM
APRIL THE- BURKE TO SPEAK WITH
THE COURT TODAY. AND COMMITTEE
ON THIS AND TOPIC- OVER THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS CALIFORNIA. TIMBER
HARVESTING INDUSTRY HAS SHRUNK
FROM HARVESTING SIXTY BILLION
BOARD FEET OF TIMBER PER YEAR TO
LESS THAN ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
POOR TREAT THEN THAT PART AND
PARCEL DUE TO THE OVER
REGULATION AND THE COPS OVERLY
COMPLICATED PERMITTING PROCESS.
WHICH WAS DISCUSSED TODAY- THAT
YOU KNOW SOME LINK BUT YOU KNOW
I HAVE TO ASK THE BOARD WERE YOU
HAPPY WITH THE ANSWERS THAT YOU
WERE GIVEN BECAUSE WHAT I HEARD
WAS A LOT OF BUREAUCRATIC
SIDESTEPPING REGARDING THIS
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW THE SOLUTION LIES. TO BRING
BACK INCREASED LOGGING IN
IMPRESSIVE REGULATIONS THAT
PREVENT CONTROLLED BURNS BRING
BACK BIOMASS POWER STATIONS AS
WELL AS DISCUSS- DURING THIS
MEETING AND EXTEND TAX CREDITS
TO INCENTIVIZE. CONSTRUCTION OF
NEW LUMBER MILLS- YOU KNOW I
JUST. HAVE TO MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED EARLIER IF YOU COULD
NOT BELIEVE IT WAS. YEP WHEN IT
WOULD ASKED- COUNTING ACRE FEET-
BUT BUREAUCRATIC ANSWER WAS WAS
GIVEN AND THE ANSWER WAS IT IS
ABOUT DEVELOPING WORKING
ENVIRONMENT FOR PEOPLE AND
CULTURAL ISSUES AND NOT
NECESSARILY ABOUT ACRE FEET AND
I. KNOW THAT I'M NOT HAPPY WITH
THAT ANSWER AND I DON'T THINK
THE BOARD. EITHER I THANK THE
PROP ANSWER BE WE WANT TO SEE
RESULTS FOR OUR TAXPAYER MONEY
AND WE WANT S. B. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS SIR. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OUR LAST
COMMENT FROM NINE THIRTY PLEASE
CALL AT. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
CHERYL W. I'M A FORMER COUNCIL
MEMBER OF THE CITY OF BERKELEY
AND FOUNDER OF THE CRIME
EMERGENCY MOBILIZATION CAPS FOR-
PLEASE PRIORITIZE INDIGENOUS
VOICES THAT INDIGENOUS LANDS.
AND STOP OLD GROWTH- STOP IN
DOWN OLD GROWTH TREES AND
REDWOODS SAVE OUR TREES- STOP
CLEAR CUTTING AND THEN ALSO STOP
DEFORESTATION DECLARE A CLIMBER
AND EMERGENCY AND REMEMBER OUR
ON HOW COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY OKAY THE AND- ALL
THE BRAND NAME OF WILD- MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE- WHAT THEY
NEED TO THRIVE AND NEEDS AT
WHILE THEY'RE OUTSIDE. AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOU DO AND HAPPY
HOLIDAYS. THANK YOU SAME TO YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE OPERATOR WE
WILL- BE ADJOURNING NOW WANT TO
WISH EVERYONE HAPPY HOLIDAYS
WILL RETURN AFTER THE FIRST OF
THE YEAR TO CONTINUE OUR
IMPORTANT- OVERSIGHT WORK AND
UNTIL THEN. WE ARE ADJOURNED.